ओके। सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव।
ओके। लेट मी चेक वंस। मुझे आप कंफर्म कर
दीजिए सभी लोग। इफ आई एम ऑडिबल।
इफ आई एम क्लियरली ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल।
प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए। मैं एक बार चेक मैं
एक बार क्रॉस चेक भी कर लेता हूं।
ओके
यस लेट मी चेक द ऑडियो हियर एक बार ऑडियो
चेक कर लेते हैं
25 पीपल आर ऑलरेडी हियर
एक बार ऑडियो चेक कर लेते है
आई थिंक एवरीथिंग इज गुड
ओके सो गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू गुड इवनिंग
अ वेरी वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ
अ या ये हैशटग इसलिए आ रहे हैं क्योंकि
जैसे नंबर वन हैशटग का मतलब है कि आप सबसे
ज्यादा एक्टिव रहे हैं इस चैनल के ऊपर में
स्पेशली इन लाइव सेक्शन में लाइव में भी
आप काफी एक्टिव रहते हैं तो आपको हैशटग वन
का जो है वो खिताब मिला है। सो थैंक यू
एंड वेलकम एवरीबॉडी टू अनदर सेशन ऑफ़ बग
बंटीज। मुझे पता है काफी लेट हुआ है। काफी
डिले हुआ है इस बार एंड काफी टाइम बाद जो
है हम मिल रहे हैं इस पर्टिकुलर सेशन में
जिसमें कि हम नेक्स्ट एक टॉपिक लेकर आ रहे
हैं जिसका नाम है सेशन रिलेटेड वनेबिलिटीज
एंड उसको हम एक्सप्लोर करने वाले हैं। बट
यहां अ आई होप कि आप सभी ठीक होंगे। आप सब
अभी तक वो जो आपकी जो एक एंथूजियाज्म थी
एक एक जोश था बग बंटीज को लेके वो वीडियोस
ना आ पाने के कारण कम नहीं हुई होगी मेरे
ख्याल से क्योंकि वीडियो का ना आना
डायरेक्टली प्रोपोर्शनल नहीं होना चाहिए
आपके जोश से वीडियोस इतने पड़े हैं अभी बग
बाउंटी के सीरीज में हमारे इतने पड़े हैं
इतने टॉपिक्स हैं इतने जो है ना वोबिलिटीज
को हमने डिस्कस करी है कि अगर आप उन सबको
एक-एक करके मास्टर करना शुरू करेंगे तो
आपको काफी ज्यादा टाइम टाइम लग जाएगा।
बिलीव मी। एंड काफी लोगों ने ऐसा किया है।
बाउंटज़ लगी है। काफी लोगों के Lindin पे
आप जाके देख सकते हैं। अब आज भी अब भी
लाइक हमने कब की ट्रेनिंग ये स्टार्ट करी
थी बग बंटीज की। एंड लोगों को अब
धीरे-धीरे इसका आउटकम दिख रहा है।
धीरे-धीरे जो है उनको बंटीज, कॉल ऑफ फेम,
रिवॉर्ड्स वगैरह मिलनी स्टार्ट हो चुकी
है। कई लोगों ने Lindin पे पोस्ट करा है।
एंड मुझे इस बात का बहुत प्राउड है
क्योंकि हमने ये चीज एकदम फ्री में
स्टार्ट करी थी इस ट्रेनिंग को एंड 55
वीडियोस 55 क्लासेस हमने कंप्लीट करा है।
ये 56th क्लास है। हालांकि इन सेशंस में
अब हमारे पास बहुत ज्यादा टॉपिक्स बग
बाउंटज में बहुत ज्यादा टॉपिक्स नहीं बच
गए हैं। कुछ टॉपिक्स बचे हैं बस। दैट्स
इट। एंड इसी के साथ हम कुछ और चीजें भी
स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं। मैं आपको इसी आज
के सेशन में बताने वाला हूं। तो आज सेशन
में आपको नई-नई चीजें एंड कुछ एक्साइटिंग
चीजें भी पता चलेंगी। फर्स्ट थिंग कि बग
माउंट के साथ एक और चीज स्टार्ट करने की
मैंने सोची है। एंड वो है एसओसी लेवल वन।
एसओसी एल वन बेसिकली यू कैन से। तो एसओसी
हमने स्टार्ट करने की सोची है। एंड कई
लोगों की डिमांड थी कि ब्रिंग द एसओसी
ट्यूटोरियल्स। एसओसी सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन
सेंटर कई लोग एसओसी के बारे में ऑलरेडी
जानते होंगे। एसओसी की जॉब्स की
रिक्वायरमेंट्स की बहुत ज्यादा डिमांड है।
रिक्वायरमेंट्स बहुत हैं एसओसी के। हर
कंपनी को एसओसी चाहिए आज के टाइम में। वो
अलग बात है। अब एआई का टाइम आ चुका है तो
लाइक एसओसी विद ए आर प्रेफरिंग। बट स्टिल
यू नीड टू बी लर्निंग एसओसी एंड कई लोग जो
है स्टार्टिंग साइबर सिक्योरिटी डोमेन में
एसओसी से करते हैं। एंड देन धीरे-धीरे वो
स्विच करते हैं, अपग्रेड करते हैं। राइट?
एकदम बढ़िया हाल है मेरा। बढ़िया हाल है।
आई होप आप भी ठीक होंगे।
गॉड जॉब इन प्रीति कुमारी इस सेइंग गॉड
जॉब इन एमएनसी एंड आई हैव रेफर्ड योर
वीडियोस ऑफलाइन। थैंक यू। ओके। अ ग्रेट
ग्रेट ग्रेट प्रीति। अह कांग्रेचुलेशंस अह
ऑन योर लाइक अह सिलेक्शन एंड एंड आई एम
रियली मतलब मुझे काफ़ी प्राउड फ़ील होता है।
काफ़ी ज़्यादा फ़ील होता है। अगर मैं अभी
जैसे प्रीति कुमारी इनका एमएसी में कोई
प्लेसमेंट हुआ है। इन्होंने
रेफर किया है वीडियोस को तो आई जस्ट लव
इट। आई लव इट। ऐसे अगर आप कहीं पे रेफर कर
रहे हो, कहीं पे लोगों को बता रहे हो। इन
वीडियोस से कुछ सिखा भी रहे हो। इनफैक्ट
आप मेरी वीडियोस का यूज़ करके दूसरों को
सिखा भी सकते हो। सो आई डोंट माइंड दैट।
एंड मैं यहां पे आपको कुछ बोलने नहीं जा
रहा उसके लिए। ठीक है? चलिए कंसिस्टेंसी
अब आएगी। बिल्कुल सही बात है। कंसिस्टेंसी
थोड़ी टूट गई थी। उसके लिए एक्सट्रीमली
सॉरी फ्रॉम माय साइड। रियली सॉरी क्योंकि
वो थोड़ी सी गड़बड़ हो गई थी। बट अब जो है
वो कंसिस्टेंसी मेंटेन रहेगी। तो चलिए
स्टार्ट करने से पहले सबसे पहले हम आ जाते
हैं Lindin पेज पे। तो ये हमारा Lindin
पेज है। ये Lindin प्रोफाइल है मेरा। आप
आके यहां पे मुझे फॉलो कर सकते हैं।
lindin.com
technical naविat। हियर यू कैन फॉलो मी
10,000 से ज्यादा लोगों ने यहां पे मेरे
से कनेक्ट कनेक्शन रखा हुआ है। आप भी
कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। एंड उसके बाद यहां पे
मैं बात करूं डिफ़्रॉनिक्स की तो
डिफ्रॉनिक्स का पेज है हमारा। इस
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स हमारी कंपनी का पेज है। इसको
आप फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। Lindin.com कंपनी
dfनिक्स। यहां पे लगभग 18,000 फॉलोवरर्स
हैं डिफ्रॉनिक्सर्स जुड़े हुए हैं। आपको
कंपनी से रिलेटेड सारी अपडेट्स एंड
एवरीथिंग विल गेटिंग बी हियर। यहां पे
हमारा Instagram पेज है डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी
नाम से जहां 500 से भी ज्यादा जो है
फॉलोवर्स हैं। यहां पे आपको साइबर
सिक्योरिटी रिलेटेड एंड अदर वीडियोस जो है
मिल जाती हैं। एंड यह हमारा Twitter पेज
है टीम डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी x.com dfonic
accडमी जहां 500 प्लस पीपल आर हियर। सो यू
कैन जस्ट फॉलो अस हियर आल्सो। एंड वेबसाइट
के बारे में तो आपको पता ही होगा
डिफ़्रोनिक्स.com एंड दैट्स इट। उसके बाद
accडमी पे आके हमारे कोर्सर्सेस को आप
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। चलिए अब
बग बाउंट की हमारी ये सेशन को स्टार्ट
करेंगे। उसके पहले मैं आपको बस एक चीज
बताना चाहता हूं। कई लोग जो है कई लोग
मेरे से कई बार पूछते आ रहे थे कि मैं कौन
सा बग बाउंट के लिए वीपीएस यूज़ करता हूं।
तो मैं आपको सिंपली बता देना चाहता हूं।
एंड एक जो है आपको उसका एक बेनिफिट भी दे
दूंगा साथ ही में साथ ही में। तो मैं जो
वीpएस यूज़ करता हूं, मैं इंटेक DC का
वीpएस यूज़ करता हूं। आप लोगों ने पहले भी
यह पोर्टल देखा होगा हमारी पहले बग बंटी
के वीडियोस में। तो मैं यहां पे Inte DC
की VPS यूज़ करता हूं। मैं एक सेकंड
मैं यहां पे लॉग इन कर लेता हूं।
सो आई यूज़ दिस वीपीएस इंटेक डीसी वाली।
यहां पे मैं अगर आपको सर्विसेस में दिखाऊं
तो मैं ये जनरल क्लाउड VPS V6 यूज़ करता
हूं इनका। ये वाली मशीन जो है। ठीक है? सो
यहां पे आपने ये चीज़ पहले भी देखी होगी।
int DC का मैं इसलिए आपको बता रहा हूं।
इसका रीज़न एक रीज़न प्रॉपर रीज़न क्या है?
मैं आपको बता देता हूं। क्योंकि सबसे पहली
चीज़ यह मैं खुद यूज़ करता हूं। दूसरी चीज़
इनका प्राइसिंग काफी अफोर्डेबल है। तीसरी
चीज़ हमने जब प्रीवियस वीडियोस में जब
प्रीवियस वीडियोस में अह कई ऐसे वीडियोस
में इनका मेंशन किया था क्योंकि मैं पहले
से यूज़ कर रहा था बहुत पहले से। तो
इन्होंने मुझे रीच आउट किया था कि हम आपको
स्पॉन्सर करना चाहते हैं। याद रखिएगा दिस
इज़ नॉट अ पेड एडवर्टाइजमेंट। दिस इज़ अ
स्पॉन्सर्ड अ वीडियो। तो ये स्पॉन्सर
इन्होंने करा यहां पे आके। एंड स्पॉनसर
करके इन्होंने बोला कि हम आपको जो है आपके
स्टूडेंट्स के लिए लर्नर्स के लिए कूपन
कोड देंगे। तो मैंने बोला दे दो भाई दे
दो। बहुत लोगों को चाहिए होता है कूपन
कोड। एंड इनका सपोर्ट काफी अच्छा है। मतलब
जब आप वीpएस ले लोगे जब आपको वीपीएस में
किसी तरह का कोई इशू आएगा तो यू विल बी
गेटिंग ग्रेट सपोर्ट। यहां जो मेरी मशीन
है 4GB रैम एंड टू कोर मशीनंस की है। तो
मेरा काम इसमें हो जाता है। आपका जिसमें
भी हो आप सिंपली int dc.com पे आके कोई भी
वीpएस प्लान चूज़ कर सकते हैं। मेरा ये
जनरल क्लाउड VPS वाले प्लान है। इसमें आप
आएंगे तो आप Windows एंड Linx दोनों VPS
यूज़ कर सकते हैं। मैं Linux VPS यूज़ कर
रहा हूं। ये वाला Linux VPS i49 पर मंथ
वाली। इसमें मेरा दो कोर का CPU है, 4 GB
का रैम है। 500 GB की SSD है एंड 4
टेराबाइट का बैंडविथ है जो कि इनफ होता
है। वन डेडिकेटेड IP आपको यहां पे इसमें
मिल जाती है। एंड बहुत ही शानदार है। आप
सिंपली आप यहां गेट स्टार्टेड कर दीजिएगा।
गेट स्टार्टेड करने के बाद
जब आप इस पे आएंगे तो मैं आपको यहां पे
आपका बेनिफिट करा दूंगा। देखो इसमें इस
चीज में मेरा कोई बेनिफिट नहीं है। जैसे
आपको यहां पे सिंपल यूज़ करना है
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
20। ये कूपन कोड यूज़ करना है। दैट्स इट।
तो इन्होंने मुझे कूपन कोड दिया है
स्टूडेंट्स एंड लर्नर्स के लिए कि जिनको
फर्स्ट मंथ पे 20% का डिस्काउंट ये दे रहे
हैं। दैट्स इट। फर्स्ट मंथ पे 20% का
डिस्काउंट। तो यहां पे मैंने सबमिट किया।
जैसे ही सबमिट आप करोगे। सो यहां पे आपका
कूपन अप्लाई। यहां पे कूपन अप्लाई लिख रहा
है कि कैन नॉट बी अप्लाई। क्योंकि मैं
लॉगिन हूं ऑलरेडी। मैं अगर आपको बिना
लॉगिन वाले अकाउंट पे लेके चलूं तब आप जो
है यहां पे इसको देख पाएंगे इस कूपन को।
तो मैं यहां पे दूसरे ब्राउज़र पे चल लेता
हूं ताकि आपको क्लियर यहां पे दिख जाए।
कोई सा भी आप प्लान चूज कर सकते हैं। डजंट
मैटर व्हाटएवर प्लान यू नीड टू जो भी आपके
यूज़ के अकॉर्डिंग हो। मेरा जो है जिसमें
हो जाता है मैंने वही प्लान यूज़ किया
Linux VPS i4 का दोज़ कोर CPU एंड 4GB RAM
इसमें आप सिंपली जाएंगे गेट स्टार्टेड पे
जाएंगे आप यहां पे
देन दैट्स इट। यहां पे आ जाना है। एंड
यहां पे आप यूज़ कर लीजिएगा डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
20 तो इन्होंने स्पोंसर किया तो मैं
स्पॉनसरशिप मैंने इसका ले लिया। इसको
एक्सेप्ट कर लिया स्पोंसरशिप ताकि आप
लोगों का भी कुछ बेनिफिट हो। एंड यहां पे
इनकी सर्विस एक्चुअली काफी अच्छी है।
डिफरेंश 20 यूज़ कीजिएगा 20% फर्स्ट मंथ पे
आपका डिस्काउंट मिल जाएगा। याद रखिएगा। तो
यहां पे आपको 999 जो है वो 799 का हो
जाएगा। 799 में 4 GB रैम दो कोर CPU एंड
ये सब जो कॉन्फ़िगरेशन है वो जनरली जनरली
आपको नहीं मिलेगी शायद। ये काफी मतलब काफी
अफोर्डेबल भी है। इनका सर्व इनका जो डाटा
सेंटर है वो इंडिया में लोकेटेड है। तो
आपको स्पीड भी काफी अच्छी मिलेगी। बग
बाउंटज़ कर सकते हैं आप इसमें। ऐसे ऐसा कोई
ब्लॉकेज का कोई झंझ हां बहुत ज्यादा मलिशस
एक्टिविटी मत कीजिएगा। नहीं तो फिर उसके
उस उसमें तो कुछ भी हो सकता है।
पॉसिबिलिटी है। राइट? तो यहां पे ये आपको
मजा आएगा। एक महीना आप ट्राई करके देख
सकते हैं। आप 1 महीने के बाद जब ट्राई
करके आपको अगर अच्छा लगे तो आप नेक्स्ट
मंथ कंटिन्यू कर सकते हैं। राइट? सो यू
कैन गो विथ दैट। ओके? मैं यह नहीं बोल रहा
कि आपको लेना ही लेना है। आपको मैंडेटरी
है ही लेना है। ऐसा नहीं है। बट यह मुझे
काफी अच्छा लगता है। एंड मैं यूज़ कर रहा
हूं। तो मैंने आपको एक डिस्काउंट कोड भी
दे दिया। यू कैन जस्ट यूटिलाइज़ दिस
डिस्काउंट कोड एंड यू कैन यूज़ दिस वीपीएस
फॉर बग बाउंटज़। क्योंकि अब आपका लेवल उस
टाइप का हो चुका होगा। काफी जो पुराने बग
बाउंट हंटर्स हैं क्योंकि वीपीएस में
स्विच करना चाहते होंगे। तो यू कैन गेट
दिस पर्टिकुलर वीपीएस। ओके? थैंक यू सो
मच। चलिए अब जल्दी से आ जाते हैं हमारे
मेन टॉपिक पे एंड वी आर गोइंग टू
सी सेशन मैनेजमेंट सेशन वनेबिलिटीज़। सेशन
वनेबिलिटीज़ के ऊपर हम डिस्कशन करने वाले
हैं। एंड ये काफी एक इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक है
आप सबके लिए क्योंकि सेशन रिलेटेड
वनेबिलिटीज़ हमेशा P1, P2 या क्रिटिकल हाई
अह जो है सीिवियरिटी में आती है। एंड सेशन
हाईजैकिंग की बात करें, सेशन फिक्सेशन की
बात करें ये सब इसी के अंदर में आ जाता
है। एंड दिस इज़ रियली रियली ग्रेट अह टू
टू गो थ्रू एंड टू हैव नॉलेज। क्योंकि ये
जो वनेबिलिटीज है ये आपको वैसे तो पता
नहीं चलेगी बट आपको जब तक कोर चीजें कैसे
सर्वर जो है किस तरीके से क्लाइंट सर्वर
से इंटरेक्ट कर रहा है। किस तरीके से
ऑथराइजेशन ऑन ऑथेंटिकेशन काम करती है। जब
तक उसकी समझ नहीं होगी यू विल नॉट बी
गेटिंग दिस काइंड ऑफ़ वोलेबिलिटी। इसका
आपको समझ में नहीं आने वाला है। अब ये जो
सेशन मैनेजमेंट है ट्राई हैक पे मैं आया
हूं। ये एक पेड प्रीमियम रूम है। ऑब्वियस
सी बात है। अगर आपके पास प्रीमियम नहीं भी
है बिल्कुल बेफिक्र रहिए। मैं आपको एक-एक
चीज ऐसे समझाऊंगा कि आपको प्रीमियम लैब की
भी जरूरत शायद ना पड़े। आप रियल वेबसाइट
पे ट्राई कर सकते हैं। जी हां, सेम चीज,
सेम थिंग्स यू कैन गो एंड चेक आउट एंड
प्रैक्टिस ऑन रियल वेबसाइट्स आल्सो या
किसी भी लैब पे भी कर सकते हैं। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। ठीक है? अगर आप नहीं
चाहते हैं प्रीमियम लेना तब। सो यहां पे
हम एक-एक चीज करके बहुत ही इजी वे में,
बहुत ही बहुत ही अच्छे तरीके से इसको
समझेंगे, पढ़ेंगे एंड जानेंगे। बस ध्यान
अपना इधर देखे रखिएगा। कंसंट्रेशन बनाए
रखिएगा। दैट्स इट। मैं आपसे यही चाहता
हूं। ठीक है? चलिए।
ओके। सो
यहां पे कुछ क्वेश्चंस हैं।
डीसीएसबी के नेक्स्ट बैच अनाउंसमेंट आ
जाएगी। जब भी आएगी, आपको अनाउंसमेंट मिल
जाएगी डीसीएसबी की नेक्स्ट बैच की। ठीक
है।
कोई बात नहीं। प्रोग्राम अगर साइन अगर
प्रोग्राम ने फिक्स कर दिया, आपको पेमेंट
नहीं दे रही तो उसमें आप कुछ कर नहीं सकते
हैं। जस्ट इग्नोर दैट प्रोग्राम। आप उस
प्रोग्राम को इग्नोर कर दीजिए। एंड दैट्स
इट। ठीक है?
सर, मैं आपका कोर्स कर रहा हूं। साथ में
रियल टारगेट की नॉलेज नहीं मिल। रियल
टारगेट पे प्रैक्टिस करनी होती है। नॉलेज
बिल्कुल मिलेगी। बिल्कुल मिलेगी। अब मैं
चाहता हूं आपसे कि आप सभी जो है मेरे साथ
कुछ नेक्स्ट कपल ऑफ आ जो आवर्स या कपल ऑफ
मिनट्स आप यू कैन से मेरे साथ रहिए एंड इन
चीजों को समझिए। सबसे पहले हम इंट्रोडक्शन
पार्ट को स्टार्ट कर देते हैं। याद रखिएगा
ट्राईमी का जो हमारा ओपन वीपीए
कनेक्टिविटी है कनेक्शन है उसको भी हम देख
लेंगे अगर आपको चाहिए होगा तो। कई लोगों
का इशूज़ आता है बट आई डोंट थिंक इशू आना
चाहिए। बहुत इजी टू यूज़ होता है।
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल डाउनलोड करो, इंपोर्ट
करो और यूज़ करो। बस सिंपल सा चीज है। यहां
पे इंट्रोडक्शन से स्टार्ट करते हैं। एंड
देखो रूम ट्राई हैक के रूम्स को बहुत
लाइटली आपको नहीं लेना है कि अरे यार ये
तो रूम्स ही तो है। क्या है? यह टॉपिक है
ट्राईकमी के रूम्स सॉल्व कर कर के आप
बड़ी-बड़ी एग्जामिनेशंस को क्रैक कर सकते
हैं। ईजीपीटी ओएसईपी लेवल की एग्जामिनेशंस
को क्रैक कर सकते हैं। हालांकि अब कुछ
एडवांस सर्ट मतलब थोड़े से जब आप अपर लेवल
पे जाएंगे लाइक ओएसईपी के ऊपर अगर जाते
हैं तो वहां पे फिर हैक द बॉक्स वगैरह का
भी यूज़ करना पड़ेगा आपको। एंड और भी
चीजें हैं। बट बिल्डिंग ब्लॉक जो है ना
आपका जो स्टार्टिंग पॉइंट है वो यहीं
ट्राई हैक में होने वाला है। आपके
कंसेप्ट्स को यहीं स्ट्रांग करने वाला है।
दूसरा कुछ नहीं करने वाला आपके कांसेप्ट
को स्ट्रांग। तो इसको इग्नोर नहीं करना है
आपको। जो भी मैं बताऊं उसको समझना है। हो
सके तो नोट्स बनाना। अगर नोट्स बना सको तो
नोट्स बना लीजिएगा। एंड अगर आपने नोट्स
बनाया या इस सेशन से जो भी चीज सीखी उसको
लिंकन पे आके पोस्ट कीजिएगा। डिफ्रॉनिक
साइबर सिक्योरिटी को टैग कर दीजिएगा। वी
विल बी हैप्पी टू सी दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग।
सो लेट्स गो विद द इंट्रोडक्शन।
ठीक है? इन दिस रूम यू विल लर्न अबाउट
सेशन मैनेजमेंट। सेशन के मैनेजमेंट के
बारे में हम सीखेंगे। ठीक है? चलिए और कुछ
भी नहीं है। तो यहां पे हम सिंपल सा इस पे
कुछ नहीं करते। इसको कंप्लीट कर लेते हैं।
इसमें कुछ भी नहीं है। सबसे पहले स्टार्ट
करते हैं। व्हाट इज़ सेशन मैनेजमेंट से?
सेशन मैनेजमेंट से स्टार्ट करते हैं।
बिफोर वी डिस्कस एवरीथिंग वी कैन गो
रॉन्ग। वी नीड टू लर्न अबाउट सेशन
मैनेजमेंट। एज मेंशंड द प्रीविटा यू डोंट
नीड यू डोंट सेंड योर यूजरनेम एंड पासवर्ड
विथ ईच रिक्वेस्ट। हर रिक्वेस्ट के साथ आप
यूजरनेम और पासवर्ड सेंड नहीं करते हो। जब
भी आप किसी सर्वर से इंटरेक्ट करते हो
सर्वर से ऑथेंटिकेट करते हो ना जैसे मान
लो Google में जाके लॉग इन किया, Facebook
में जाके लॉग इन किया तो हर बार आप
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड नहीं डालते हो। राइट?
आपने एक बार लॉग इन कर लिया। आप अंदर चले
गए। वापस से आपने ब्राउज़र वगैरह वो सब बंद
किया। वापस से जब आप Facebook ओपन करोगे
तो ऑलरेडी लॉग्ड इन मिलोगे। ऑलरेडी आपको
एक पेज होम पेज जो है वहां पे सामने मिल
जाती है। राइट? ये आप सब ने नोटिस किया
होगा। सबने देखा होगा। अब देखिए ये देखने
में कितना इजी लग रहा है। बट इसके बीच के
प्रोसेससेस इतने कॉम्प्लेक्स मतलब इतने
छोटे-छोटे और माइन्यूट अ प्रोसेससेस हैं
जो बैक एंड में चल रहे हैं। बट आपको समझ
नहीं आ रहा। वो चीज़ आप नहीं समझेंगे। तो
सेशन रिलेटेड वनेबिलिटीज़ फाइंड कैसे
करेंगे? सेशन हाईकिंग सेशन फिक्सेशन कैसे
करेंगे? आपने ये तो देख लिया कि यूटर्स का
अकाउंट हैक हो जाता है। बट क्यों हैक हो
रहा है? कैसे हैक हो रहा? कई लोगों के
सेशंस कम कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो गए। कैसे हो गए?
उसका नॉलेज तो लेना पड़ेगा ना। उसका नॉलेज
नहीं लोगे तो कैसे काम चलेगा? तो वो नॉलेज
कई लोग इन चीजों से भागते हैं। देखो इन
चीजों से भागोगे तो कभी भी आप एक
सक्सेसफुल बग हंटर नहीं बन पाओगे। आप एक
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट नहीं बन पाओगे।
क्योंकि आपको लगेगा कि बस मुझे ना कुछ
वलेबिलिटीज़ फाइंड कर लेनी है। कुछ एक दो
चीजें कर लेनी है। एंड दैट्स इट। मैं तो
बस इसी में खुश हो गया। तभी मुझे मजा आएगा
जब मैं कुछ वनेबिलिटीज़ फाइंड करके रिवॉर्ड
या बाउंड्रीज़ ले लूं। बट बात ये है कि
वनेबिलिटीज मिलेगी कब? द थिंग इज कि
वनेबिलिटीज मिलेगी कब? जब आपको कांसेप्ट
पता होगा, एग्जीक्यूशन पता होगा,
मेथोडोलॉजी पता होगा, लॉजिक पता होगा। तो
वही चीज तो सीखते हैं हम इन चीजों से।
चलिए। सो
मैं यहां पे ऑडियो वॉल्यूम एक बार चेक कर
लेता हूं। इफ द वॉल्यूम इज़
करेक्ट।
या, वॉल्यूम इज़ गुड। चलिए। सो
यहां पे द एचटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल इज
इनहेरेंटली स्टेटलेस।
ठीक है? सेशंस आर देयर फॉर यूज्ड टू सेशंस
आर देयर फॉर यूज्ड टू ट्रैक यूज़र्स थ्रूउ
देयर यूज़ ऑफ ए वेब एप्लीकेशन। ठीक है?
स्टेटलेस प्रोटोकॉल होता है आपका जो
एचटीडीp होता है। बेसिकली कोई ट्रैकिंग
नहीं कुछ नहीं। सेशंस का यूज़ किया जाता है
यूज़र्स को ट्रैक करने के लिए थ्रू आउट
देयर यूज़ ऑफ़ वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस। वेब
एप्लीकेशनेशंस को जो भी यूज़ करते हैं जो
भी यूज़र्स हैं उनके यूसेस को ट्रैक करने
के लिए सेशंस का यूज़ किया जाता है। सेशन
मैनेजमेंट इज़ द प्रोसेस ऑफ़ मैनेजिंग दीज़
सेशंस एंड इंश्योरिंग दैट देयर रिमेन
सिक्योर। सेशन मैनेजमेंट इसी को सिक्योर
करने का एक तरीका होता है। जैसे आप कोई
चीज ब्राउज़ कर रहे हैं, कोई चीज ओपन कर
रहे हैं तो उस समय उस ब्राउजिंग एंड उस
ओपनिंग में जो भी
आपका जो प्रोसेस है जो पूरा का पूरा उस
प्रोसेस को मैनेज करना एंड उसको सिक्योर
बना के रखना सेशन मैनेजमेंट का काम है। अब
देखो सेशन मैनेजमेंट में चार साइकिल्स
यहां पे आपको मिलेंगे। फोर साइकिल्स आर
देयर जहां पे सेशन मैनेजमेंट सस जिसको हम
बोलते हैं सेशन मैनेजमेंट सल्स। सेशन
क्रिएशन, सेशन ट्रैकिंग, सेशन टाइम आउट,
सेशन टर्मिनेशन। सबसे पहले सेशन क्रिएशन
होता है। फिर सेशन को ट्रैक भी किया जाता
है। सेशन टाइम आउट होता है। सेशन को
टर्मिनेट कर दिया जाता है। यानी सेशन
टर्मिनेट हो जाता है। ये चार प्रोसेससेस
इनवॉल्वड हैं। अब हम एक-एक करके शॉर्ट में
हालांकि इन सबके ऊपर ना बहुत बड़ी-बड़ी आप
थ्यरीज़ एंड कांसेप्ट्स को पढ़ सकते हैं।
ठीक है? बट इनको हम शॉर्ट में बहुत ही टू
द पॉइंट समझने की कोशिश करते हैं। लास्ट
में प्रैक्टिकल याद रखिएगा। इसमें लास्ट
में लैब है, प्रैक्टिकल्स हैं। उसको भी हम
देखेंगे थोड़ा। सेशन क्रिएशन। सबसे पहले हम
आते हैं सेशन क्रिएशन पे क्या होता है? यू
माइट थिंक दिस इज़ द फर्स्ट स्टेप इन द
लाइफ स लाइफ साइकिल अकर्स ओनली आफ्टर यू
प्रोवाइड योर क्रेडेंशियल्स। ये एक फर्स्ट
स्टेज है जब आप क्रेडेंशियल्स प्रोवाइड
करते हैं। जैसे कि सच ऐज़ यूजरनेम एंड
पासवर्ड। जैसे ही आप यूजरनेम एंड पासवर्ड
डालते हैं, सेशन क्रिएशन शुरू हो जाता है।
हाउएवर ऑन मेनी वेब एप्लीकेशन, द इनिशियल
सेशन इज़ ऑलरेडी क्रिएटेड व्हेन यू विजिट द
एप्लीकेशन। ठीक है? दिस इज़ बिकॉज़ सम
एप्लीकेशन वांट टू ट्रैक योर एकशंस इवन
बिफोर ऑथेंटिकेशन। देखो, यूजुअली होना
क्या चाहिए कि आपके जो भी सेशन है या जो
भी आपका एक्शन है वो जब आप लॉगिन कर लो या
अपने आप को ऑथेंटिकेट कर लो तब ट्रैक होना
चाहिए। बट कई ऐसे एप्लीकेशनेशंस हैं वो
आपको लॉग इन ऑथेंटिकेशन से पहले ही ट्रैक
करना शुरू कर देते हैं। आपकी मूवमेंट को
ट्रैक करते हैं। आपके एक्शंस को ट्रैक
करते हैं। आप वेब एप्लीकेशन पे क्या-क्या
चीजें कर रहे हैं? क्या ओपन कर रहे हैं?
क्या कर रहे हैं? कौन सा पेज ज्यादा ओपन
कर रहे हैं? किस पेज पे ज्यादा टाइम
स्पेंड कर रहे हैं? इन सबकी भी ट्रैकिंग
होती है। वो होता है हमारी ऑथेंटिकेशन से
पहले का। तो कई ऐसे वेब एप्लीकेशन होते
हैं जो ये काम होते करते हैं। कई ऐसे वेब
एप्लीकेशन हैं जब आप ऑथेंटिकेट कर लोगे
खुद को जब आप लॉगिन यूजरनेम पासवर्ड दे
दोगे ऑथेंटिकेशन हो जाएगी तब आपका जो है
सेशन जो है वो मैनेज करना यानी कि सेशन
क्रिएशन शुरू हो जाती है एंड ट्रैकिंग
शुरू होती है। हाउएवर आवर मेन फोकस फॉर
दिस रूम विल बी ऑन ऑथेंटिकेटेड सेशन। बट
इसके लिए हम अभी फिलहाल ऑथेंटिकेटेड सेशन
पे बात करेंगे। नॉट ऑन अन ऑथेंटिकेटेड
सेशन। जो ऑथेंटिकेटेड सेशन है हम उसी के
लिए बात करेंगे। वंस यू प्रोवाइड योर
यूजरनेम एंड पासवर्ड यू रिसीव अ सेशन
वैल्यू दैट इज देन सेंट विद ईच न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट। जैसे ही आप लॉगिन कर लेते हो
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड के साथ आपको एक सेशन की
वैल्यू मिल जाती है। एंड उस वैल्यू को हर
नए रिक्वेस्ट के साथ सेंड की जाती है।
किसको? सर्वर को। और सर्वर उसको मैच करता
है। सर्वर देखता है कि भैया यह सही में
वही यूजर है या नहीं है। अगर वही यूजर है
तो कंटिन्यू करेगा। नहीं है तो वहां सेशन
आपका टर्मिनेट कर दिया जाएगा। सेशन आपका
बंद कर दिया जाएगा। हाउ दी सेशन वैल्यूज़
आर जनरेटेड यूज़्ड एंड स्टर्ड इज़ क्रूशियल
इन सिक्योरिटिंग इन सिक्योरिंग सेशन
क्रिएशन। अब इन्हीं सेशन वैल्यूज़ को कैसे
जनरेट किया जाता है? कैसे यूज़ किया जाता
है? कैसे स्टोर किया जाता है? यही पूरा
प्रोसेस है सेशन मैनेजमेंट का। एंड इन्हीं
प्रोसेससेस में जब कोई मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशन
होती है, जब कोई प्रॉब्लम्स आती हैं, जब
किसी तरह का कोई ऐसी पॉलिसी जो सही से
कॉन्फ़िगर नहीं की गई है, देन वहां सेशन को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया जाता है। सेशन
हाईजैकिंग कर ली जाती है। सेशन
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया जाता है। एंड सेशन
वनेबिलिटीज़ वहीं पे अराइज़ होती है। यह हो
गया सेशन क्रिएशन। अब बात करते हैं सेशन
ट्रैकिंग की। आपने ऑथेंटिकेट कर लिया है।
अब आपकी ट्रैकिंग होगी। जो भी चीज करोगे
ट्रैक किए जाओगे। जो जो पेज खोलोगे ट्रैक
किए जाओगे। जबजब जोज चीजें करोगे ट्रैक
किए जाओगे। वंस यू रिसीव योर सेशन वैल्यू
दिस इज़ सबमिटेड विद ईच न्यू रिक्वेस्ट। हर
नया रिक्वेस्ट जो सर्वर से आप बनाओगे ना
उसके साथ इस सेशन वैल्यू को सबमिट की जाती
है। आपके कुछ नया बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
कॉनंसेप्ट्स यहां पे क्लियर होने वाले
हैं। याद रखिएगा इस चीज़ पे थोड़ा फोकस
कीजिए। आप लोग चैट से बाहर आके आप लोग इस
पे फोकस कीजिए। आपको बहुत ज्यादा मजा
आएगा। जब आप कांसेप्ट्स को समझेंगे ना आप
डेली लाइफ में इसको यूज़ करते हैं। बट आपको
अभी तक समझ में नहीं आता होगा। मतलब आप
डेली जो भी आप वेबसाइट्स हैं जो भी वेब
पेजेस ब्राउज़ करते हैं जो भी लॉग इन लॉगउ
करते हैं ना सब जगह ये यूज़ हो रहा है।
लाइव मैं आपको डेमोंस्ट्रेट करके भी
दिखाऊंगा कि कैसे कहां पे यूज़ हो रहा है।
किस तरीके से आप देख सकते हैं हर एक
रिक्वेस्ट को वो सब देखेंगे। बट इसको
अच्छे से समझिएगा। तभी आपको मजा आएगा।
नहीं तो फिर आपको शायद मजा
ना
ओके।
दिस अलाउस द वेब एप्लीकेशन टू ट्रैक योर
एक्शन इवन दो द एचटीटीp प्रोटोकॉल इज
स्टेटलेस इन नेचर स्टेटलेस प्रोटोकॉल होता
है। इवन दो जब आपका सेशन वैल्यू है उसके
थ्रू आपके हर एक्शन को ट्रैक किया जा सकता
है। विथ ईच रिक्वेस्ट मेड द वेब एप्लीकेशन
कैन रिकवर द सेशन वैल्यू फ्रॉम द
रिक्वेस्ट। वेब एप्लीकेशन उस रिक्वेस्ट से
सेशन वैल्यू को रिकवर कर लेता है। यानी कि
उसको ढूंढ लेता है। परफॉर्म अ सर्वर साइड
लुकअप टू अंडरस्टैंड हु द सेशन बिलोंग्स
टू एंड ये सर्वर साइड लुक अप करता है कि
ये सेशन भाई किसको बिलोंग करता है? कौन है
इस सेशन का ओनर? कौन था?
एंड व्हाट परमिशन दे हैव एंड उसको किस चीज
की परमिशन है? अब देखो ऐसा भी हो सकता है
कि जो ऑथेंटिकेटेड यूजर है उसको एक
पर्टिकुलर सेगमेंट एक्सेस करने का जो है
ना राइट है। पर्टिकुलर सेगमेंट एक्सेस
करने का उसका परमिशन है। एंड दूसरा एक और
सेगमेंट है उसको एक्सेस करने का परमिशन
नहीं है। ऐसा भी होता है। एंड ये बहुत
बड़ा ब्लंडर हो जाता है कई बार कि एक
ऑथेंटिकेटेड यूजर कभी-कभी उन चीजों को
एक्सेस कर लेता है जो उसके लिए परमिसबल
नहीं है। जिसके लिए वो परमिटेड है ही
नहीं। एंड दिस इज अ ब्लंडर। दिस इज अ
सिक्योरिटी मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन। यानी इस तरह
की ही चीजों को समझने के लिए आपको यह
समझना पड़ेगा। यानी एक बार यह समझ जाओगे
तो मैं गारंटी देता हूं कि जब आप नेक्स्ट
बग बंटीज या हंटिंग वगैरह करोगे तो आप
सेशन वनेबिलिटीज के ऊपर जरूर हंट करोगे
क्योंकि आपको ऐसे वनेबिलिटीज जो है ना
मिलने के चांसेस होते हैं। ऐसा नहीं है।
कई लोग इसको छोड़ देते हैं। इग्नोर मार
देते हैं। अरे यार ऐसी वनेबिलिटीज़ कहां
मिलेगी यार दूसरे? नहीं ऐसा नहीं है। हर
एप्लीकेशन के साथ चेक आउट करना है।
बड़ी-बड़ी एप्लीकेशन कंपनीज़ के साथ यह
प्रॉब्लम्स हुई है। कोई अलग-अलग सबडोमेनस
पे यह प्रॉब्लम्स हुई हैं। तो आपको चेक
आउट तो जरूर करना है। जब आप नेक्स्ट टाइम
वनेबिलिटीज़ के लिए हंट करें। जब नेक्स्ट
टाइम आप बग बाउंट करें, तो इसको अपने चेक
लिस्ट में डाल लीजिए। एंड इस पे ट्राई
जरूर कीजिएगा।
इन द इवेंट दैट देयर आर इशूज़ इन द सेशन
ट्रैकिंग प्रोसेस। इट मे अलऊ अ थ्रेट
एक्टर टू हाईजैक अ सेशन और इंपपर्सनेट
देम। मतलब अगर कुछ गड़बड़ हुआ, अगर कुछ
गड़बड़ कॉन्फ़िगरेशन हुई, तो ये अलाउ करेगा
किस तरीके का? सेशन को हाईजैक करने का या
सेशन को मेमिक कर लेने का। यानी कि उसी
यूजर के बिहाफ पे लॉगिन करके उसी यूजर के
बिहाफ पे उस सेशन को टेकओवर करके उस सेशन
में जो भी करना है वो करेगा। या तो पूरा
का पूरा सेशन हाईजैक ही कर लिया जाएगा।
ठीक है?
अब आते हैं इसमें चार इसमें जो है ना यह
हम किसको देख रहे हैं अभी? सेशन मैनेजमेंट
साइकिल में सेशन क्रिएशन हमने देखा। सेशन
ट्रैकिंग। अब सेशन यहां पे टाइम आउट यानी
कि सेशन एक्सपायरी की बात हो रही है। सेशन
टाइम आउट बोलिए या एक्सपायरी बोलिए। बात
एक ही है। बिकॉज़ द एच एचtपी प्रोटोकॉल इज़
स्टेटलेस। इट मे हैपन दैट अ यूजर ऑफ़ द वेब
एप्लीकेशन ऑल ऑफ़ अ सडन स्टॉप्स यूजिंग इट।
मतलब ऐसा हो सकता है ना कि आप Facebook
यूज़ कर रहे हो। अचानक से यूज़ करना बंद कर
दिया। ब्राउज़र ही क्लज़ कर दिया। टैब ही
क्लज़ कर दिया। फॉर एग्जांपल यू माइट क्लोज
द टैब और योर एंटायर ब्राउज़र सिंस द
प्रोटोकॉल इज़ स्टेटलेस द वेब एप्लीकेशन
हैज़ नो मेथड टू नो दैट दिस एक्शन हैज़
अकरर्ड। ठीक है? मतलब कि ट्रैकिंग नहीं
होती है। स्टेटलेस प्रोटोकॉल है तो उसको
पता नहीं चलेगा कि भैया हां अरे हां टैब
क्लोज हो गया है या फिर ब्राउज़र क्लोज हो
गई है। उसका तो सेशन चल रहा है। वो तो चल
रहा है अपना जहां चलना है जो भी चल रहा है
बैकग्राउंड में चल रहा है। राइट? सो वेब
एप्लीकेशन इ हैज़ नो मेथड टू नो दैट दिस
एक्शन हैज़ अकर्ड कि आपने भैया टैब क्लोज
किया है। आपने ब्राउज़र क्लोज कर दिया है।
इसका कोई वो नहीं होगा। दिस इज़ व्हेयर द
सेशन एक्सपायरी कम्स इनू प्ले। योर सेशन
वैल्यू इटसेल्फ शुड हैव अ लाइफटाइम अटैच
टू इट। हर सेशन वैल्यू की एक लाइफटाइम
होनी चाहिए। होनी चाहिए। अब कुछ सेशन
वैल्यूज़ की लाइफ टाइम मतलब नहीं होती है।
पर्सिस्टेंट होते हैं। जिसको आप
पर्सिस्टेंट कुकीज़ के बारे में जानते हैं।
अगर कुकीज़ के थ्रू पास होती है। सेशन दो
चीजों के थ्रू पास होती है। कुकीज़ एंड
टोकंस एज अ कुकी वैल्यू एज अ टोकन। दोनों
तरीके दोनों हम डिस्कस करेंगे। दोनों
देखेंगे क्या है? क्या डिफरेंसेस हैं? कौन
सुपीरियर है, क्या कौन इनफीरियर है। योर
सेशन वैल्यू इटसेल्फ शुड हैव अ लाइफटाइम
अटैच्ड। एक वैल्यू होना चाहिए जिसके बाद
भैया उसको बोलना चाहिए कि भैया अब हो गया,
बहुत हो गया। अब इसके बाद मेरे से नहीं
रहा जाएगा। मैं अपने को एक्सपायर कर रहा
हूं। सिक्योरिटी प्रायोरिटी
इफ द लाइफटाइम एक्सपायर्स एंड यू सबमिट एन
ओल्ड सेशन वैल्यू टू द वेब एप्लीकेशन अगर
लाइफटाइम एक्सपायर हो जाता है एक सेशन का
एंड अगर आपने ओल्ड सेशन वैल्यू को ठीक है
रिप्लेस डाला है एक न्यू सेशन वैल्यू में
इट शुड बी डिनाइड एज सेशंस शुड हैव बीन
एक्सपायर्ड तो ये डिनाइड होना चाहिए ऐसा
नहीं है कि ओल्ड सेशन वैल्यू डाल दिया एक
नए रिक्वेस्ट में तो ओल्ड वाली सेशन चलने
लग जाए इस सेशन में। ये नहीं ये गलत है।
ऐसा होगा तो ये मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशन कहा जाएगा।
एंड दिस इज़ अ वलेबिलिटी कि अगर आप मान लो
लेट्स सपोज मैं इसका एग्जांपल लिख देता
हूं।
मैं आपको एक एग्जांपल बताता हूं।
मान लो कि आपका आपके दोस्त के लैपटॉप पे
आप गए हो। ठीक है? लेट्स सपोज उसके उस
लैपटॉप में आपके दोस्त ने xyz.com एक
वेबसाइट खोली हुई है। उस वेबसाइट में
लॉगिन करा हुआ है। अब आपने कैसे भी चुपके
से उसको धोखा देके उसके साथ धोखेबाजी कर
ली है। ठीक है? और अपने दोस्त के साथ एक
धोखेबाजी कर ली।
धोखेबाजी में आपने उसका
सेशन वैल्यू चुरा लिया। अब उस सेशन वैल्यू
को कॉपी करके लेकर आए। सेम वेबसाइट खोली।
उसको इंपोर्ट कर दिया सेशन वैल्यू को।
कुकी इंपोर्टर वगैरह ऐसे है। बहुत सारे
इंपोर्टर्स आते हैं। और जैसे ही इंपोर्ट
किया क्या हुआ कि उसी फ्रेंड का आपका सेशन
यहां पे ओपन हो गया। तो ये बहुत बड़ा
ब्लंडर है। दिस इज़ अ सिक्योरिटी मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन। ये नहीं होना चाहिए। सो
बेसिकली अगर हां ऐसा भी हो सकता है कि
आपने जब वो चीज क्वेश्चन कॉपी कर ली है
सेशन वैल्यू और यहां पे लेकर आए हैं और
आपने जब इसको इंपोर्ट किया जब आपने ओपन
करने की कोशिश करी वहां पे आ रहा था कि
नहीं ये लॉगउ ही है लॉगउ है लॉग इन नहीं
हो पाएगा क्योंकि आपके फ्रेंड ने वहां पे
अपने सेशन को लॉगउ कर दिया है। तो बाय
डिफॉल्ट यही होना चाहिए कि आपका फ्रेंड जब
अपने अकाउंट को डिफॉल्ट लॉग आउट कर दे तो
उस समय जो भी सेशन वैल्यू एसोसिएटेड होगी
उस पर्टिकुलर सेशन से वो एक्सपायर हो जाना
चाहिए। उसकी वैल्यू खत्म हो जानी चाहिए।
वो काम नहीं करता रहना चाहिए। अदरवाइज कोई
भी उस सेशन वैल्यू को उठाएगा और उसके उस
सेशन को लॉग इन कर लेगा अपने पास। राइट?
तो ये बहुत बड़ा ब्लंडर है। यह आपने आप
मुझे यह बताओ। आप ये चीजों को कनेक्ट कर
पा रहे हो जो मैं बोल रहा हूं। आप समझ पा
रहे हो मैं क्या बोल पा रहा हूं। बोल रहा
हूं। आप मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए।
मुझे बता दीजिए सर जल्दी से।
धन्यवाद हंटर एक्सक्स। थैंक यू सो मच।
सो प्लीज लेट मी नो इफ यू आर गेटिंग व्हाट
आई एम सेइंग। सेशंस के बारे में आपको
चीजें समझ में आए। तभी मुझे पता चलेगा कि
हां आपको समझ में आ रहा है। अगर आप
रिप्लाई करेंगे तो रिप्लाई कर दीजिए। तब
तक मैं अपनी कोल्ड कॉफी जो मैंने बनाई थी
सेशन शुरू होने से पहले वह भी पी लेता
हूं।
हो रही है।
ठीक है।
गेटिंग
ओके 78 पीपल आर हियर बट रिस्पांस बहुत कम
लोगों का आ रहा है। अच्छा ये बताओ कोई
दुश्मनी है क्या मतलब रिस्पांस से आप
लोगों की? कोई मतलब दुश्मनी है कोई कुछ
गलती कर दिया रिस्पांस वालों ने आपके साथ?
रिस्पांस तो दो कि मजा आ रहा है कि नहीं आ
रहा। मतलब समझ में आ रहा है कि नहीं आ रहा
है यह बताओ।
फर्स्ट टाइम लाइव थैंक्स। ग्रेट। चलिए समझ
में आ रही है? कई लोग बोल रहे हैं समझ में
आ रहा है। बहुत अच्छी बात है।
गुड गुड।
ओके। सो यहां पे हम सेशन एक्सपायरी की बात
कर रहे थे।
यू माइट क्लोज द टैब और योर एंटायर
ब्राउज़र सिंस द प्रोटोकॉल इज स्टेटलेस वेब
एप्लीकेशन हैज़ नो मेथड टू नो राइट
योर सेशन वैल्यू इटसेल्फ शुड हैव अ
लाइफटाइम अटैच टू इट इफ द लाइफट एक्सपायर
इफ द लाइफटाइम एक्सपायर्स एंड यू सबमिट एन
ओल्ड सेशन वैल्यू टू द वेब एप्लीकेशन इट
शुड बी डिनाइड बस ये डिनाइड होना चाहिए
इंस्टीड यू शुड बी रीडायरेक्टेड टू द
लॉगिन पेज टू ऑथेंटिकेट अगेन एंड स्टार्ट
द सेशन मैनेजमेंट लाइफ साइकिल ऑल ओवर अगेन
मतलब होना यही चाहिए कि अगर आपने कोई
एक्सपायर्ड सेशन यूज़ किया है। सेशन वैल्यू
बेसिकली यू कैन से सेशन वैल्यू बात करते
हैं। तो इसका मतलब यह होना चाहिए कि अगर
आप उसको इंपोर्ट कर रहे हो तो जैसे ही
इंपोर्ट किया और आपने रीलोड किया इट शुड
गिव यू विद द लॉगिन पेज अगेन टू लॉग इन
एंड स्टार्ट द सेशन अगेन। यही होना चाहिए।
बट कई ऐसे केसेस में ऐसा नहीं होता। आप
सबको पता होना चाहिए। अच्छा मुझे बताइए आप
सबको शायद इसका आईडिया हो। Netflix
एक टेंपरेरी सेशन वैल्यू यूज करता है
जनरली या एक पर्सिस्टेंट सेशन वैल्यू यूज
करता है जिसकी एक्सपायरी काफी लंबी होती
है एंड काफी टाइम तक वो एक्टिव रहता है
Netflix कौन सा यूज़ करता है बता दीजिए
मुझे पर्सिस्टेंट होता है उसका या
टेंपरेरी होती है उसकी
आई विल बी आस्किंग
अगेन Netflix का जो सेशन वैल्यू होता है
पर्सिस्टेंट होता है या टेंपरेरी होता है?
ओके। सो
ठीक है। Netflix का जो सेशन वैल्यू होता
है वो पर्सिस्टेंट होता है। पर्सिस्टेंट
होता है। एंड जब तक आप अपने अकाउंट को
लॉगउ नहीं करें। जैसे मैंने Netflix लॉग
इन कर लिया। अब आपने मेरा अगर कुकीज़
वैल्यू मतलब सेशन वैल्यू अगर आपने ले लिया
उसको अपने ब्राउज़र में इंपोर्ट कर लिया यू
कैन हैव माय Netflix सेशन रनिंग ऑन योर
लैपटॉप और आप मेरा पूरा का पूरा अकाउंट का
सेशन जो है वो रन कर सकते हैं। ये फैक्ट
है। आप कभी आपने अगर हां आपने अगर
डीसीजीएसपी हमारी जो कोर्स है वो करी होगी
या आप हमारे किसी भी कोर्स में हैकिंग
वाले कोर्स में एथिकल हैकिंग वाले कोर्स
में होंगे तो आपको ये चीज़ पहले से पता
होगी। नहीं करा है तो कोई बात नहीं ये
चीजें मैंने वैसे भी बताई है कई बार बट
ऐसा होता है। ठीक है।
मेरे हां ठीक है। हमारे सर्टिफिकेशन के
डिफरेंस पे बाद में आएंगे। अभी फिलहाल जो
हम कर रहे हैं वो कर लेते हैं क्योंकि
काफी कुछ अभी बचा है हमारा यहां पे समझना
सीखना। ठीक है? चलिए अब आते हैं सेशन
टर्मिनेशन के ऊपर में। ठीक है? ये तीनों
हो गई। अब आते हैं सेशन टर्मिनेशन। इन सम
केसेस यूजर माइट फोर्स फोर्सिबली परफॉर्म
अ लॉगउ एक्शन। कुछ केसेस में क्या हो सकता
है? यूजर लॉगउ एक्शन परफॉर्म कर सकता है।
इन द इवेंट दैट दिस अकर्स द वेब एप्लीकेशन
शुड टर्मिनेट द यूजर सेशन। जैसे ही लॉगउ
होता है, वेब एप्लीकेशन को क्या करना
चाहिए? सेशन को टर्मिनेट कर देना चाहिए।
यह बात हमेशा ध्यान रखिएगा। ये तो नॉर्मल
होना चाहिए कि जैसे ही कोई बंदा कोई यूजर
लॉगउ कर दे, सेशन शुड बी टर्मिनेटेड।
व्हाइल दिस इज़ सिमिलर टू सेशन एक्सपायरी,
इट इज़ यूनिक इन द सेंस दैट इवन इफ द सेशंस
लाइफटाइम इज़ स्टिल वैलिड, द सेशन इटसेल्फ
शुड बी टर्मिनेटेड। सेशन एक्सपायरी एंड
टर्मिनेशन में डिफरेंस है। सेशन एक्सपायरी
जो हम इसकी बात कर रहे थे या फिर हम बात
करें सेशन टाइम आउट की एंड सेशन टर्मिनेशन
दोनों में डिफरेंस है। सेशन एक्सपायरी की
डेट अभी बहुत आगे की भी है तो भी अगर कोई
बंदा लॉगउ कर दे तो सेशन टर्मिनेट हो जाना
चाहिए। वैल्यू ज़ीरो हो जानी चाहिए। वैल्यू
टर्मिनेट हो जानी चाहिए। वैल्यू की कोई
वैल्यू नहीं होनी चाहिए। सेशन वैल्यू की
कोई वैल्यू नहीं होनी चाहिए। लॉगउ के बाद
ये होना चाहिए। ये नॉर्मल बिहेवियर है।
इसके अलावा कुछ भी होता है वो एबनॉर्मल
बिहेवियर है। सिंपल सा वो मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
है। अगर यही कांसेप्ट्स आपके दिमाग में
बैठ जाए ना तो जब आप एक-एक वेब एप्लीकेशन
को चेक आउट करोगे इस वनेबिलिटी के लिए
सेशन रिलेटेड वनेबिलिटी आपके दिमाग में
आएगा कि अरे भैया
इसका मैंने तो यार लॉगउ कर दिया है। फिर
भी मैं इसका सेशन वैल्यू इंपोर्ट कर रहा
हूं। तो यह वापस से उसी लॉगिन सेक्शन
लॉगिन सेक्शन ही ओपन हो रहा है। लॉगिन
फॉर्म में ओपन हो रहा है। तो इट्स अ
वनेबिलिटी यही तो रिपोर्ट करना है। इट्स अ
वनेबिलिटी P1 P2 डिपेंडिंग ऑन द इंपैक्ट
यू आर शोइंग। दिस इज़ द थिंग। अब चलिए
द सेशन इटसेल्फ शुड बी टर्मिनेटेड। इशूज़
इन दिस टर्मिनेशन प्रोसेस कुड अलाउ अ
थ्रेट एक्टर टू गेन पर्सिस्टेंट एक्सेस टू
एन अकाउंट। इसी टाइप के प्रोसेस में जो
अगर यह टर्मिनेशन प्रोसेस में अगर किसी
तरह की गड़बड़ी होती है, मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
होती है, तो अटैकर के पास आपका पूरा का
पूरा सेशन जो है एक्सेस करने का क्षमता
होगा। इन दिस रूम वी विल लुक एट व्हाट कैन
बी रोंग। अब यहां पे कुछ क्वेश्चंस हैं।
इन क्वेश्चंस को सबमिट करते हैं। देखते
हैं हमने क्या पढ़ा है, क्या वो करा है।
व्हिच स्टेट? अब मुझे क्वेश्चंस के आंसर
आप दीजिएगा। बिना देखे ईमानदारी से
ऑनेस्टली दीजिएगा। हम सब हम दोनों साथ में
मतलब हम लोग साथ में इसको सॉल्व करेंगे।
ठीक है? तभी मजा आएगा यार। मैं अकेले कर
लूंगा फटाफट। तो क्या मतलब है? व्हिच
स्टेट इन द सेशन मैनेजमेंट साइकिल डील्स
विद यूज़र्स प्रेसिंग द लॉगउ बटन? कौन सा
स्टेट सेशन मैनेजमेंट साइकिल का डील करता
है? यूजर प्रेसिंग द लॉगउ बटन। ये चारों
में से कौन सा करता है? मुझे बताइए। जल्दी
बताइए। यूजर क्वेश्चन आपने देख लिया। सेशन
क्रिएशन, सेशन ट्रैकिंग, सेशन टाइम और
सेशन टर्म टर्मिनेशन। लॉगउ बटन जब प्रेस
करता है यूजर तो कौन सा साइकिल इसमें होता
है? सेशन टर्मिनेशन हमारा पहला क्वेश्चन
का आंसर आ गया। रितेश प्रजापति बढ़िया
अच्छी बात है। देखते हैं यहां पे सेशन
टर्मिनेशन। चलिए क्या बात है। बिल्कुल सही
जवाब है। आपको मिल चुके हैं ₹10,000। अब
करोड़पति बनने के लिए हमारा नेक्स्ट
क्वेश्चंस मतलब उस फेज में आगे बढ़ने के
लिए। वि स्टेट इज द सेशन मैनेजमेंट इन द
सेशन मैनेजमेंट लाइफ साइकिल डील्स विद
यूज़र्स प्रोवाइडिंग देयर क्रेडेंशियल्स
कौन सा सेशन करता है व्हिच स्टेट यूज़र्स
प्रोवाइडिंग देयर क्रेडेंशियल्स बताइए
यूज़र्स जब क्रेडेंशियल्स दे रहे होते हैं
यूजरनेम एंड पासवर्ड उस समय कौन सा मैनेज
इस सेशन साइकिल का कौन सा प्रोसेस होता है
सेशन क्रिएशन चलिए बहुत अच्छी बात है सेशन
क्रिएशन क्वेश्चन कमाल है। आप जीत चुके
हैं ₹00 और अगला सवाल ₹25,000 के लिए। यह
रहा आपके स्क्रीन पर। व्हिच स्टेट इन द
सेशन मैनेजमेंट लाइफ साइकिल डील्स विद
यूज़र्स एक्शन परफॉर्म्ड आफ्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन?
यूज़र्स एक्शन को जो है ना डील करता है।
ऑथेंटिकेशन के बाद ऑथेंटिकेशन के बाद
यूज़र्स के एक्शन को डील करता है। बताइए
कौन सा है? यूज़र्स के एक्शन को डील करता
है। सेशन ट्रैकिंग। एक ने बोला सेशन
ट्रैकिंग।
ओके दो लोगों ने बोला सेशन ट्रैकिंग। चलिए
सेशन ट्रैकिंग लिख देते हैं। सेशन
ट्रैकिंग बिल्कुल सही जवाब है। आप जीत
चुके हैं ₹25,000। चलिए बहुत अच्छी बात
है। अगला सवाल ₹00 के लिए। यह रहा स्क्रीन
पे। वि स्टेट इन द सेशन मैनेजमेंट सल
डील्स विद यूज़र्स दैट फॉरगेट टू लॉग आउट
ऑफ द एप्लीकेशन। डील्स विद यूज़र्स दैट
फॉरगेट टू लॉग आउट ऑफ द एप्लीकेशन। लॉग
आउट करना भूल चुका है भैया। तो उसमें कौन
सा यूज़ होगा बताइए? लॉग आउट करना भूल चुका
है।
सेशन टाइम आउट
ठीक है। सेशन कुछ लोगों का आंसर कुछ लोगों
का आंसर कुछ और कुछ और भी है। सेशन टाइम
आउट। यहां तो यार टाइम आउट का स्पेलिंग वो
लिखने का आ ही नहीं रहा भाई। कैसे होगा?
सेशन
टाइम आउट। यह तो हो ही नहीं रहा।
सेशन टाइम आउट सेशन एक्सपायरी
चलिए हो गया सही है देखो टाइम आउट और
एक्सपायरी दोनों एक ही था बट यहां पे
ट्राई हैटमी का इशू है क्या है कि
इन्होंने पहले से प्रीडफाइंड जो वर्ड्स
इनको लेना है वही नहीं दोगे तो इनको लगेगा
गलत है तो जितने फील्ड्स डिफाइंड थे उतने
ही आपको देने थे तो यहां पे इन्होंने सेशन
एक्सपायरी लिखा है यहां पे टाइम आउट लिखा
है तो बिल्कुल सही है सेशन टाइम आउट आउट
भी जिन्होंने बोला उनका भी सही है। सेशन
एक्सपायरी जिन्होंने बोला उनका भी सही है।
ठीक है? तो यूज़र्स अगर लॉगउ करना भूल जाता
है वेब एप्लीकेशन पे तो वहां पे सेशन
एक्सपायरी या टाइम आउट ही इन इफेक्ट होते
हैं। एंड बिल्कुल सही जवाब है। तो आप सब
ने बिल्कुल सही जवाब देके जीत चुके हैं
पूरे ₹30,000। अगला सवाल जो होगा नेक्स्ट
पार्ट में वो होगा आपके ₹35,000 के लिए
₹35,000 के लिए। तो बाद में मिलते हैं
उसमें। यहां पे अब आते हैं ऑथेंटिकेशन
वर्सेस ऑथोराइजेशन। याद रखिएगा ये जो एक्स
एक्सप्लइटिंग इनसिक्योर सेशन मैनेजमेंट ये
एक्सप्लइट जो लैब है ये काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
है। आपको बहुत मजा आएगा। प्रैक्टिकल है ये
बेसिकली। तो इसमें आपको बहुत ज्यादा मजा
आने वाला है। ठीक है? तो देखते हैं अभी
वहां तक पहुंचेंगे तब। ये छोटे-छोटे
पार्ट्स हैं। इसको समझना बहुत जरूरी है।
अगर आप समझेंगे नहीं ना तो फिर मजा नहीं
आएगा आपको।
मेरा कोल्ड कॉफी भी खत्म हो गया। बहुत कम
था। मतलब मैं ऐसे पता नहीं चल रहा। बहुत
वैसे ज्यादा थी क्वांटिटी। बट पीते-पीते
पता नहीं चला। एनीवे
एनीवे कोई बात नहीं चलिए हाइब्रिड क्या है
मतलब नहीं वो नाम इन्होंने दो यूज़ कर लिए
ठीक है
सर कंटिन्यूएशन नहीं कर पा रहा हूं 101
वीडियोस किया हूं इस प्ले तो कीजिए ना
कंटिन्यूएशन कीजिए वो आपके ऊपर है उसमें
मैं क्या कर सकता हूं आपको बस एक जोश
चाहिए एक अंदर से हिम्मत और जज्बा चाहिए
दैट्स इट
बढ़िया लॉजंस तुम बताओ कैसे हो अब आते हैं
ऑथेंटिकेशन वर्सेस
अ कराजुल कराजुल कराजुल आपका नाम ले लिया
सॉरी अगर गलत लिया तो बट वही है
का कराजुल आप अच्छा ठीक है ऑथेंटिकेशन
वर्सेस ऑथराइजेशन अब इसको समझते हैं दोनों
में बहुत डिफरेंसेस है याद रखिएगा
ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड ऑथराइजेशन में डिफरेंस है
चलिए
ठीक है ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड ऑथोराइजेशन में
बहुत डिफरेंस है। हम समझेंगे उसको पहले
इसको पढ़ते हैं क्या है ये? टू अंडरस्टैंड
द कॉमन वबिलिटीज़ इन सेशन मैनेजमेंट।
वी फर्स्ट नीड टू एग्जामिन ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड
ऑथराइजेशन। ठीक है? हमें दोनों एग्जामिन
करना है। ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड ऑथराइज़ेशन।
व्हाइल दे साउंड द सेम दे आर ऑफेन
कंफ्यूज्ड। ईच प्ले अ क्रिटिकल एंड यूनिक
रोल इन सेशन मैनेजमेंट। दोनों का यूनिक
रोल है। चलिए अब आते हैं यहां पे। इनको
समझने से समझने समझने के लिए हमें आई
आई टेट्रा ए ठीक है हमें यहां पे आई
ट्रिपल ए बेसिकली आई ट्रिपल ए मॉडल समझना
पड़ेगा आई ट्रिपल ए मॉडल व्हाट इज़ आई
ट्रिपल ए मॉडल आई फॉर आइडेंटिफिकेशन एंड
बाकी के तीन जो ए है उनका मतलब होता है
ऑथेंटिकेशन ऑथोराइजेशन एंड अकाउंटेबिलिटी
ये होते हैं आई ट्रिपल ए मॉडल ओके अब आते
हैं आइडेंटिफिकेशन पे आइडेंटिफिकेशन इज़ द
प्रोसेस ऑफ़ वेरीाइंग हु टू द यूजर इज भैया
जब आप जाओगे लॉगिन करने ऑथेंटिकेशन मतलब
बेसिकली तो आपको वेरीफाई करा जाएगा कि आप
एक्चुअली कौन हो आप वही हो जो होने चाहिए
या कोई और हो जिसका नाम किसी ने सुना नहीं
या आप वही हो जिसका नाम सबने सुना है। दिस
स्टार्ट्स विद द यूजर क्लेमिंग टू बी अ
स्पेसिफिक आइडेंटिटी इन मोस्ट वेब
एप्लीकेशनेशंस दिस इज़ परफॉर्म्ड बाय
सबमिटिंग योर यूजरनेम। तो यूजरनेम आप
सबमिट करोगे तो क्या होगा वहां पे? आपकी
आइडेंटिटी पता चलेगी कि भैया मैं ही हूं
जो होना चाहिए और कोई नहीं हूं। ठीक है?
तो आपने यूजरनेम डाला। यहां पर आपकी
आइडेंटिफिकेशन हो गई है। यू आर क्लेमिंग
दैट यू आर द पर्सन एसोसिएटेड विद द
स्पेसिफिक यूजरनेम। सम एप्लीकेशनेशंस आर
यूनिकली क्रिएटेड यू यूज़ यूनिकली क्रिएटेड
यूजरनेम्स वेयर ऐज़ अदर्स विल टेक योर ईमेल
आईडी एज योर यूजरने। कई ऐसे एप्लीकेशनेशंस
होते हैं जहां पे आप खुद का यूजरनेम बना
सकते हो। कई ऐसे एप्लीकेशनेशंस होते हैं
जो आपके ईमेल आईडी को ही क्या कर लेते
हैं? यूजरनेम बना देते हैं। आपकी ईमेल
आईडी को वो यूजरनेम घोषित कर देते हैं।
आपको यूजरनेम बोल देते हैं। तो, यह तो
फैक्ट है। यह तो आप सबको पता ही होगा।
उसके बाद आती है ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोसेस। ऑथ
ऑथेंटिकेशन इज़ द प्रोसेस ऑफ़ एनश्योरिंग
दैट द यूजर इज़ हु दे से दे आर। ऑथेंटिकेशन
में यह होता है यूजर ने जो बोला है, वही
वो हैं। पहले तो यह बताते हैं कि हु द
यूजर इज़। मैं कौन यूजर हूं ये बताने का
काम आइडेंटिफिकेशन। अब मैं वही यूजर हूं।
ये ऑथेंटिकेशन के थ्रू होता है। इसमें
यूजरनेम आप देते हैं। वेयर इन
आइडेंटिफिकेशन यू प्रोवाइड अ यूजरनेम। फॉर
ऑथेंटिकेशन यू प्रोवाइड प्रूफ दैट यू आर
हु यू से यू आर। आप यहां पे प्रूफ देते हो
कि भैया मैं ही हूं यार। प्रूफ कैसे दोगे?
पासवर्ड से दोगे। फॉर एग्जांपल यू कैन
सप्लाई द पासवर्ड एसोसिएटेड विद द क्लेम्ड
यूजरनेम। उस यूजरनेम से एसोसिएटेड पासवर्ड
जो है आप दे सकते हो उसके लिए। अब सोचो आप
तो ऐसे जाते हो Facebook, Instा जो भी
जहां भी लॉगिन करते हो यूजरनेम पासवर्ड
डाला, फटाक से लॉगिन किया, अकाउंट एक्सेस
किया। वाह क्या-क्या कर लिया। सोचो ये
एक-एक प्रोसेस का ना मतलब होता है। एक-एक
प्रोसेस जो आप कर रहे हो, यूजरनेम दे रहे
हो उसका मतलब है आइडेंटिफिकेशन। पासवर्ड
डेल रहे हो उसका मतलब है ऑथेंटिकेशन। ठीक
है? उसके बाद जो चीजें एक्सेस करोगे उसका
मतलब है ऑथोराइजेशन।
हर एक चीज सोचोगे तो बहुत मजा आएगा। पता
नहीं कौन इतना सोचता है बट स्टिल
फर्स्ट टाइम लाइव ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट आई एम
गुड साइबर टेक अजू
आई एम गुड ब्रदर
सॉरी भाई लेट हो गया अच्छा कोई बात नहीं
लेट हो गया कोई बात नहीं थोड़ा जल्दी आ
जाया करना नेक्स्ट टाइम से आप लोग
ऑथराइजेशन पे यहां पे आप देख द वेब
एप्लीकेशन कैन कंफर्म दिस इनेशन इफ इट इज़
वैलिड दिस इज़ द पॉइंट वेयर सेशन क्रिएशन
वुड टेक इन जब आप यूजरनेम आपने पहले डाल
दिया पासवर्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन में डाल दिया। तो
अब वेब एप्लीकेशन आपका जो है यह इनेशन
कंफर्म करेगा। एंड यहीं से सेशन क्रिएशन
की स्टार्ट होती है। जैसे ही आप यूजरनेम
पासवर्ड डाल देते हो वहां से आफ्टर
ऑथेंटिकेटेड सेशन क्रिएशन वाली जो प्रोसेस
है वो स्टार्ट हो जाती है। अब बात आती है
ऑथोराइजेशन की। ऑथोराइजेशन इज़ द प्रोसेस
ऑफ़ एश्योरिंग दैट द स्पेसिफिक यूजर हैज़ द
राइट्स रिक्वायर्ड टू परफॉर्म द एक्शन
रिक्वेस्टेड।
जो भी उसने रिक्वेस्ट किया एक्शन उसके पास
उसकी परमिशन है। यह ऑथराइजेशन का काम है।
इसी प्रोसेस में होता है। फॉर एग्जांपल
व्हाइल ऑल यूर्स मे व्यू द डेटा ओनली अ
सेलेक्ट फ्यू मे मॉडिफाई इट। अब ये हो
सकता है कि कोई एक डेटा को सारे यूज़र्स
देख तो सकते हैं बट उसको मॉडिफाई करने का
उसमें चेंजेस करने का परमिशन सिर्फ कुछ
यूज़र्स को या कुछ सेलेक्टिव यूज़र्स को या
कुछ सुपर एडमिनस को या एडमिंस को या रूट
यूज़र्स को। ऐसा हो सकता है। इन द सेशन
मैनेजमेंट लाइफ साइकिल सेशन ट्रैकिंग
प्लेस अ क्रिटिकल रोल इन ऑथोराइजेशन। एंड
इसी में सेशन ट्रैकिंग का भी यूज़ होता है।
याद रखिएगा सेशन ट्रैकिंग का यूज़
ऑथराइजेशन प्रोसेस में होता है। हमेशा
दिमाग में रखिएगा कि वो कौन सा पर्टिकुलर
सेक्शन वो यूज़ एक्सेस कर सकता है। इसका
ट्रैक डाउन किया जाता है सेशन ट्रैकिंग
में। अब आती है अकाउंटेबिलिटी जो कि बहुत
सिंपल है। अकाउंटेबिलिटी इज़ द प्रोसेस ऑफ़
क्रिएटिंग अ रिकॉर्ड ऑफ़ एकशंस परफॉर्म।
मतलब आपने जो भी एज अ यूजर आप जो भी
एक्शंस सर्वर पे परफॉर्म कर रहे हो या एज
अ ऑथेंटिकेटेड यूजर परफॉर्म कर रहे हो उन
सबका एक रिकॉर्ड एक लॉग क्रिएट किया जाता
है ताकि बाद में जब किसी तरह की डिबगिंग
हो किसी तरह का कोई मशियस अटैक होता है
सर्वर के ऊपर किसी तरह की कोई प्रॉब्लम्स
होती है सर्वर के अंदर तो उन्हीं लॉक्स का
यूज़ किया जाता है एंड उनसे देखा जाता है
कि कौन से यूजर ने क्या-क्या एकशंस
परफॉर्म किए हैं। उस एक्शन परफॉर्म करने
के लिए वो यूजर एक्चुअली परमिशेबल था।
उसको परमिशन थी कि नहीं थी। अब उसने अगर
बिना परमिशन के भी एक्सेस किया है तो फिर
कैसे एक्सेस कर लिया है? क्यों एक्सेस कर
लिया है? किस तरह की वलेबिलिटीज़ है? किस
तरह की वीकनेसेस आई हैं? एंड वगैरह-वगैरह।
ठीक है? ये सारी चीजें होती है। वी शुड
ट्रैक द यूजर सेशन एंड लॉग ऑल एकशंस
परफॉर्म्ड ड्यूरिंग द स्पेसिफिक सेशन। दिस
इनफॉर्म्स इनेशन प्लेज़ अ क्रिटिकल रोल इन
द इवेंट ऑफ़ अ सिक्योरिटी इंसिडेंट टू पीस
टुगेदर। व्हाट हैज़ हैपेंड। तो कोई भी तरह
का अगर अटैक या सिक्योरिटी इंसिडेंट होता
है तो उसके टाइम में यह काफ़ी ज़्यादा जो है
आपका यूज़ आता है। उस टाइम में काफी ज्यादा
यूज़ इसकी पड़ती है।
ठीक है? ये हो गया। तो ये चारों हमने
डिस्कस कर लिया। अब आ जाते हैं इसके
क्यूएनए सेशन पे। सभी लोग रेडी हैं इस
हमारे कौन बनेगा ट्राईकमीपति पे खेलने के
लिए नेक्स्ट 35,000 के धनराशि के लिए। सो
35,000 के धनराशि के लिए आपका अगला सवाल
यह रहा स्क्रीन पर जिसका जवाब आप सबको
देना है। ठीक है? व्हाट इज द नेम ऑफ द
प्रोसेस इन द आई ट्रिपल ए मॉडल दैट वुड बी
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर ट्रैकिंग योर एक्शंस एंड
लॉगिंग देम। बताइए ट्रैकिंग योर एकशंस एंड
लॉगिंग देम।
प्लीज डोंट स्पैम। बार-बार एक ही मैसेज आप
अगर भेजेंगे तो आपको मजबूरन मुझे वहां से
हटाना पड़ेगा। तो प्लीज डोंट डू।
चलिए बताइए इसका। इसका व्हाट इज़ द नेम ऑफ़
द प्रोसेस इन आई ट्रिपल ए मॉडल? दैट वुड
बी रिस्पांसिबल फॉर ट्रैकिंग योर एक्शंस
एंड लॉगिंग देम। ट्रैकिंग योर एकशंस एंड
लॉगिंग देम। बताइए।
ट्रैकिंग योर एक्शन एंड लॉगिंग देम।
मैंने अभी बताया था कि ट्रैकिंग योर एकशंस
एंड लॉगिंग देम। या आप देखिए
ट्रैकिंग एंड लॉगिंग का जो फंडा है वह
हमने तो इसी में तो देखा था अकाउंटेबिलिटी
में तो आप लोग ये ऑथोराइजेशन
अ सेशन ट्रैकिंग ये सब कहां से आ रही है
मुझे समझ नहीं आ रहा अकाउंटेबिलिटी
ये होगा ना अकाउंटेबिलिटी तो ये ऑथराइजेशन
कहां से आएगी ट्रैकिंग एक्शंस एंड लॉगिंग
देम ये तो अकाउंटेबिलिटी में है ना कि
अकाउंटेबल आप अकाउंटेबल खुद को ठहरा रहे
आप खुद को अकाउंटेबल बोल रहे हैं कि भैया
हां सब कुछ मेरे नजर में होना चाहिए। सही
से अकाउंटेबिलिटी होगी। व्हाट इज़ द नेम ऑफ़
द प्रोसेस इन आई ट्रिपल ए मॉडल? दैट वुड
बी रिस्पांसिबल फॉर ग्रांटिंग यू अ सेशन
वैल्यू। सेशन वैल्यू कौन देता है? बता
दीजिए अब। सेशन वैल्यू कौन देता है इनमें
से?
हु गिव्स द सेशन वैल्यू?
यस। जिन्होंने आंसर सही दिया उनको 35,000
की धनराशि प्राप्त हो गई है। अगला सवाल
400 धनराशि के लिए। यह है सवाल। व्हाट इज
द नेम ऑफ़ प्रोसेस ऑफ़ आई ट्रिपल ए मॉडल दैट
विल बी रिस्पांसिबल फॉर ग्रांटिंग यू अ
सेशन वैल्यू? सेशन वैल्यू बता दीजिए कौन
देता है?
ऑथेंटिकेशन
ऑथेंटिकेशन।
ऑथेंटिकेशन यहां पे इसका आंसर है
ऑथेंटिकेशन। ठीक है? ऑथोराइजेशन फिर क्यों
बोल रहे हो? मेरे को समझ नहीं आ रहा। आप
लोग ऑथराइजेशन क्यों बोल रहे हो?
ऑथराइजेशन तब होती है जब ऑथेंटिकेशन हो
जाती है। राइट? ऑथराइजेशन में क्या हो
जाता है कि आप कौन-कौन से चीजों को एक्सेस
कर सकते हैं? उसका ये पूरा डील करता है।
बट ऑथेंटिकेशन में ही तो सेशन यहां देखो
ना सेशन क्रिएशन यहीं से स्टार्ट होती है।
ऑथेंटिकेशन में ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोसेस में
सेशन क्रिएशन स्टार्ट हो जाती है। एंड
सेशन क्रिएशन का मतलब क्या हो जाता है?
सेशन क्रिएशन का मतलब है कि आपको सेशन
वैल्यू मिल गई है। सेशन क्रिएट होते ही
सेशन वैल्यू मिल जाएगी। तो ऑथेंटिकेशन हो
जाएगा। सिंपल। अब यहां पे है व्हाट इज़ द
नेम ऑफ़ द प्रोसेस इन आई ट्रिपल ए मॉडल?
दैट वुड बी रिस्पांसिबल फॉर वेरीफ़ाइंग दैट
यू हैव द रिलेवेंट परमिशन टू परफॉर्म एन
एक्शन। यह तो बहुत आसान है। अब इसका बता
दीजिए। यह है ₹45,000 नहीं ₹ज़ धनराशि के
लिए। यह ₹00 धनराशि है। अगर आप सही जवाब
देते हैं तो आपको ₹00 की धनराशि मिलेगी।
सभी लोग बताइए सभी लोग। जिनको नहीं भी पता
जो नहीं संतोष प्लीज डोंट सेंड मल्टीपल
आंसर्स। प्लीज आप एक बार आंसर कीजिए एंड
उसके बाद आप उसको आंसर मत कीजिए। अदरवाइज़
आपको मुझे टाइम आउट कर जाना पड़ेगा। सो
इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट। बाकी लोग जवाब दीजिए। अ
ये तो बहुत आसान है। परमिशंस चेक करना है।
ऑथोराइजेशन। सो ये तो बहुत ईजी था। सो
यहां पे हमने ऑथोराइजेशन लिखना है।
ऑथोराइजेशन।
ये तो आपको अब ये आपको ज्यादा अच्छे से
समझ में आ रहा होगा। ये चीज़ बहुत ईजी वे
में समझ में आ रही होगी। राइट? ऐसे आप जब
सीखेंगे तो आपको समझ में भी बहुत ईज़ली
आएगा। मुझे पता है। ऐसे आप पढ़ेंगे, रट्टा
मारेंगे तो आपको शायद उतना समझ में ना आए।
अब आते हैं कुकीज़ वर्सेस टोकंस पे। ये भी
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग पार्ट है। कुकीज़ वर्सेस
टोकंस। देखना, ध्यान देना। यह बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट है। ठीक है? कुकीज़ वर्सेस
टोकंस।
ओके?
द टू मेन अप्रोचेस।
द लास्ट टॉपिक टू कवर बिफोर ड्राइविंग
इंटू सेशन मैनेजमेंट सिक्योरिटी इज़। द
टाइप ऑफ सेशंस बीइंग यूज्ड। सेशंस के टाइप
जो यूज़ में होते हैं। द टू मेन अप्रोचेस
आर कुकीज़ एंड टोकंस। दो अप्रोचेस होते
हैं। एक कुकी होता है और एक टोकन के थ्रू
होता है। ईच विद इट्स ओन बेनिफिट्स एंड
ड्रॉबैक्स। दोनों के अपने बेनिफिट्स हैं
और अपने ड्रॉबैक्स हैं। अब दोनों को हम
समझते हैं। एक कुकी बेस्ड सेशन मैनेजमेंट
होता है और एक होता है टोकन बेस्ड सेशन
मैनेजमेंट। देखो
दोनों के अपने फायदे हैं और अपने नुकसान
भी हैं। याद रखिएगा। फायदे नुकसान दोनों
है। तो अब आते हैं यहां पे कुकी बेस्ड
सेशन मैनेजमेंट के ऊपर में। कुकी बेस सेशन
मैनेजमेंट इज़ ऑफेन कॉल्ड द ओल्ड स्कूल वे
ऑफ़ मैनेजिंग सेशंस। क्योंकि ये काफी ओल्ड
सेशन मैनेजमेंट टेक्निक है। काफी टाइम से
चला आ रहा है। वंस द वेब एप्लीकेशन वांट्स
टू बिगिन ट्रैकिंग इन अ रिस्पांस द सेट
कुकी हेडर वैल्यू विल बी सेंट। सेट कुकी
का हेडर वैल्यू सेंड किया जाता है सर्वर
के तरफ से। अगर आपको ये चीजें नहीं पता ये
सेट कुकी वगैरह तो मैंने ऑलरेडी शायद
पढ़ाया हुआ है। आप में से कितने लोगों को
याद है कि मैंने ये एचटीटीपी कुकीज़ वाली
क्लास जो हुई थी हमारी एचटीटीपी वाली जो
क्लास हुई थी स्पेशली मैंने कराई थी।
उसमें मैंने एचटीटीपी हेडर्स के बारे में
बात करी थी। रिक्वेस्ट हेडर रिस्पांस हेडर
उसमें मैंने आपको सेट कुकी हेडर के बारे
में बताया था जो सर्वर की हेडर होती है।
सर्वर के साइड से सेट की जाती है। आपको
याद है? किसी को याद है यहां पे या नहीं
याद है? मुझे डाउट है बट फिर भी बता
दीजिए।
एनीवन रिमेंबर दिस पर्टिकुलर सेट कुकी?
आई एम न्यू। ठीक है। कोई बात नहीं। बाकी
लोग
यस। ठीक है? याद है? चलिए अच्छी बात है।
जिनको याद है अच्छी बात है। सेट कुकी एक
हेडर होती है जो सर्वर के साइड से सेट
किया जाता है। एंड उसी में कुकी वैल्यू जो
है वो पास की जाती है। वंस द वेब
एप्लीकेशन वांट्स टू बिगिन ट्रैकिंग। जब
वो ट्रैक करना शुरू करेगा रिस्पांस में
सेट कुकी हेडर वैल्यू विल बी सेंट। योर
ब्राउज़र विल इंटरप्रेट दिस हेडर टू स्टोर
अ न्यू कुकी वैल्यू। लेट्स टेक अ लुक एट
सच सेट कुकी हेडर। तो ब्राउज़र उसको
इंटरप्रेट करेगा और एक न्यू कुकी वैल्यू
जो है वो स्टोर मतलब वो सेंड करेगा। अब
सेट कुकी ऐसे कुछ होता है। इस तरीके से
कुछ पास की जाती है। सेट कुकीज़ सेशन एंड
उसकी वैल्यू। ठीक है? सेट कुकी एक हेडर हो
गया। उसमें क्या है? सेशन एक आर्गुमेंट
है। उसकी वैल्यू जो है यहां पे आपको दे दी
गई है। योर ब्राउज़र विल क्रिएट अ कुकी
एंट्री फॉर अ कुकी नेम्ड सेशन। यहां पे एक
सेशन नाम का कुकी है। इसके नाम की एक कुकी
एंट्री कर देगा विथ अ वैल्यू ऑफ़ 1 2 3 4 5
व्हिच विल बी वैलिड फॉर द डोमेन वेयर द
कुकी वाज़ रिसीव्ड फ्रॉम। ये उस डोमेन के
लिए वैलिड होगा जहां से ये कुकी सेट कुकी
रिसीव हुआ था। उसी डोमेन के लिए वैलिड
होगा। सेवरल एट्रिब्यूट्स कैन आल्सो बी
एडेड टू दिस हेडर। इफ यू वांट टू लर्न मोर
अबाउट। ये तो अपना दिया हुआ है। अब यहां
पे कुछ एट्रिब्यूट्स और होते हैं जो इसके
साथ होते हैं। कुछ इसके साथ ऐड किए जाते
हैं। एक होता है सिक्योर। मतलब कि एक
सिक्योर जो है वह भी ऐड किया जाता है।
आपका जो एट्रिब्यूट्स है इसके साथ सिक्योर
एट्रिब्यूट ऐड होती है। इसको हम लाइव भी
एग्जांपल के थ्रू देखेंगे। लाइव
डेमोंस्ट्रेट करके देखेंगे। आपको उस टाइम
में अच्छे से समझ में आ जाएगी। मैं वैसे
आपको दिखाना चाहूं तो मैं वैसे भी आपको
कोशिश करता हूं दिखाने की। जैसे मैं यहां
पे हूं। मैं यहां पे अ मोर टूल्स पे चलता
हूं। वेब डेवलपर इस पर चलते हैं। इस पर
करते हैं। इसको रीलोड करते हैं। यहां पर
रीलोड करोगे तो आपको यहां पर मैं इसको
थोड़ा सा बड़ा कर लेता हूं। आपको यहां पे
अलग-अलग रिक्वेस्ट दिखेंगे जिसमें एक ये
20 200 रिक्वेस्ट है यहां पे। अब देखेंगे
यहां पे हेडर्स में तो यहां देखेंगे आप
रिस्पांस हेडर आ रही है। ये रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर आ रही है। ठीक है? तो रिस्पांस हेडर
में यहां पे अभी कुछ भी कुकी ट्रैकिंग
नहीं हो रही है फिलहाल के लिए। तो आपको
यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं दिख रहा। कुकीज़ में
जाएंगे तो यहां पे आपको कोई भी ऐसा सेट
कुकी वैल्यू जो है वो ये रिक्वेस्ट कुकी
है। ये रिस्पांस कुकी नहीं है। तो यहां पे
कुछ भी नहीं मिला क्योंकि यहां पे
ऑथेंटिकेटर ऑथेंटिकेटेड जब होंगे तब ये
आपका जो है ये प्रोसेस चालू होगा। जैसे
मैं यहां पे लॉग इन कर लेता हूं। एंड
मैंने यहां पे ऑलरेडी शायद लॉग इन करा हुआ
था। नहीं
यहां से। चलो मैं एक बार लॉग इन कर लेता
हूं और आपको वैसे दिखा देता हूं लॉग इन
करके। चलिए हम एक बार ना लॉग इन कर लेते
हैं। ठीक है? सो
मैंने यहां पे लॉग इन किया। अब मैं यहां
पे लॉग इन करूंगा। लॉग इन करूंगा। देन अभी
देखते हैं यहां पे नेटवर्क टैब को। यहां
पे आ चुका है। अब हम इसको एक्सेस करते
हैं। अ
अ
कोई भी पेज जो एक्सेसिबल हो उसको हम यूज़
कर लेंगे 200 यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके से आ
रही है यहां पे। सो हियर वी आर नॉट गेटिंग
द सर्वर
यहां पर हमें कुछ नहीं मिल रहा।
Google का देख लेते हैं। इफ दे आर
रिस्पांस में यहां पर कुछ कुकीज़ वैल्यू है
तो
यहां देख लेते हैं। नो्स नो
यहां डैशबोर्ड पे चल लेते हैं एक बार। एक
बार डैशबोर्ड को कर लेते हैं। हां अब यहां
पे शायद हमें मिल जाएगा जो हमें पेज
एक्सेस करना था। अह सो लेट्स चेक आउट द
पेज। या यह है क्लाइंट एरिया 200। यहां पे
देख लेते हैं रिस्पांस हेडर में।
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर में रिक्वेस्ट हेडर में तो
यह रिक्वेस्ट कुकीज़ है। इससे हमें कोई खास
हमें कुछ मतलब नहीं है। ये रिक्वेस्ट
कुकीज़ यहां पे आपको दिख रही है। हमें
चाहिए
कोई रिक्वेस्ट देख लेते हैं।
ओके सर्विसेस चलो यहां पे ना एक बार
प्रोफाइल पे चल देते हैं।
एक कोई सा भी पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट पे देख लेते
हैं। इफ देयर इज़ सम
कुकी असाइन।
चलिए यहां पे तो कुकी अभी हमें फिलहाल
यहां पे नहीं मिल रही है जिसको मैं आपको
दिखा सकूं। बट हमें जिसमें जहां पे भी जब
किसी भी सर्वर रिक्वेस्ट करेंगे अगर
मिलेगी तो वी विल बी सीइंग दैट राइट यहां
पे अभी फिलहाल सेट कुकी का यहां पे हमें
मिल नहीं रहा किसी और लाइक पेज पे जाके हम
देख सकते हैं लाइक वी कैन गो टू द
flipkart.com या कोई भी ऐसी ब्राउज़ पेज
जहां पे हां यहां पे एक बार कोई सा भी
प्रोडक्ट ओपन कर लेते हैं।
सेटिंग्स सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी
सॉरी सॉरी टूल्स मोर टूल्स वेब डेवलपर
टूल्स एंड लेट्स गो टू द नेटवर्क ठीक है
रीलोड कर लेते हैं हां जी तो यहां पे
हमारे पास Flipkart आ चुके हैं
ऊपर की तरफ चलते हैं फ्लिप फ्लिप Flipkart
ये क्या है भाई
बाइंडिंग अबाउट इट ठीक है यहां पे चलते
हैं एंड लेट्स सी इफ वी हैव कुकीज़। सो
यहां पे हां देखो यहां पे रिस्पांस कुकी
है। यहां पे कुकी है यहां पे। जैसे यहां
पे मैंने Flipkart को ओपन किया तो यहां पे
आप रिस्पांस हेडर देखेंगे। रिस्पांस हेडर
में नीचे की तरफ आएंगे तो आपको दिखेगा सेट
कुकीज़ की यहां पे हेडर्स मिल रही है आपको।
यहां पे सेट कुकीज़ हेडर मिल रही है। ये
देखिए आप।
ये हेडर मिली है आपकी सेट कुकी की। ठीक
है? अब इस हेडर को अगर मैं कॉपी कर लूं
यहां पे। एंड मैं यहां पे अगर मैं इसको
ओपन कर लूं कुछ इस तरीके से मैं आपको
दिखाऊं। तो कुछ इस तरीके से जो है इसकी
एंट्री होती है कुकीज़ की। कुछ इस तरीके से
यहां पर सेट कुकी की वैल्यू यहां पर असाइन
है। ठीक है? तो यहां पर SN यहां पे फिर
कुकी की वैल्यू यहां पे दिया हुआ है यहां
पे। एंड यहां पे आपको दिया हुआ है डोमेन
Flipkart। यानी ये Flipkart पे ही ये
Flipkart के लिए ये कुकी है। ओनली
Flipkart के लिए पाथ दिया हुआ है यहां पे।
एंड इसकी एक एक्सपायरी डेट दी गई है। आप
देखिए एक्सपायरी डे है। डेट क्या है? 24th
फरवरी 2026 इतने बजे। ठीक है? एंड ये
एचटीdटीp ओनली है। एचटीडीटीp ओनली यहां पे
सेट है। यानी कि एचटीडीपी ओनली ट्रू होगी।
आप देख लीजिएगा। एचटीडीपी ओनली यहां पे
ट्रू है। अब एचटीडीपी ओनली क्या होता है?
इसको भी हम समझेंगे कि इसका क्या मतलब
होता है। इसका मतलब यहां पे हम
जावास्क्रिप्ट के थ्रू इसको हम नहीं मंगा
सकते। जावास्क्रिप्ट के थ्रू इसको हम फैच
नहीं कर पाएंगे। तो ये सिक्योरिटी एक
सिक्योरिटी अह कॉन्फ़िगरेशन है। ये
सिक्योरिटी के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है।
फिलहाल हम आगे बढ़ेंगे तो उसमें हम और भी
चीजें समझेंगे। देखिए
अब यहां पे है सिक्योर। एक फ्लैग है यहां
पे। पे एक एट्रिब्यूट है सिक्योर।
इंडिकेट्स टू द ब्राउज़र दैट द कुकी मे
ओनली बी ट्रांसमिटेड ओवर वेरीिफ़ाइड
एचटीटीपीएस चैनल्स। इफ़ देयर आर सर्टिफिकेट
एरर्स और एचटीटीp इज़ यूज़्ड, द कुकी वैल्यू
विल नॉट बी ट्रांसमिटेड। मतलब यहां पे जब
कुकी कुकी वैल्यू है और वहां पे अगर
सिक्योर एट्रिब्यूट यूज़ हो रहा है, इसका
मतलब यह हुआ कि इट इज़ पॉसिबल कि ये जो
कुकी है, यह वेरीिफ़ाइड एचटीटीपीएस चैनल्स
पे ही ट्रांसमिट होगी। एंड किसी भी अनवेड
या HTTP चैनल्स पे ट्रांसमिट नहीं होगी।
यानी कि ये ट्रांसमिट नहीं की जाएगी बाय द
सर्वर। उसके बाद है http ओनली इंडिकेट्स
टू द ब्राउज़र दैट द कुकी वैल्यू मे नॉट बी
रीड बाय क्लाइंट साइड जावास्क्रिप्ट। जैसे
आप जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड डाल देते हैं ना
जावास्क्रिप्ट के पेड डाल देते हैं
डॉक्यूमेंट डॉट कुकी कुकी वैल्यू आप निकाल
लेते हैं। राइट? तो http ओनली अगर है वहां
पे, इसका मतलब है आप उस तरीके से उस कुकी
वैल्यू को गैब नहीं कर सकते। तो, यह एक
सिक्योरिटी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन है। एक्सपायर
इंडिकेट्स द ब्राउज़र व्हेन अ कुकी वैल्यू
विल नो लगर बी वैलिड एंड शुड बी रिमूव्ड।
यह बताएगा इसका एक्सपायरी टाइम सिंपल। और
उसके बाद है
सेम साइट इंडिकेट्स टू द ब्राउज़र वेदर द
कुकी मे बी ट्रांसमिटेड इन क्रॉस साइट
रिक्वेस्ट्स टू हेल्प प्रोटेक्ट अगेंस्ट
सीएसआरएफ अटैक्स।
ये है सीएसआरएफ अटैक से बचाने के लिए सेम
साइट एट्रिब्यूट्स का यूज़ भी किया जाता
है। इन सबको हम थोड़ा समझेंगे अच्छे से जब
हम प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन पे आएंगे
क्योंकि उसमें आपको ज्यादा अच्छे से शायद
समझ में आ जाएगी। अ की थिंग टू रिमेंबर
विद कुकी बेस्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन इज़ दैट ब्राउज़र
इटसेल्फ विल डिसाइड व्हेन अ सर्टेन कुकी
वैल्यू विल बी सेंट विथ अ रिक्वेस्ट। यह
ब्राउज़र ही डिसाइड करेगा।
आफ्टर रिव्यूइंग द डोमेन एंड द
एट्रिब्यूट्स ऑफ द कुकी द ब्राउज़र मैक्स द
डिसीजन एंड द कुकी इज़ अटैच्ड ऑटोमेटिकली
विदाउट एडिशनल क्लाइंट साइड जावास्क्रिप्ट
कोड एंड कुकी को अटैच कर दिया जाता है।
यानी कि एक ब्राउज़र का डिसीजन होता है।
याद रखिएगा ये चीज़। अब आते हैं यहां पे
टोकन बेस्ड सेशन मैनेजमेंट पे। टोकन बेस्ड
सेशन मैनेजमेंट क्या होता है? इसको समझ
लेंगे। देन हम इसके क्वेश्चंस को आंसर
करेंगे। एंड देन हम प्रैक्टिकल जो हमारा
आने वाला है उस पे भी हम जाएंगे। टोकन बेस
सेशन मैनेजमेंट इज रिलेटिबिलिटी न्यू
कांसेप्ट। देखो कुकी में कुकी वैल्यू सेट
होती है। सर्वर के साइड से सबसे पहले
सर्वर के साइड से सेट कुकी हेडर को सेट
किया जाता है और उसके रिस्पांस में
क्लाइंट यानी ब्राउज़र आपका कुकी नाम के
हेडर से रिसोंड करता है। दैट्स इट। कुकी
जो है वो रिक्वेस्ट हेडर में जाएगी और
आपकी जो सेट कुकी है वो रिस्पांस हेडर में
जाती है। कंफ्यूज मत हो जाना। कई लोग
कंफ्यूज हो जाते हैं कि सेट कुकी है तो
क्लाइंट भेजेगा। नहीं सेट कुकी सर्वर
भेजता है एंड सिर्फ कुकी जो हेडर है वो
क्लाइंट के तरफ से जाती है। ऑलवेज रिमेंबर
इन रिस्पांस टू दैट सेट कुकी। ठीक है? अब
देखिए टोकन बेस सिस्टम मैनेजमेंट
रिलेटिवली न्यू कॉनंसेप्ट इंस्टीड ऑफ़
यूजिंग द ब्राउज़र्स ऑटोमेटिक कुकी
मैनेजमेंट फीचर। ब्राउज़र का कुकी
मैनेजमेंट फीचर यूज़ नहीं करना है। उसमें
दिक्कतें आ सकती है। रिलाईज़ ऑन क्लाइंट
साइड कोड फॉर द प्रोसेस। क्लाइंट साइड के
कोड के ऊपर रिलाई करता है। कौन सा कोड?
आफ्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन द वेब एप्लीकेशन
प्रोवाइड्स अ टोकन विद द रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी।
एक रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी में टोकन प्रोवाइड करता
है वेब एप्लीकेशन। यूजिंग क्लाइंट साइड
जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड दिस टोकन इज़ देन स्टर्ड
इन द ब्राउज़र्स लोकल स्टोरेज। ब्राउज़र के
लोकल स्टोरेज में ये टोकंस जो हैं वो
स्टोर कर दिए जाते हैं। जी हां, ब्राउज़र
के स्टोरेज में ये टोकंस को स्टोर कर दिए
जाते हैं। व्हेन अ न्यू रिक्वेस्ट इज़ मेड,
जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड मस्ट लोड द टोकन फ्रॉम
स्टोरेज। जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड का यूज़ करके
उस टोकन को स्टोरेज से लोड किया जाता है।
जबजब नया रिक्वेस्ट बन किया जाता है सर्वर
से एंड अटैच इट एज अ हेडर और हेडर में
उसको अटैच कर दिया जाता है। मतलब पूरा
माजरा जब समझोगे तो आपको बहुत ब्यूटीफुल
एक एक कनेक्टिविटी नज़र आएगी क्लाइंट और
सर्वर के बीच की बात की कि दो तरीके से
सर्वर मैनेज कर दो तरीके से मैनेजमेंट हो
रही है यहां पे से मतलब सेशन वैल्यू की
कुकी के थ्रू हो रही है जो कि सेट कुकी
करता है आपका सर्वर कुकी के फॉर्म में
सर्वर जो भी सेट कुकी के अंदर जो भी
वैल्यू देता है उसके रिस्पांस में कुकी
वैल्यू कुकी हेडर जो है वो जाती है
क्लाइंट की तरफ से ब्राउज़र की तरफ से टोकन
बेस्ड सेशन मैनेजमेंट में क्या हो जाता है
कि सर्वर के साइड से एक टोकन वैल्यू इशू
किया जाता है रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी में सॉरी
रिस्पांस बॉडी में जो भी सर्वर के साइड से
रिस्पांस आता है जब आप कोई भी चीज
रिक्वेस्ट करते हो ना तो सर्वर रिस्पांस
करता है ना बबशूट में आपने देखा होगा
रिक्वेस्ट रिस्पांस उस रिस्पांस बॉडी में
एक टोकन वैल्यू दे देता है अब उस टोकन
वैल्यू के टोकन वैल्यू को क्या किया जाता
है ब्राउज़र के लोकल स्टोरेज में सेव कर
दिया जाता है जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड का यूज़
करके और उसी जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड का यूज़
करके फिर उसको क्या किया जाता है एज अ
हेडर में अटैच करके पास कर दिया जाता है
हर एक नए रिक्वेस्ट के साथ वन ऑफ़ द मोस्ट
कॉमन टाइप्स ऑफ़ टोकन इज़ jसon वेब टोकंस
JWT टोकंस इसके ऊपर ऑलरेडी जो है वीडियो
मैंने बना रखी है आपको jसon वेब टोकंस या
JW टोकंस के बारे में बहुत अच्छे से समझा
रखा है लाइव डेमोंस्ट्रेशन भी करके दिखा
रखा है नहीं देखा होगा तो पिछले वीडियोस
को आप देख लीजिएगा आपको जेडब्ल्यूटी के
बारे में पता चल जाएगा ठीक है
व्हिच आर पास थ्रू द ऑथराइजेशन बियर हेडर
अब ऐसे टोकन जो जैसे मान लो जेडब्ल्यू
टोकंस हैं इनको पास किया जाता है कौन से
हेडर से ऑथराइजेशन बियरर हेडर हाउएवर एज
वी आर नॉट यूजिंग द ब्राउज़र्स बिल्ड इन
कुकी मैनेजमेंट फीचर इट इज़ अ बिट ऑफ़ द
वाइल्ड वेस्ट वेयर एनीथिंग गोज़। ऑलदो देयर
आर स्टैंडर्ड्स नथिंग इज़ रियली फोर्सिंग
एनीथिंग फ्रॉम स्टिकिंग टू दिस
स्टैंडर्ड्स। ठीक है? तो मतलब कि सिंपल सा
फंडा है कि एक टोकन बेस्ड और एक कुकी
बेस्ड हो गया। टोकन बेस्ड जो है वो एक
हेडर के थ्रू जैसे मान लो ये JW टोकन की
बात करें। ऑथराइजेशन बियर हेडर के थ्रू जो
है ये हर रिक्वेस्ट के साथ जाती है। अब
बेनिफिट्स एंड ड्रॉबैक दोनों के बीच का हम
थोड़ा सा समझ लेते हैं। एंड देन उसके बाद
बहुत छोटा सा सिंपल सा है एक ये और उसके
बाद तो फिर मेन हमारा प्रैक्टिकल स्टार्ट
होगा जिसके लिए आप काफी टाइम से आप लोगों
में से कई लोग प्रैक्टिकल सिनेरियो के लिए
वेट कर रहे हैं क्योंकि उसमें आपको शायद
चीजें समझ में आएंगी। मैं आपको ओपन वीpए
का भी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन करके दिखाऊंगा। बहुत
लोगों को दिक्कत होती है। पता नहीं क्यों
दिक्कत होती है। वी विल सी कि व्हाई इट
शुड नॉट बी अ थिंग टू वरी।
साइबर गार्ड
हेलो सर फैज फ्रॉम दिस साइड
ठीक है करेंटली आई एम ऑन डे 22 एंड टिल
नाउ आई सबमिटेड टू स्टर्ड एक्सेस ऑन वर्क
क्राउड एंड गॉट $2 ऑफ़ ऑफ़ रिवॉर्ड। स्टिल
माय बोथ बग्स आर आउट ऑफ स्कोप एंड गॉट एंड
गॉट द बाउंट्री। अगर आपने आउट ऑफ स्कोप है
और बाउंट्री मिली है इसका मतलब है
प्रोग्राम ने आपको कंसीडर किया है कि ठीक
है हम इसके लिए आपको कुछ पैसे दे देते हैं
क्योंकि आपने एक रिलेटिवली मोर इंपैक्टफुल
वनेबिलिटी फाइंड करी है। इवन दैट इज़ आउट
ऑफ़ स्कोप। ठीक है? तो आप एक आप लकी हैं इस
इस पर्टिकुलर सिनेरियो में। आउट ऑफ स्कोप
के लिए बाउंड्रीज तो दूर की बात है। वह
एक्सेप्ट तक नहीं किए जाते।
ठीक है।
ठीक है। कोई सिस्टम स्पेसिफिकेशन तो चलो
बाद में बता दूंगा अभी उस पे अभी ज्यादा
बात नहीं करेंगे अभी। वी विल टॉक अबाउट से
सिस्टम स्पेसिफिकेशन लेटर ऑन। ओके? कुकी
इज़ ऑटोमेटिकली। हां। अब यहां पे दोनों के
बेनिफिट्स एंड ड्रॉबक्स के बारे में थोड़ी
सी बात कर लेते हैं एंड देन वी विल बी
मूविंग फॉरवर्ड। ठीक है? बहुत जल्दी हम
आगे आ जाएंगे प्रैक्टिकल पे भी। जिन लोगों
ने भी अभी तक जिनको मजा आ रहा है या मजा
आता है ऑब्वियस सी बात है तो लाइक ठोकते
जाइएगा। ठीक है? लाइक ठोकना बिल्कुल
मैंडेटरी है। इट्स मैंडेटरी राइट? लेट्स
स्टार्ट। चलिए अ कुकी
ड्रॉबैक्स एंड बेनिफिट्स देख लेते हैं।
कुकी सेशन मैनेजमेंट एंड टोकन बेस्ड सेशन
मैनेजमेंट। कुकी इज़ ऑटोमेटिकली सेंट बाय द
ब्राउज़र विद ईच रिक्वेस्ट। हर रिक्वेस्ट
के साथ कुकी को क्या करते हैं? ब्राउज़र
सेंड करता है। टोकन हैज़ टू बी सबमिटेड एज़
अ हेडर विथ ईच रिक्वेस्ट यूजिंग क्लाइंट
साइड जावास्क्रिप्ट। क्लाइंट साइड
जावास्क्रिप्ट का यूज़ होता है और टोकन को
एज अ हेडर जो है हर रिक्वेस्ट के साथ भेजा
जाता है। कुकी एट्रिब्यूट्स कैन बी यूज़्ड
टू इनस द ब्राउज़र्स प्रोटेक्शन ऑफ़ फॉर द
कुकी। मतलब कुकी के एट्रिब्यूट्स हैं।
जैसे कि ये कुछ एट्रिब्यूट्स हैं कुकी
वाले। इनका यूज़ करके और भी सिक्योर किया
जा सकता है कुकी के डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन को या
पाससेस को। टोकंस डू नॉट हैव ऑटोमेटिक
सिक्योरिटी प्रोटेक्शन इनफोर्स एंड शुड
देयर फॉर बी सेफगार्डेड अगेंस्ट
डिस्क्लोज़र। टोकंस का ऐसा कोई सिक्योरिटी
सेफ गार्डिंग नहीं होती है। लेकिन टोकंस
को हम क्या कर सकते हैं? ऐसे डिस्क्लोज़र
से बचा सकते हैं। उनको इनकोड कर सकते हैं।
उनको हम इंक्रिप्ट कर सकते हैं। देयर आर
मल्टीपल वेज़ मोस्टली इनकोडिंग्स का यूज़
किया जाता है टोकंस को इंकोड करने के लिए।
उनको हाइड करने के लिए। डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़
इनकोडिंग्स एंड इंक्रिप्शनंस आर बीइंग
यूज़्ड। एंड अगर वो ब्रेकेबल हो गया या
ब्रेक हो गया या किसी ने उस इंक्रिप्शन का
पता लगा लिया तो टोकंस को एक्सपोज किया जा
सकता है। टोकंस जो हैं वो चुराए जा सकते
हैं। एंड दैट कुड बी वेरी डिजास्टरस। ठीक
है? अब देखिए कुकीज़ कैन बी वलनेरेबल टू एक
सेकंड।
कुकीज़ कैन बी वनरेबल टू कन्वेंशनल क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स सच एज सीएसआरएफ वेयर द
ब्राउज़र इज़ स्ट्रिक्ट इंटू मेकिंग अ
रिक्वेस्ट ऑन बिहाफ ऑफ़ द यूजर। तो कुकीज़
इससे वनरेबल है। जैसे सीएसआरएफ काइंड ऑफ
अटैक से वनरेबल है। ये तो आप सब जानते भी
होंगे। आपने सीएसआरएफ वाली वीडियोस देखी
होंगी, क्लासेस देखी होंगी। तो मैंने आपको
उसमें भी बताया हुआ था किस तरीके से जो है
वो सीएसआरएफ को एग्जीक्यूट किया जाता है।
तो ये वनरेबल है सीएसआरएफ जैसे अटैक से।
एज़ द टोकन इज़ नॉट ऑटोमेटिकली एडेड टू एनी
रिक्वेस्ट एंड कैन नॉट बी रीड फ्रॉम लोकल
स्टोरेज बाय द अदर डोमेनस। अदर डोमेन से
भी इसको अदर डोमेन भी उसको लोकल स्टोरेज
से नहीं पढ़ सकता। कन्वेंशनल क्लाइंट सेड
अटैक सच ऐज़ सीएसआरएफ आर ब्लॉक्ड। जब टोकन
का यूज़ करते हैं जनरली तो सीएसआरएफ अटैक्स
जैसे अटैक्स जो हैं वो ब्लॉक हो जाते हैं।
हालांकि टोकन के भी केस में कई बार जो है
वो आप उसको अगर रिमूव कर दे कोई
मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशन हुई है तो कई बार सीएसआर
जैसे अटैक्स जो है वो एग्जीक्यूट हो जाते
हैं। मोस्टली बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट नहीं होंगे। एज़
कुकीज़ आर लॉक्ड टू अ स्पेसिफिक डोमेन इट
कैन बी डिफिकल्ट टू यूज़ देम सिक्योरली इन
डीसेंट्रलाइज़्ड वेब एप्लीकेशन। ये एक
स्पेसिफिक डोमेन के लिए लॉक होते हैं। तो
डिसेंट्रलाइज्ड एनवायरमेंट में इनको अदर
डोमेनस के साथ जो है यूज़ करना हो अगर तो
बहुत मुश्किल है। टोकंस वर्क वेल इन
डिसेंट्रलाइज़्ड वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस एज दे
आर मैनेज थ्रू जावास्क्रिप्ट एंड कैन ऑफेन
कंटेन ऑल द इनेशन रिक्वायर्ड टू वेरीफाई द
टोकन इटसेल्फ। तो टोकन को वेरीफाई करने के
लिए भी जो भी इनफेशन चाहिए होता है वो सब
उसमें होता है। तो कोई टेंशन वाली बात है
नहीं। आपने देखा होगा जे डब्ल्यूटी टोकंस
का एग्जांपल किस तरीके से वेरिफिकेशन
सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन उसमें होती है तो कोई
ज्यादा दिक्कत नहीं होती है। चलिए अब आ
जाते हैं यहां पे इंटरेस्टिंग चीज पे वो
क्या है
क्वेश्चन आंसर ₹00 तक की धनराशि आप जीत
चुके थे। अगला सवाल जो है वो है आपका
₹55,000 धनराशि के लिए। एंड आपके स्क्रीन
पे रहा यह सवाल। व्हाट कुकीज़ एट्रिब्यूट
कैन बी यूज्ड टू इंश्योर दैट द कुकी इज
ओनली ट्रांसमिटेड वाया सिक्योर एचटीटीपीएस
चैनल्स। बता दीजिए जल्दी बताइए। ओनली
ट्रांसमिटेड वाया सिक्योर एचटीटीपीएस चैनल
बताइए।
बताइए बताइए बताइए। ओनली ट्रांसमिटेड थ्रू
सिक्योर HTTPS चैनल। कौन सा कुकी का
एट्रिब्यूट यूज़ होता है? मैं आपको इसका
एट्रिब्यूट भी दिखा देता हूं। ये रहा
अब बता दीजिए
सेट कुकी क्या बोल रहे हो भाई कुछ भी कुछ
भी बोल रहे हो सेट कुकी कहां से होगा यार
एचटीपी ओनली अरे नहीं यार
सिक्योर
नहीं देखो देखो देखो यहां पे लिखा हुआ है
यार सिंपल लिखा हुआ है यहां पे सिंपल लिखा
हुआ है सिक्योर एट्रिब्यूट का जब यूज़
करेंगे इंडिकेट्स टू द ब्राउज़र दैट कुकी
मे ओनली बी ट्रांसमिटेड ओवर वेरीिफाइड
एचटीपीएस चैनल तो यहां पे सिक्योर होगा ना
यार इट्स सिक्योर सिंपल तो ये बाकी चीजें
क्यों बोल रहे हो सिक्योर इट्स सिक्योर
और यह सही जवाब आप जीत चुके हैं। पूरे
₹55,000 की धनुराशि मुबारक हो। व्हाट
एचटीटीपी हेडर यूज यूज्ड इन रिस्पांस टू
इनफॉर्म द ब्राउज़र दैट अ कुकी इज बीइंग
सेंट। व्हाट एचटीटीपी हेडर इज़ यूज्ड इन द
रिस्पांस टू इनफॉर्म द ब्राउज़र दैट अ कुकी
इज़ बीइंग सेंट। बताइए कुकी को भेजा जा रहा
है। यह कौन सा एचटीटीपी हेडर यूज़ किया
जाता है? मैं आपको यहां पे यह वाला
स्क्रीन सामने रख रहा हूं। इसी में आंसर
है इसका। बताइए। कुकी को भेजा जा रहा है
रिस्पांस हेडर के थ्रू। रिस्पांस में
सर्वर के साइड से। यह कौन से एचटीपी हेडर
के थ्रू पता चलता है?
वाह हैकर बॉय हैकर बॉय एंड रोबोट रोबोट
हैक्सर का। बिल्कुल सही जवाब है। इनको
स्पेशल देते हैं सेट कुकी।
इनको मिलती है स्पेशल धनराशि
पूरे ₹55,000 की। कांग्रेचुलेशंस
सेट कुकी होता है भाई।
बताया तो है यार यह सेट कुकी
यह वंस द वेब एप्लीकेशन वांट्स टू बिगिन
ट्रैकिंग रिस्पों्स। सेट कुकी हेडर वैल्यू
विल बी सेंट। यही तो है। सेट कुकी हेडर
वैल्यू। व्हाट एचटीटीपी हेडर इज ऑफेन
यूज्ड इन रिक्वेस्ट टू इंडिकेट द
ट्रांसमिशन ऑफ अ JWT?
JWT के ट्रांसमिशन के लिए कौन सा एचटीटीपी
हेडर रिक्वेस्ट में यूज़ किया जाता है? बता
दीजिए। कौन सा एचटीटीपी हेडर? बिल्कुल
सही। ऑथोराइजेशन बियरर बिल्कुल सही। कॉपी
मार लीजिए इसको। सो ऑथोराइजेशन बियरर यूज़
किया जाता है। आप सबको ऑलरेडी पता होना
चाहिए।
ऑथराइजेशन बी एरर इट्स ऑथोराइजेशन बी एरर
एंड इट्स करेक्ट बिल्कुल सही सो हमने इसको
भी पूरा सॉल्व कर लिया है एंड वी आर गुड
टू गो अब हमारे पास बची बस ये दो ये ये तो
कंक्लूजन है इसमें तो कुछ है ही नहीं
कंप्लीट पहले ही कर दो ये तो कंक्लूजन
हटाओ ये बच गई हमारे पास दो जिसमें एक ये
छोटा सा है उसके बाद हमारा है मेन
प्रैक्टिकल्स शनाड प्रैक्टिकल्स चलिए
सिक्योरिंग द सेशन लाइफ लाइफ साइकिल्स ये
बहुत छोटा सा वो है उम इसको हम थोड़ा कर
लेते हैं बढ़िया से कॉन्सेप्ट को। लाइफ़
साइकिल जो है सेशन का उसको सिक्योर करने
का तरीका। ठीक है? इट इज़ फाइनली टाइम टू
लर्न अबाउट सेशन मैनेजमेंट सिक्योरिटी।
गोइंग बैक टू आवर सेशन मैनेजमेंट लाइफ
साइकिल। लेट्स एग्जामिन व्हाट कैन गो
रॉन्ग एट ईच फेज। अब ये बता रहा है कि
सेशन लाइफ साइकिल जो है ना मैनेजमेंट का।
सेशन मैनेजमेंट का जो लाइफ साइकिल है, हर
लाइफ साइकिल में क्या-क्या दिक्कतें आ
सकती हैं? क्या-क्या वनेबिलिटीज़ हो सकती
हैं? गलतियां की जा सकती है जो सिक्योरिटी
पॉलिसी सेट करते हैं उनके द्वारा कि वह
वनरेबल हो सकते हैं। चलिए सेशन क्रिएशन की
पहले बात करेंगे। देन सेशन ट्रैकिंग की
बात करेंगे। देन सेशन एक्सपायरी एंड सेशन
टर्मिनेशन की बात करेंगे। तो मेनली हमारा
सेशन क्रिएशन में दिक्कतें आती हैं। उसको
देखते हैं। सेशन क्रिएशन इज़ वेयर द मोस्ट
वनेबिलिटीज़ कैन कप इन लेट्स ड्राइव इनू अ
कपल ऑफ़ कॉमन वंस। सबसे आती है पहले वीक
सेशन वैल्यूज़। इसका मतलब यह हुआ इट इज लेस
कॉमन टू सी अ वीक सेशन वैल्यू्यूज इन
मॉडर्न टाइम्स। आज के टाइम में
फ्रेमवर्क्स का यूज़ होता है। तो वीक सेशन
वैल्यू्यूज का होना ये तो बहुत मुश्किल
है। हाउएवर वि द राइज़ ऑफ़ एलएलएम्स एंड अदर
एआई कोड असिस्टेंट सॉलशंस यू वुड बी
सरप्राइज्ड एट हाउ ऑफेन दीज़ ओल्ड स्कूलज़
आर क्रिपिंग बैक इन। अब इसमें दिक्कत क्या
हो रही है कि एलएलएम्स का या एआई कोड
एडिटर्स का जमाना है। ठीक है? आप सबको पता
होगा एआई कोड एडिटर्स का जमाना है। आज के
टाइम में एi कोड एडिटर्स आ चुके हैं जहां
आप अपने प्र्प डालोगे और एi जो है उसका
कोड लिख के आपको दे देता है। जो बनवाना हो
जैसे बनवाना आजकल बहुत ज्यादा ना सीखते
हुए भी कई लोग डेवलपर का मतलब डेवलपर वाली
चीजें सीख चुके हैं एंड अच्छी खासी
डेवलपमेंट कर रहे हैं। तो ये काफी एक
अच्छी चीज है। बट इसके साथ दिक्कतें क्या
हो रही है? उनको कोड का बहुत ज्यादा
आईडिया नहीं है कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस का,
सिक्योरिटी कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस का। तो जब उसको
यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो उसमें आपको कई बार वीक
सेशन वैल्यूज़ मिल जाएंगे। और वीक सेशन
वैल्यू मिलने के कारण क्या होगा? दिक्कतें
आ जाएंगी। एंड वहां पे कुछ ऐसी वलेबिलिटीज़
अराइज़ हो जाएंगी जिससे कि वीक सेशन
वैल्यूज़ से होती है। इफ अ कस्टम सेशन
क्रिएशन मैकेनिज़्म हैज़ बीन इंप्लीमेंटेड।
अगर कोई कस्टम सेशन क्रिएशन का मैकेनिज़्म
है, देयर इज़ अ गुड चांस दैट द सेशन
वैल्यूज़ मे बी गेसबल। अगर कोई फ्रेमवर्क
यूज़ हो रहा है जो ऑलरेडी डिफाइंड है। तब
तो सेशन वैल्यू गसेबल या इजी नहीं होगी।
बट अगर कोई कस्टम ऐसा मैकेनिज्म है जिससे
सेशन वैल्यू क्रिएट की जा रही है तो वहां
पे देयर आर चांसेस कि सेशन वैल्यू को गेस
किया जा सकता है। अ गुड एग्जांपल ऑफ़ दिस
इज़ अ मैकेनिज्म दैट सिंपली बेस 64 इनकोड्स
द यूजर नेम एज़ द सेशन वैल्यू। कई लोग ऐसा
करते हैं कि जब सेशन वैल्यू जो होती है ना
यूजरनेम को ही बेस 64 से इनकोड करके उसको
सेशन वैल्यू की तरह पास कर देते हैं। अब
यह बहुत ही बेकार तरीका होता है। चाहे
यूजरनेम को आप पास कर दो या पासवर्ड को ही
आप बेस 64 इनकोड करके उसको एज अ सेशन
वैल्यू पास कर दो या किसी एक गेससेबल थिंग
को बेस 64 इनकोड या किसी भी तरह की अदर
इनकोडिंग्स जो कि इज़ली डिकोड हो सकती हैं
उसमें करके एंड उसको पास कर दो। तो ये गलत
चीज़ है। ये सही है। ये सही नहीं है। ऐसा
नहीं होना चाहिए। इफ अ थ्रेट एक्टर कैन
रिवर्स इंजीनियर द सेशन क्रिएशन प्रोसेस
दे कैन जनरेट और गेस सेशन वैल्यूस टू
हाईजेक द अकाउंट्स ऑफ लेजिट मटेरियल्स। तो
अगर किसी हैकर ने किसी अटैकर ने इसको
रिवर्स इंजीनियर कर लिया इस सेशन क्रिएशन
प्रोसेस को उस टोकन जनरेशन प्रोसेस को उस
वैल्यू जनरेशन प्रोसेस को वो बंदा ईज़ली
उसको गेस कर लेगा। एक अपना सेशन टोकन या
यू कैन से टोकन वैल्यू जनरेट कर लेगा। और
उससे क्या करेगा? पूरी की पूरी सेशन यानी
पूरी की पूरी विक्टिम को कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर
लेगा। उसके अकाउंट्स को कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर
लेगा। तो दिस इज़ द फर्स्ट गड़बड़ी फर्स्ट
प्रॉब्लम। सेकंड है कंट्रोलेबल सेशन
वैल्यूज़।
कंट्रोलेबल अपने से कंट्रोल करने वाली।
ठीक है?
यहां पे एक मैसेज है भैया। सर भारत का है।
सर आपकी वीडियो देख के हॉल ऑफ फेम पाया है
डेल में। एंड सर साइबर सिक्योरिटी की
फ्रेशर सैलरी कितनी होती है? वाओ। क्या
बात है भारत। कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू यू फॉर
गेटिंग ऑल ऑफ़ फेम इन डेल। आई थिंक मैंने
देखा था आपका पोस्ट साइड Lindin पे। एंड
एक साइबर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट या साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के अंदर फ्रेशर्स की सैलरी
आपकी स्किल्ड डिफाइन करता है, डिसाइड करता
है। कई फ्रेशर्स 15, 20,000 पे भी काम
करते हैं। कई ऐसे फ्रेशर्स हैं जिनकी
सैलरी मिनिमम 40 टू 5,000 से भी स्टार्ट
होती है। तो डिपेंड करता है आपके स्किल्स
पे एंड रिक्वायरमेंट्स जो उस पर्टिकुलर
कंपनी की तरफ से है, किस तरह का वर्क
एनवायरमेंट, किस तरीके की चीजें आपसे करा
रहे हैं। कितना वर्क लोड है, किस तरह का
काम आप कर रहे हैं, उसके ऊपर डिपेंड करता
है वो। ठीक है? नवल को नवल कोष्ी सर थैंक
यू थैंक यू जस्ट आपकी वजह से मेरा साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के स्टडीज अलग लेवल पर चली गई
है। बहुत सीखा हूं आपसे। सर पिछले एक
महीने में पांच बग्स हैकर वन पे सबमिट कर
दिया हूं। क्या बात है? क्या बात है नवल।
कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू यू। अ ह्यूज
कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू यू फॉर दिस। एंड आई होप
कि आप और अच्छा करते जाएं आगे चलके।
400 का कोई लैपटॉप मत लो। बेकार लैपटॉप
होगा वह।
थोड़ा वेट ही कर लो अगर चाहिए तो। ठीक है?
कंट्रोलेबल सेशन वैल्यूज़ क्या होते हैं?
इन सर्टेन टोकंस सच ऐज़ JWT ऑल द रिलेवेंट
इनफेशन टू बोथ क्रिएट एंड वेरीफाई द JWT
वैलिडिटी इज़ प्रोवाइडेड। JWT टोकंस ऐसे
होते हैं ना आपको पता ही होगा कि JWT
वेबसाइट जो है आप JWTओ वेबसाइट पे जाओगे।
इसके डीबगर पे यहां पर आप JSON वेब टोकन
डालोगे तो आपको पता होगा कि यहां पर हेडर
को डिकोड करने का पेलोड को डिकोड कर दिया
और यहां पे सीक्रेट की यहां पे आप डालते
हो। इस सीक्रेट की से आप इसको वेरीफाई कर
सकते हो। मतलब अब ये सीक्रेट की से क्या
होगा? ये उसको जनरेट कर सकता है उस टोकन
को। तो यहां पे इसी चीज की बात हो रही है।
इन सर्टेन टोकंस जस्ट सच एज जेडब्ल्यूटी
ऑल द रिलेवेंट इनफेशन टू बोथ क्रिएट एंड
वेरीफाई। वेरीफाई करने के लिए भी
जेडब्ल्यूटी उसी टोकन से वो पॉसिबल है।
वैलिडिटी इज़ प्रोवाइडेड इफ सिक्योरिटी
मेजर्स आर नॉट इनफोर्स सच एज वेरीाइंग द
टोकन सिग्नेचर। अगर टोकंस के सिग्नेचर को
वेरीफाई नहीं किया जा रहा है। अगर यह जो
मान लो ये सीक्रेट की है इसको अगर वेरीफाई
नहीं किया जा रहा है टोकन सिग्नेचर
और इंश्योरिंग द सिग्नेचर इटसेल्फ वाज़
क्रिएटेड सिक्योरली। सिग्नेचर जो है वो
सिक्योरली क्रिएट किया गया है। अ थ्रेट
एक्टर वुड बी एबल टू जनरेट देयर ओन टोकन।
तो तो क्या कर सकता है कोई हैकर? उस
सिग्नेचर का यूज़ करके खुद का टोकन जनरेट
कर सकता है हैकर। और उससे क्या होगा?
कॉम्प्रोमाइज अकाउंट कॉम्प्रोमाइज। दिस
टाइप ऑफ़ अटैक्स विल बी डिस्कस इन मोर
डिटेल। वो तो अलग से रूम है। ठीक है? अब
आते हैं सेशन फिक्सेशन पे। ये सारे सेशन
क्रिएशन के अंदर ही दिक्कतें जो हैं वही
हम देख रहे हैं। अब आते हैं सेशन फिक्सेशन
पे। रिमेंबर द वेब एप्लीकेशन दैट ऑलरेडी
गव यू अ सेशन बिफोर ऑथेंटिकेशन। कई ऐसे
वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस होते हैं जो बिना
ऑथेंटिकेशन के पहले ही आपको क्या करते
हैं? एक सेशन क्रिएट करके दे देते हैं।
ट्रैक करना शुरू कर देते हैं। दीज़ वेब
एप्लीकेशन कैन बी वनरेबल टू समथिंग कॉल्ड
सेशन फिक्सेशन।
इफ योर सेशन वैल्यू इज नॉट एडिक्वेटली
रोटेड वंस यू ऑथेंटिकेट। मतलब मान लो
मान लो कि मैं
यहां पे Flipkart पे ब्राउज़ कर रहा हूं।
लेट्स सपोज़ मैं यहां पे क्या कर रहा हूं?
Flipkart पे ब्राउज़ कर रहा हूं। अब ब्राउज़
करते-करते मुझे एक सेशन वैल्यू मिल गई।
सेशन वैल्यू मिल गई। अब मैं लॉग इन जब कर
रहा हूं और ये सेशन वैल्यू मान लो किसी ने
मेरा ये सेशन वैल्यू यहां से कॉपी कर
लिया। सेशन वैल्यू किसी ने एक्सपोर्ट कर
लिया।
अब मैं मान लो लॉगिन कर रहा हूं और लॉग इन
करने के बाद भी सेम सेशन वैल्यू रह रही
है। अगर उसको सही से रोटेट नहीं किया जा
रहा है, चेंज नहीं किया जा रहा है तो यह
बड़ी प्रॉब्लम है।
नॉट एडिक्वेटली रोटेटेड वंस यू ऑथेंटिकेट
अ सूटेबल पो सूटेबली पोजीशन थ्रेट एक्टर
कुड रिकॉर्ड इट व्हेन यू आर स्टिल अन
ऑथेंटिकेट एंड वेट फॉर यू टू ऑथेंटिकेट टू
गेन एक्सेस टू योर सेशन। यानी कि आप जब
ब्राउज़ कर रहे हो उसी टाइम में एक अटैकर
ने क्या किया? आपके सेशन को चुरा लिया।
जैसे मान लो Flipkart के केस में यहां पे
मैं यहां पे कोई सा भी कुछ भी यहां पे कर
रहा हूं। मैं यहां पे सेटिंग्स मोर टूल्स
पे जाके मैंने आपको दिखाया था Flipkart के
केस में यहां में यहां पे नेटवर्क पे जब
रीलोड करेंगे तो वी वर गेटिंग द
कुकीज़। मैं यहां पे दिखा देता हूं। जैसे
कि मैं Flipkart का कोई भी पेज एक्सेस कर
लेता हूं। मान लो यह पेज है। Flipkart का।
ठीक है?
सॉरी।
यह पेज है। मान लो कुकीज़ में चलते हैं। यह
रिस्पांस कुकी है। अब मान लो यहां पे यह
रिस्पांस कुकी है ना। अब मान लो यहां पे
रिस्पांस कुकी की वैल्यू है। यहां पे मान
लो ये कुकी है। इसकी एक वैल्यू है यहां
पे। ये वैल्यू है। ठीक है? ये जस्ट एक
एग्जांपल के लिए मैं आपको बता रहा हूं।
ठीक है?
मान लो ये वैल्यू है। ये मैंने कॉपी कर
लिया। अब ये अनऑथेंटिकेटेड वे में इस
वैल्यू को कॉपी कर लिया। अन अभी आपने लॉग
इन मैंने लॉग इन नहीं किया अपने अकाउंट
में। आई हैव जस्ट व्हाट आई आई हैव डन? आई
हैव जस्ट ब्राउजिंग। िंग आई एम जस्ट
ब्राउजिंग दिस एंड मैंने कॉपी कर लिया
अटैकर ने मेरे सेशन वैल्यू को। अब जैसे ही
मैं लॉगिन करूंगा उसको वो वो ट्रैक करता
रहेगा कि कभी लॉग इन करेगा लॉग इन करेगा।
तो सेम वैल्यू से अगर वो दूसरे ब्राउज़र
में उसको इंपोर्ट कर देगा वैल्यू को तो वो
मेरा सेशन जो है वो टेकओवर कर लेगा। सेशन
जो है उसके पास चली जाएगी। सेशन फिक्सेशन
इसको हम बोलते हैं वलेबिलिटी को कि बिना
ऑथेंटिकेटेड सेशन से एक ऑथेंटिकेटेड सेशन
को कैप्चर कर लेना। दिस इज़ समथिंग अ वेरी
ब्लंडर ऑफ मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशन जो काफी सारे
वेब एप्लीकेशन में पाया जाता है। पॉपुलर
वेब एप्लीकेशन में जनरली आपको नहीं
मिलेगा। बट कई ऐसे जो हैं वेब
एप्लीकेशनेशंस जहां पे डेवलपर्स जो हैं जो
ऐसे कुछ नए डेवलपर्स होते हैं जो ज्यादा
एक्सपीरियंस नहीं होते। ये गलतियां कर
देते हैं। तो ऐसी गलतियों का फायदा हैकर
उठा लेते हैं। राइट?
ओके
हां चलिए बढ़िया अब आते हैं नेक्स्ट पे
चलिए काफी अच्छी बात है 100 127 पीपल हैव
लाइक्ड 127 लाइक अरे आए तो काफी लोग थे
यार बस 127 लाइक मुझे लगता है कि 150
लाइक्स पूरा हो जाना चाहिए अभी यह खत्म
होते यह वाला पॉट
सेशन फिक्सेशन आई थिंक समझ में आपको आ
चुका होगा। अब आ जाते हैं इनसिक्योर सेशन
ट्रांसमिशन। इनसिक्योर सेशन ट्रांसमिशन
क्या है? इन मॉडर्न एनवायरमेंट्स इफ इट इज़
कॉमन फॉर द ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्वर एंड
एप्लीकेशन सर्वर्स टू बी डिस्टिंक्ट। मतलब
आज के टाइम में ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्वर एंड
एप्लीकेशन सर्वर्स दोनों अलग हो सकते हैं।
अब ये दोनों क्या है? मैं आपको बता देता
हूं। ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्वर जहां से आप
ऑथेंटिकेट करते हो खुद को। जैसे आपने
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड डाला। यह काम एक अलग
सर्वर कर रही है। उसको हम ऑथेंटिकेशन
सर्वर बोल देते हैं। और एक है एप्लीकेशन
सर्वर जहां से आप सर्विज को एक्सेस कर रहे
हैं। जैसे मान लो आपने Google.com मैं
मतलब एग्जांपल देता हूं। मान लो Google पे
गए। मान लो यहां पे एंड यहां पे Google
में आपने लॉग इन किया। तो यूजरनेम पासवर्ड
डाल के मैं यहां पे
मान लो आप Google पे गए एंड यहां पे आपने
साइन इन किया। अब यहां पे आपने यूजरनेम
पासवर्ड डाला। ठीक है? यूजरनेम पासवर्ड
डाला। तो यह एक ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्वर हैंडल कर
रही है। बट इसको इसको लॉगिन करने के बाद
जब आप दूसरे सर्विसेज एक्सेस कर रहे हैं
जैसे कि Gmail एक्सेस कर ले रहे हैं या
ड्राइव एक्सेस कर रहे हैं, Google ड्राइव
एक्सेस कर रहे हैं या आप Google बिनेस
एक्सेस कर रहे हैं, जेमिए एक्सेस कर रहे
हैं, शीट एक्सेस कर रहे हैं। ये काम
एप्लीकेशन सर्वर का हो जाता है। ये काम
कौन हैंडल करता है? एप्लीकेशन सर्वर। तो
दोनों डिवाइड हो गई है। ऑथेंटिकेशन
ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्वर हैंडल करेगा। एंड बाकी
जो प्रोसेससेस है जो एक्सेसिंग है वो
एप्लीकेशन सर्वर हैंडल करेगा। उसी की बात
हो रही है यहां ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्वर एंड
एप्लीकेशन सर्वर्स। ठीक है? थिंकिंग अबाउट
देखो यही चीजें होती हैं जो आपको समझनी
होती है चीजों को। जब आप खुद से ये सब
चीजें देखो इसलिए मेंटोरशिप की काफीेंस
होती है। मैं ऐसा मानता हूं मैं खुद ही एक
ऐसा इंसान हूं जो यह मानता है कि हर एक
लर्निंग हर एक चीजों और स्किल को खुद से
भी सीखा जा सकता है विदाउट द गाइडेंस ऑफ़
एनी एनीबॉडी। बट मैं ही वह भी इंसान हूं
जो यह भी मानता है कि कई ऐसी जगहों पर अगर
आपको एक मेंटोरशिप मिल जाती है, एक
गाइडेंस मिल जाती है, कोई आपको एक्सप्लेन
करने वाला बताने वाला मिल जाता है तो आपकी
जो स्पीड है वह काफी ज्यादा उस चीज को गैब
करने की बढ़ जाती है। एंड आप काफी ज्यादा
एक्सलरेटेड वे में आगे बढ़ते हैं। एंड
आपको उस चीज उसको समझ में आती है। आप में
से कई लोग यह जब रूम कर रहे होंगे तो मे
बी आप इसको स्किप कर देंगे पता है आपको आप
पढ़ेंगे पता है क्या होता है आप पढ़ेंगे
ऑथेंटिकेशन एप्लीकेशन अच्छा अच्छा हां ठीक
है कुछ होता होगा और आगे बढ़ के आपको आपका
फोकस रहेगा इसके क्वेश्चंस को आंसर करके
सही-सही करके कंप्लीट कर लेने का दैट्स इट
ऐसा होता है आप खुद ही आप खुद ही बताइए
मुझे ऐसा आपके साथ होता है कि नहीं होता
है ये एकदम ऑनेस्टली बोलिएगा कि आप इतना
एक-एक वर्ड पे ध्यान नहीं देते एक-एक वर्ड
का मतलब समझने की कोशिश नहीं करते हैं
बल्कि एक-एक वर्ड वर्ड में एक-एक कांसेप्ट
छुपा होता है। ऐसा कई लोगों के साथ होता
है। आप नहीं भी मानेंगे तो भी मैं जानता
हूं। मैं माइंडसेट जानता हूं उन लोगों की।
तो ऐसा होता है। तो ये चीजें यही बेनिफिट
है मेंटोरशिप का। जैसे अगर मैं आपको कोई
चीज बता रहा हूं, सिखा रहा हूं। अगर आप
यहां पे सीख रहे हैं तो आपको जरूर कुछ ना
कुछ एक्स्ट्रा देखने को मिलेगा, सीखने को
मिलेगा। क्योंकि आपका माइंड अलग है, मेरा
माइंड अलग है। थर्ड पर्सन किसी और का
माइंड अलग है। हो सकता है मैं आपको कुछ
अदर चीजें सिखा दूं। हो सकता है आपसे मैं
कुछ चीजें सीख लूं। दैट्स पॉसिबल। राइट?
चलिए
तो आपको समझ में आ गया होगा ऑथेंटिकेशन
सर्वर एंड एप्लीकेशन सर्वर क्या होते हैं?
क्या काम होता है? थिंकिंग अबाउट द थिंग्स
लाइक सिंगल साइन ऑन एसएसओ सॉलशंस जो होते
हैं सिंगल साइन ऑोन जैसे एक सिंगल साइन
ऑोन से मल्टीपल एप्लीकेशनेशंस को एक्सेस
किया जाता है। ठीक है? वन एप्लीकेशन इज़
यूज्ड फॉर ऑथेंटिकेशन टू सेवरल टू
ऑथेंटिकेशन फॉर ऑथेंटिकेशन टू सेवरल अदर
वेब एप्लीकेशन। सिंगल साइन ऑन वाले सॉलशंस
में क्या होता है? एक एप्लीकेशन का यूज
किया जाता है अदर बहुत सारे वेब एप्लीकेशन
को ऑथेंटिकेट करने के लिए। इन ऑर्डर फॉर
दिस प्रोसेस टू वर्क योर सेशन मटेरियल
मस्ट बी ट्रांसफरर्ड फ्रॉम वन ऑथेंटिकेशन
सर्वर टू द एप्लीकेशन सर्वर वाया योर
ब्राउज़र। यानी इसको वर्क करने के लिए क्या
होना पड़ता है कि आपका जो सेशन वैल्यू है
वो ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्वर से एप्लीकेशन सर्वर
तक ट्रांसफर होना चाहिए ब्राउज़र के थ्रू।
इन दिस ट्रांसमिशन हाउएवर सर्टेन इशूज़ कैन
क्रिप इन दैट वुड एक्सपोज योर सेशन इनफेशन
टू अ थ्रेट एक्टर। जब ये
ट्रांसफर प्रोसेस होता है ऑथेंटिकेशन
सर्वर से एप्लीकेशन सर्वर पे तब उस टाइम
में हो सकता है कोई अटैकर जो है आपके उस
वैल्यू को चुरा ले एंड वो किसी मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन की वजह से वो वैल्यू एक्सपोज
हो जाए। ठीक है? द मोस्ट कॉमन इज एन
इनसिक्योर रीडायरेक्ट वेयर द थ्रेट एक्टर
कैन कंट्रोल द यूआरएल वेयर यू विल बी
रीडायरेक्टेड टू पोस्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन। इसमें
एक सबसे बड़ी प्रॉब्लम आती है इनसिक्योर
रीडायरेक्ट। इनसिक्योर रीडायरेक्ट। जी
हां। इनसिक्योर रीडायरेक्ट प्रॉब्लम्स तब
आती हैं जब आप ऑथेंटिकेशन तो कर चुके हैं
लेकिन ऑथेंटिकेशन के बाद आप कहीं और
रीडायरेक्ट हो जाते हैं। आप सोचिए
ऑथेंटिकेशन के बाद आपको जाना किसी और पेज
पे। आपके पास सेशन वैल्यू है। आपके पास
सेशन वैल्यू है और आप चले जा रहे हैं किसी
और पेज पर। वहां से आपकी सेशन वैल्यू को
चुरा ली जा रही है और आपके सेशन को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया जा रहा है। कितना
मस्त प्रोसेस है। दिमाग में सोचिएगा तो
आपको समझ में आ जाएगा। राइट?
इट्स इट हैज़ बीन वन ईयर 8 मंथ्स फॉर दिस
सीरीज। थैंक्स हंटर एक्स फॉर काउंटिंग
दिस। एंड रियली आई एम ग्लैड कि मैं लास्ट
मोर देन 1.5 इयर्स से यह सीरीज चला रहा
हूं। आई नो कई बार डिलेज़ हुए हैं, कई बार
चीजें हुई हैं। बट स्टिल इट्स ऑनगोइंग एंड
इट विल कीप ऑन गोइंग। इसमें अदर चीजें जो
हैं, अदर थिंग्स आएंगी। पेन टेस्टिंग का
पार्ट आना शुरू होगा। अ ट्यूटोरियल्स आने
स्टार्ट होंगे। एसओसी और मल्टीपल चीजें
आनी स्टार्ट होंगी। बट दिस शो विल कीप ऑन
गोइंग। इट विल नॉट गोइंग इट इट इज़ नॉट
गोइंग टू स्टॉप एनी टाइम सून। सो बेफिक्र
रहिए। डीईएई की भी सीरीज आपकी बहुत जल्द
आएगी। डीईएई की सीरीज भी आपके लिए फिर से
रिज्यूम होगी। तो उसके लिए भी आपको टेंशन
नहीं लेनी है। उस सीरीज को रोका गया था।
उसके बाद कुछ इशूज़ आए जिसकी वजह से वो
रिज्यूम नहीं हो पाई। बट बहुत जल्द
स्टार्ट होगी। ठीक है?
ओके।
नहीं नहीं नेक्स्ट वीडियो कोई 3 मंथ के
बाद नहीं होगा यार जल्दी जल्दी अब होंगी
टेंशन नहीं लो लाइक ठोक दो फिर 3 महीने के
बाद नहीं होगी अगर तुमने लाइक को 150
लाइक्स कर दिया अरे यार 143 तो अभी हो गए
ठीक है ठीक है 150 ही कर लो चलो कोई बात
नहीं ओके
अब यहां पे आते हैं सेशन ट्रैकिंग सोचो ये
इनसिक्योर सेशन ट्रांसमिशन आपने समझ में आ
गया होगा सबको समझ में आया इनसिक्योर सेशन
ट्रांसमिशन कैसे होता है जब आप ऑथेंटिकेशन
से एप्लीकेशन सर्वर पे जाते हैं, भेजते
हैं। तो किस तरीके से बीच में से भी है जो
है आपके अह सेशन वैल्यू को चुराया जा सकता
है इनसिक्योर रीडायरेक्ट का यूज़ करके जहां
पे एक डिफरेंट इनसिक्योर पोर्टल पे आप
रीडायरेक्ट हो जाते हैं और अपनी सेशन
वैल्यू दे देते हैं। यू गॉट एवरीवन गॉट?
ओके। आप लोग रिप्लाई तो नहीं करते यार। ये
मजा नहीं आता। चलिए अभी तो आ रहे हैं हम
उस पे। अब आते हैं सेशन ट्रैकिंग से
रिलेटेड प्रॉब्लम्स की। ठीक है? सेशन
ट्रैकिंग्स में क्या होता है? सेशन
ट्रैकिंग इज द सेकंड लार्जेस्ट कल्पिट ऑफ
वनेबिलिटीज़। मतलब इसका सबसे पहले सेशन
क्रिएशन में सबसे ज्यादा वनेबिलिटीज़ अराइज़
होते हैं। दूसरा होता है सेशन के ट्रैकिंग
में। तो पहला वलेबिलिटी क्या होता है?
ऑथोराइज़ेशन बाईपास। यह तो आपने पढ़ा भी
होगा। ऑथोराइज़ेशन बाईपास अकर व्हेन देयर
आर नॉट सफिशिएंट चेकक्स बीइंग परफॉर्म्ड
ऑन वेदर ए यूजर इज़ अलाउड टू परफॉर्म द
एक्शन दे आर रिक्वेस्ट दे रिक्वेस्टेड।
ऑथराइजेशन चेक में प्रॉब्लम्स आती है। मान
लो आप यूजर हो। आप किसी वेब एप्लीकेशन पे
क्या कर रहे हो? आपने ऑथेंटिकेट कर लिया
है। अब आप उस वेब एप्लीकेशन के किसी एक
पोर्शन को एक्सेस करने के लिए ऑथेंटिकेटेड
हो। बट आप ऑथेंटिकेटेड तो हो किसी एक
पर्टिकुलर पोर्शन को एक्सेस करने के लिए
बट आप उसके अलावा भी और पोर्शन को एक्सेस
कर पा रहे हो जो आपको नहीं करना चाहिए था।
जो आपके लिए था ही नहीं। आपको परमिशन ही
नहीं था। देन उस केस में उसमें ऑथराइजेशन
बाईपास वलेबिलिटी आ जाती है। इन इन एसेंस
दिस फेल्स टू ट्रैक द यूजर सेशन एंड इट्स
एसोसिएटेड राइट्स करेक्टली। इट इज़ आल्सो
वर्थ टेकिंग वर्थ टॉकिंग अबाउट द टू
टाइप्स ऑफ़ ऑथोराइज़ेशन बायपासेस। मतलब
इसमें क्या होता है? जब ये प्रॉब्लम्स आती
है तो यूज़र्स के सेशन एंड इससे एसोसिएटेड
राइट्स को सही से ट्रैक नहीं किया जाता
है। एंड यहां पे प्रॉब्लम्स आ जाती है। दो
टाइप्स के होते हैं ऑथोराइजेशन बायपासेस
वर्टिकल एंड हॉरिजॉन्टल। वर्टिकल देखो
वर्टिकल यू कैन परफॉर्म यू कैन परफॉर्म एन
एक्शन दैट इज़ रिजर्व्ड फॉर अ मोर
प्रिविलेज यूजर। कोई मोर प्रिविलेज यूजर
के लिए कोई चीज है। उसको भी आप अगर कर पा
रहे हैं तो वो वर्टिकल बाईपास हो गया। तब
आप तो वर्टिकल ऑथोराइजेशन बाईपास कर रहे
हैं। यह थोड़ा लेस कॉमन है। हॉरिजॉन्टल
बाईपास ज्यादा कॉमन है। यू कैन परफॉर्म एन
एक्शन यू आर अलाउड टू परफॉर्म बट ऑन डेटा
सेट दैट यू शुड नॉट बी अलाउड टू परफॉर्म द
एक्शन। मतलब कि सिंपल सा फंडा है। इसका
एग्जांपल क्या है? आप एक घर में घुसने
आपका मान लो घर है। आप ही का घर है। चलो।
आप उसमें जाने के लिए अलाउड हो। और एक घर
है जहां पे आप अलाउड ही नहीं हो। ठीक है?
दोनों में डिफरेंस है। एक घर जहां आप एंटर
भी नहीं हो सकते उसमें एंटर होना मुश्किल
है। उसके अंदर की चीजों को करना मुश्किल
है। जो कि वर्टिकल बाईपास की बात हो रही
थी। बट हॉरिजॉन्टल बाईपास जहां पे आपके घर
के अंदर तो एंट्री है बट एक पर्टिकुलर रूम
का एंट्री आपके लिए नहीं है। तो आप घर में
तो घुस जाओगे। अब अगर रूम में भी घुस गए
उस रूम में जो आपके लिए अलाउड नहीं है तो
वर्टिकल बाईपास सॉरी तो हॉरिजॉन्टल बाईपास
कहलाता है वो। तो हॉरिजॉन्टल बाईपास ईजी
है क्योंकि एक बार जब आप कोई घर में घुस
गया तो कोई इतना कहां देखने जा रहा है यार
मतलब इजी है ना उसके लिए घर में नहीं घुस
पाया तो उसमें मुश्किल है तो घर में ना
घुस पाया तो वर्टिकल बाईपास है अगर फिर भी
कुछ कर पाया एंड हॉरिजॉन्टल बाईपास घर में
घुस के बाय कर रहे हैं दैट्स द मेन
डिफरेंस इन मोस्ट वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस
वर्टिकल बाईपासेस आर ईजी वर्टिकल बाईपासेस
आर ईजी टू डिफेंड अगेंस्ट मतलब वर्टिकल
बाईपासेस को डिफेंड किया जा सकता है
हाउएवर द हॉरिजॉन्टल बाईपासेस द यूजर इज
परफॉर्मिंग एन एक्शन दैट दे शुड बी अलाउड
टू परफॉर्म द इशू इज़ दैट दे परफॉर्मिंग इट
इन परफॉर्मिंग इट ऑन समवन एल्स डेटा किसी
और के डेटा पे ये परफॉर्म कर रहे हैं मतलब
अलाउड हैं बट अपने डेटा पे अलाउड थे बट वो
कर किसी और के डेटा पे रहे हैं टू रेमेडी
दिस द एक्चुअल कोड इज़ रिक्वायर्ड टू
वेरीफाई हु द यूजर इज व्हिच डेटा दे आर
रिक्वेस्टिंग एंड इफ दे आर अलाउड टू
रिक्वेस्ट अब इसके लिए एक मैनुअल जो है ना
कोड की जरूरत पड़ती है जहां से वो वेरीफाई
होता
सेशन से एक्सट्रैक्ट किया जाता है एंड
वेरीफाई होता है कि भैया यह कौन है यार
कहां से आया है? क्यों आया है? किस क्या
एक्सेस करने की इसके राइट्स हैं? परमिशंस
हैं, क्या नहीं है? वो सब देखा जाता है।
सो, दीज़ आर द टू टाइप्स ऑफ़ ऑथराइजेशन
बायपासेस। ठीक है? अब आते हैं सेशन
एक्सपायरी पे। सेशन एक्सपायरी ओनली हैज़ अ
सिंगल वलेबिलिटी व्हिच इज़ व्हेन द
एक्सपायरी टाइम ऑफ़ सेशन आर एक्सेसिव। मतलब
अगर कोई सेशन का एक्सपायरी टाइम बहुत
एक्सेसिव है तो यह वलेबिलिटी अराइज़ होती
है। अ सेशन शुड बी सीन एज अ टिकट टू अ
मूवी। ईच नाइट द सेम मूवी इज़ शोन बट वी डू
नॉट वांट समवन टू बी एबल टू यूज़ द सेम
टिकट टू वाच द मूवी अगेन। अब एक ही टिकट
ले लिया और उसी टिकट पे बार-बार एक ही
मूवी को देख रहे हैं। तो ये है सेशन
एक्सपायरी का वनेबिलिटी।
मतलब
कि एक ही सेशन वैल्यू से बार-बार सेशन में
लॉग इन कर पा रहे हैं। तो दिस इज़ द सेशन
एक्सपायरी वलेबिलिटी
इन द इवेंट ऑफ़ लॉन्ग लाइव सेशंस सच एज़ दोज़
फॉर अ वेबल क्लाइंट। द सेशन इटसेल्फ शुड
अटेस्ट टू द लोकेशन वेयर इट इज़ यूज़्ड।
मतलब ऐसा होना चाहिए कि अगर मान लो कोई
बहुत लंबे टाइम वाला सेशन है जिसकी
एक्सपायरी बहुत लंबा है तो उसको लोकेशन
वाइज़ टैग हो जाना चाहिए। कर देना चाहिए कि
अगर उस लोकेशन के अलावा कहीं और यूज़ हो
रही है तो वो ऑटोमेटिकली टर्मिनेट हो जाए
या एक्सपायर हो जाए एंड सेशन टर्मिनेट हो
जाए। ठीक है? अब है यहां पे सेशन
टर्मिनेशन। फॉर सेशन टर्मिनेशन द की इशू
इज़ व्हेन सेशंस आर नॉट प्रॉपर्ली
टर्मिनेटेड सर्वर साइड व्हेन द लॉगउ एक्शन
इज़ परफॉर्म्ड। जब आप लॉगउ कर रहे हैं तो
सर्वर साइड ना सेशन टर्मिनेट सही से नहीं
हो पा रहा। यह प्रॉब्लम। सपोज़ अ थ्रेट
एक्टर वेयर टू हाईजैक अ यूजर सेशन। सपोज अ
थ्रेट एक्टर्स वेयर टू हाईजैक अ यूजर सेशन
इन दैट केस इवन इफ द यूजर बिकम अवेयर ऑफ द
इशू विदाउट द एबिलिटी टू इनवैलिडेट सेशन
सर्वर साइड देयर इज़ नॉट अ मेथड फॉर द यूजर
टू फ्लश द एक्सेस ऑफ़ द थ्रेट एक्टर मतलब
यहां पे ये है आप समझ लीजिएगा कि ये सेशंस
की बात हो रही है ऑलरेडी जो ऑथेंटिकेटेड
यूजर हैं जैसे Instagram Facebook इन सब
में आप देखते होंगे Instagram पे जाओगे
सिक्योरिटी प्राइवेसी में तो वहां पे लिखा
रहता है लॉग्ड इन डिवाइसेस आपको मिलेगा
यानी कि उस आपके अकाउंट को जितने लोगों ने
जहां-जहां से भी एक्सेस करा है उन सबकी
वहां पे सेशंस होते हैं। इवन Windows में,
Google में सब जगह पे सॉरी Google के
अकाउंट में Gmail में भी आप जाओगे तो आप
देखोगे कि जहां-जहां से भी एक्सेस हो रही
है उसकी डिटेल्स होती है। तो वहां से आप
उनको लॉगउ कर सकते हो। बट कई ऐसे वेब
एप्लीकेशन जो होते हैं ये फीचर ये जो है
फीचर नहीं देते हैं। एंड इसका फायदा उठाया
जाता है कि एक बार अगर किसी ने सेशन को कर
लिया अपने एक्सेस में तो वहां उसको हटा
पाना बहुत ही मुश्किल हो जाता है। अगर कोई
लॉन्ग टर्म का सेशन वैल्यू एक्सपायरी
लॉन्ग टर्म एक्सपायरी वाला कोई सेशन
वैल्यू है तो सेशन वैल्यू जिसका बहुत लंबा
टर्म का वो है तो फिर दिक्कत है यहां पे।
ठीक है? अब देखिए हाउएवर दिस कैन बी
क्वाइट एन इशू फॉर टोकंस वेयर द लाइफ टाइम
ऑफ द टोकन इज एंबेडेड इन द टोकन इटसेल्फ।
यह टोकन वालों के लिए भी इशू हो सकता है
जहां कि लाइफटाइम टोकन के साथ ही एंबेडेड
होता है। इन दिस केस द टोकन कैन बी एडेड
टू द ब्लॉक लिस्ट टू बी वेरीिफाइड
अगेंस्ट। सम एप्लीकेशनेशंस आल्सो टेक दिस
फर्दर वेयर ऑल सेशंस ऑफ़ द यूजर कैन बी
व्यूड्ड एंड टर्मिनेटेड। यह वही बात हो
गई। कई ऐसे वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस होते हैं जो
ये फीचर डालते हैं जहां से आप सारे सेशंस
को देख सकते हैं। जैसे Instagram, Google
इन सबके पास होता है। उसको टर्मिनेट कर
सकते हैं। कई ऐसे नहीं करते हैं। तो वहां
पे उस केस में क्या होता है कि सेशन एक
बार कहीं पे किसी अटैकर के पास चला गया वो
उसी के पास रह जाएगा। अंटिल अनलेस कि वो
सेशन एक्सपायर ना हो जाए या जो भी सेशन
एक्सपायरी टाइम है वो रीच ना हो जाए। ठीक
है?
फ़दर मोर अपॉन अ सक्सेसफुल पासवर्ड रिसेट।
इट इज़ आल्सो रिकमेंडेड दैट ऑल सेशंस आर
टर्मिनेटेड टू अलाउ अ यूजर टू रीगेन फुल
कंट्रोल ऑफ़ देर अकाउंट। यह एक अच्छी
प्रैक्टिस एंड एक सिक्योरिटी प्रैक्टिस है
कि जब कोई यूजर अपना पासवर्ड रिसेट करता
है तो सेशन एक्सपायर हो जाना चाहिए। एंड
ये एक वनेबिलिटी है जो कई लोग फाइंड करते
हैं। जैसे एक अकाउंट में लॉगिन किया। मतलब
दो अकाउंट बना लिए। एक ही अटैकर ने एक
अकाउंट में लॉगिन किया। उसने वहां पे
लॉगिन करने के बाद सेशन को कॉपी कर लिया।
मतलब सेशन वैल्यू को कॉपी कर ली और
पासवर्ड को रिसेट कर दिया। अब उसके बाद
उसी सेशन वैल्यू को इंपोर्ट करके दूसरे
ब्राउज़र में वो सेम अकाउंट में लॉग इन भी
हो जा रहा है। यार यहां तो पासवर्ड रिसेट
कर दिया तो सेशन को एक्सपायर हो जाना
चाहिए था। उस पर्टिकुलर वैल्यू को खत्म हो
जानी चाहिए थी। टर्मिनेट हो जानी थी सेशन
को बट नहीं हुआ तो दिस इज़ अ वन एबिलिटी।
ये आप रिपोर्ट भी कर सकते हो। कई जगह पे
इसको एक्सेप्ट किया जाता है। मतलब अगर
इंपैक्ट अच्छा हुआ तो अच्छी खासी मतलब
आपको रिस्पांस भी मिल जाएगी। चलिए
अब यहां पे क्वेश्चंस आंसर करते हैं।
हमारी नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन जो है अ
हमारे ₹60,000 धनराशि के लिए आपके स्क्रीन
पे यह हमारा सवाल है। व्हाट फेज ऑफ द सेशन
मैनेजमेंट लाइफ साइकिल वुड बी वनरेबल इफ
यू कुड प्रिडिक्ट व्हाट द वैल्यू ऑफ़ सेशन
वुड बी? सेशन की वैल्यू अगर आपने
प्रेडिक्ट कर ली तो कौन सा लाइफ साइकिल
वनरेबल होगा? बताइए। सेशन की वैल्यू अगर
आपने प्रेडिक्ट कर ली।
और लोग बताइए बाकी लोग भी बताइए। अजू ने
बोला है सेशन क्रिएशन। बाकी लोग बताइए।
यहां क्वेश्चन है व्हाट फेज ऑफ़ सेशन
मैनेजमेंट लाइफ साइकिल वुड बी वनरेबल इफ
यू कुड प्रेडिक्ट व्हाट द वैल्यू ऑफ़ अ
सेशन वुड बी? बताइए।
एनीवन एल्स देन तारिक अहमद
अजू सेशन क्रिएशन तारिक अहमद सेशन क्रिएशन
सेशन क्रिएशन
सेशन सेशन क्रिएशन हमने सेशन क्रिएशन में
ही यहां पे देखा था अ मल्टीपल वलेबिलिटीज़
को सबसे ज्यादा वलेबिलिटी सेशन क्रिएशन
में ही आपकी मिल जाती है। तो हम यहां पे
डालते हैं सेशन
क्रिएशन एंटर करते हैं यहां पे। एंड दिस
इज़ द करेक्ट आंसर। ठीक है? ठीक है?
क्योंकि ऑब्वियस सी बात है यहां पे कि
सेशन की वैल्यू प्रेडिक्ट अगर आप कर पा
रहे हैं जो कि हमने पहले ही देखा था वीक
सेशन वैल्यू्यूज तो ये सेशन क्रिएशन के
अंदर में ही है तो ये सही जवाब है। आप जीत
चुके हैं पूरे ₹60 आप लोग जीत चुके हैं।
ठीक है? अगला सवाल है अ
सीधा 5 लाख के लिए। सॉरी 60 आपने 60 लाख
जीता है। 60 लाख 60 नहीं जीता है। 60 लाख
आपने जीता है। ठीक है? अब अगला सवाल है।
प्लीज डोंट आंसर आप पहले ही प्लीज आंसर मत
कीजिए। बाकी लोगों को भी आंसर करने दीजिए
ताकि बाकी लोग भी सीखें। राइट? व्हाट फेज
ऑफ द सेशन मैनेजमेंट लाइफ साइकिल वुड बी
वनेरेबल इफ यू डोंट हैव द एबिलिटी टू फ्लश
अ थ्रेट एक्टर्स एक्सेस टू योर सेशन?
थ्रेट टू फ्लश थ्रेट एक्टर्स एक्सेस टू
योर सेशन। यह बताइए इसका आंसर। यह है आपके
70 लाख की धनराशि।
₹0 लाख की धनराशि के लिए यह सवाल है।
व्हाट फेज ऑफ द सेशन मैनेजमेंट लाइफ
साइकिल वुड बी वनरेबल इफ यू डोंट हैव द
एबिलिटी टू फ्लश अ थ्रेट एक्टर्स एक्सेस
टू योर सेशन? थ्रेट एक्टर्स के सेशन को आप
फ्लश नहीं कर सकते तो कौन सा होगा? सेशन
क्रिएशन तो होगा नहीं। उसके बाद सेशन
ट्रैकिंग
ऐसा कुछ नहीं है। सेशन एक्सपायरी
नहीं है। सेशन टर्मिनेशन
जिसमें कि आप
फ्लश द एक्सेस ऑफ़ द थ्रेट एक्टर जिसमें कि
आप क्या कर सकते हैं? थ्रेट एक्टर के
एक्सेस को फ्लश कर सकते हैं। वो है आपका
टर्मिनेशन। तो सेशन टर्मिनेशन आपका यहां
पे आंसर होगा। बिल्कुल सही है। आंसर सही
है आप लोगों का।
अब्सोलुटली राइट।
सेशन टर्मिनेशन इज़ द आंसर। सो, इज़ द
करेक्ट आंसर। आप जीत चुके हैं ₹70 लाख की
धनराशि। मुबारक हो। कांग्रेचुलेशंस। व्हाट
फज़ ऑफ़ द सेशन मैनेजमेंट लाइफ साइकिल वुड
बी वनेरेबल इफ देयर वाज़ नॉट सफिशिएंट
इनेशन टू पीस टुगेदर व्हाट हैपेंड
ड्यूरिंग एन इंसिडेंट? अगर ड्यूरिंग
इंसिडेंट क्या हुआ है? उसको अगर एक साथ
कलेक्ट करके करने की ना हो तो क्या है वह?
कौन सा कौन सा सेशन मैनेजमेंट लाइफ साइकिल
का वह मलरेबल होगा? बताइए।
बताइए कौन सा होगा? जब उसको प्रॉपर्ली लॉक
ना किया जा रहा हो। प्रॉपर्ली इंसिडेंट के
टाइम में हमें उसका इंफॉर्मेशन ना मिले तो
उसमें कौन सा लाइफ साइकिल सेशन लाइफ
साइकिल जो है वो वनरेबल होगा?
बताइए बताइए।
नहीं पता ना इसका इसका आंसर है सेशन
एंड
इंसिडेंट के ड्यूरिंग अगर सही से लॉगिंग
ना हो इनसफिशिएंट लॉगिंग हो सही से लॉगिंग
ना की जाए वो किस में आती है सेशन
ट्रैकिंग में तो यहां पे सेशन ट्रैकिंग ही
तो होगा ना यार
सिंपल इनसफिशिएंट लॉगिंग तो सेशन ट्रैकिंग
होगा
राइट सो इट्स सेशन ट्रैकिंग ध्यान नहीं दे
रहे हैं आप लोग ध्यान दीजिए इधर ध्यान
दीजिए पहले इधर ध्यान दीजिए सभी।
उसके बाद है व्हाट फेज ऑफ़ सेशन मैनेजमेंट
लाइफ साइकिल वुड बी वनरेबल इफ द
या इफ द सेशन वैल्यू इटसेल्फ वाज़
ट्रांसमिटेड थ्रू एन इनसिक्योर
रीडायरेक्ट। इनसिक्योर रीडायरेक्ट से अगर
सेशन वैल्यू ट्रांसमिट हो रही है तो ये
अभी हमने रिसेंट में देखा था कि अगर
इनसिक्योर रीडायरेक्ट हो रही है तो किसके
थ्रू होती है वह? किसके थ्रू होती है?
किसके थ्रू होती है? इनसिक्योर
इनसिक्योर रीडायरेक्ट बताइए
यह आपने देखा था यहां पर करेक्ट सही जवाब
है अजू इनसिक्योर रीडायरेक्ट यह आपने देखा
तो था यहां पे इनसिक्योर ट्रांसमिशन जो
होती है सेशन ट्रांसमिशन उसके अंदर हमने
देखा था इनसिक्योर सेशन ट्रांसमिशन तो ये
आती है सेशन क्रिएशन में तो इसका आंसर जो
है वो वही है हमारा सेशन क्रिएशन
दैट्स इट
एंड इसका भी जवाब सही है तो हमने इसको भी
सॉल्व कर लिया है एंड कांग्रेच
आप सब जीत चुके हैं इसको इसको करने के बाद
1 करोड़ की धनराशि करोड़ धनराशि जीत चुके
हैं आप सब बन चुके हैं करोड़पति आप सबको
बहुत-बहुत कांग्रेचुलेशंस एंड बधाई हो
करोड़पति बनने के लिए अब जो है अगला है
हमारा प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन पार्ट
जिसको अगर आपने थोड़ा दिमाग लगा लिया तो
आप बन सकते हैं ₹1 करोड़ के हकदार ₹1
करोड़पति
सर मैंने गलती से एक बग बाउंड्री
प्रोग्राम के टारगेट वेबसाइट पे एफएफ यूएफ
से फजिंग करने वाला था लेकिन गलती से एक
दूसरे छोटी वेबसाइट में कर दिया उसका
डोमेन भी सेम ही था। कोई बात नहीं कुछ
नहीं होगा। कोई टेंशन मत लो। कुछ नहीं
होगा।
कुछ नहीं होगा। टेंशन नहीं लेना है। ठीक
है? चलिए
अब यहां पे आते हैं एक्सप्लइटिंग
इनसिक्योर सेशन मैनेजमेंट। अब हम
एक्सप्लइट करेंगे इनसिक्योर सेशन
मैनेजमेंट को। ठीक है? तो यहां पर बेसिकली
एक मशीन है। इसको हमें स्टार्ट करना है।
यहां पे लिखा हुआ है।
हम इसके प्रैक्टिकल को देखेंगे। तो पहले
मशीन को यहां पे स्टार्ट करते हैं। जस्ट
लेट इट स्टार्ट।
मशीन स्टार्ट होगी एंड यहां पर आईपी आपको
आ जाएगी। थोड़ी देर में आईपी यहां पे आपके
सामने आ जाएगी।
देन वी विल बी डूइंग स्टार्टिंग दिस
थिंग्स। मशीन स्टार्ट करने के बाद क्या
है? पहला है इनमरेशन प्रोसेस। पहला जो
हमारा प्रोसेस है यहां पे इन्यूमरेशन का
प्रोसेस है जिसमें कि सारी चीजें यहां पे
दे रखी हैं। अलग-अलग प्रोसेससेस हैं वो
करने के लिए।
चलिए आते हैं।
लेवरेजिंग द नॉलेज यू हैव गेन। इट इज टाइम
टू एक्सप्लोर हाउ द सेशन मैनेजमेंट लाइफ
साइकिल कैन बी मैप्ड आउट एंड टेस्टेड।
स्टार्ट द मशीन बाय प्रेसिंग द स्टार्ट
मशीन बटन एट द टॉप ऑफ़ दिस टास्क एंड लेट्स
गेट हैकिंग। यू मे एक्सेस द वीएम यूजिंग
अटैक्स बॉक्स और योर वीपीएन कनेक्शन। ठीक
है? तो इसको हम अटैक बॉक्स या वीpए
कनेक्शन से एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। जैसे कि
हमारे पास IP आ गई है। अब हम या तो देखो
दो ऑप्शंस होते हैं। अगर आपने पेड परचेस
किया हुआ है प्रीमियम प्लान तो आप काली
एंड अटैक बॉक्स दोनों यूज़ कर सकते हैं।
अटैक बॉक्स काफी स्लो मुझे लगता है काम
करता है। काफी काफी स्लो होता है। तो मैं
इसको यूज़ नहीं करूंगा। मैं काली वाला यूज़
करूंगा। वेब बेस्ड काली मशीन। तो मैं काली
मशीन को यहां पे स्टार्ट कर देता हूं।
लेट्स स्टार्ट द काली मशीन। आप इसको वीpए
के थ्रू भी एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। जैसे मेरे
पास ओपन वीpए का कॉन्फ़िगरेशन मैंने डाल
रखा है। ये रहा ओपन वीpए राइट क्लिक करके
कनेक्ट करूंगा। ये यहां से भी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
यहां पे इसकी हो जाएगी। तो, आप वो भी कर
सकते हैं। राइट राइट राइट डन डन डन। तो,
हमारी मशीन स्टार्ट हो रही है। इसमें थोड़ा
सा टाइम लगता है बट इट्स वर्थ वेटिंग
स्टार्टिंग दिस मशीन। सो वी विल वेट।
इट्स स्टार्टिंग
ओके इसका पार्ट टू भी आएगा देखेंगे अगर
जरूरत पड़ेगी ऐसी ही कुछ पार्ट टू की तो
बिल्कुल लेकर आएंगे
ठीक है
परमजीत सिंह सर आई गॉट 10 प्लस हॉल ऑफ फेम
एंड रिकॉग्निशन ऑल बाय सीइंग योर
प्लेलिस्ट थैंक्स अ लॉट फॉर द सीरीज
परमजीत आई आई एम ग्लैड कि आपको 10 प्लस
हॉल ऑफ एम मिले ग्रेट कांग्रेचुलेशंस
परमजीत कांग्रेचुलेशंस चलिए यहां पे आ
चुके हैं यहां पे हमने ये चीज कर लिया है
अब इसको ना मैं फुल फुल स्क्रीन करने की
कोशिश करता हूं।
हां जी। ये रही। तो यहां पे फुल स्क्रीन
यहां तो हो चुकी है ये बट उधर वो वो गायब
हो चुका है। आई थिंक
ठीक है। इसको हम ले लेंगे। फुल स्क्रीन कर
लेंगे बाद में। अब यहां पे आते हैं
क्वेश्चंस के ऊपर में। इनमरेशन क्या है?
यहां पे IP आ चुकी है। यह हमारा टारगेट
IPपी है। तो, इसको ना हम इसको ओपन कर लेते
हैं। इसको हमने कॉपी किया एंड वेब ब्राउज़र
Firefox स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं।
एंड हियर आई एम गोइंग टू स्टार्ट दिस
टारगेट। तो यहां पे हमने टारगेट को एक्सेस
कर लिया।
सो इट इज़ गेटिंग एक्सेस। आ गई। चलिए।
यह आ रहा है कि लेट्स नेविगेट टू आवर
एप्लीकेशन एंड वी शुड बी सीइंग द फॉलोइंग
पेज। ठीक है? अब वी फर्स्ट नोटिस दैट वी
आर नॉट प्रेजेंटेड विद एनी कुकी और टोकंस
व्हेन वी फर्स्ट विजिट द पेज। ठीक है?
इसको भी हम देख लेते हैं कि भैया हमें कुछ
मिला है कि नहीं मिला है। तो हम यहां पे
आए हैं। अब इसके डेवलपर टूल्स को ओपन कर
लेते हैं।
Firefox में मोर टूल्स में चलते हैं। वेब
डेवलपर टूल्स को ओपन करते हैं। एंड यहां
देखते हैं हमें कुछ नेटवर्क पे चलते हैं।
नेटवर्क पे यहां पे हमें कुछ कुकी वगैरह
मिली है कि नहीं। मैं इसको रीलोड करता हूं
इस पेज को।
एंड इसको मैं थोड़ा सा ऊपर की तरफ करता
हूं। बड़ा करता हूं ताकि आपको दिख जाए।
एंड यहां मैं देखता हूं कि कोई सा भी एक
ऑथ लॉगिन पेज है ना ऑथ लॉग इन पेज। तो
चलिए ऑथ लॉग इन पेज ओपन कर लेते हैं।
ये रहा लॉग इन पेज। लॉग इन पेज पे आएंगे।
इसको थोड़ा सा मैं बड़ा कर रहा हूं।
हम यहां पे लॉग इन पेज में आएंगे। यहां पर
आप बेसिकली देखेंगे हियर कुकीज़ में तो
यहां पे आ रहा है नो कुकीज़ फॉर दिस
रिक्वेस्ट। हेडर्स में भी आएंगे तो आपको
कुछ भी यहां पे देखने को बेसिकली नहीं
मिलता है। यहां पे सिंपल इन्होंने क्या
लिखा हुआ है? यहां पे क्या लिखा हुआ है?
ये बेसिकली स्टोरेज में जाके चेक कर रहे
हैं कि नो डेटा प्रेजेंट फॉर सिलेक्टेड
होस्ट। और हमने यहां पे स्टोरेज में नहीं
चेक किया। हमने कहां पे क्या चेक किया?
हमने सीधा नेटवर्क टैब पे ही इस रिक्वेस्ट
के लिए चेक कर लिया है। आप किसी पे भी चेक
कर सकते हैं। यहां पे कुकीज़ में कोई कुकी
वैल्यू नहीं है। स्टोरेज में भी जाएंगे तो
आप सिमिलर यहां पे देख सकते हैं। कुकी
वैल्यू जो है स्टोरेज में यहां पे इस
तरीके से दिखेगी आपको। तो यहां पे इस
पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल के लिए नो डेटा इज़
प्रेजेंट। ठीक है? अभी कोई भी कुकी वैल्यू
नहीं है। चलिए
दिस टेल्स अस दैट अनऑथेंटिकेटेड सेशंस आर
मोस्ट लाइकली नॉट बीइंग ट्रैक्ड। इसका
मतलब है कि अन ऑथेंटिकेटेड जो सेशंस हैं
उनको ट्रैक यहां पे नहीं किया जा रहा है
इस पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के लिए इस पर्टिकुलर
वेब एप्लीकेशन के तरफ से। इफ वी क्लिक द
साइन अप बटन वी सी दैट देयर आर टू मेन
साइन अप्स स्टूडेंट एंड लेक्चरर। दिस कैन
बी यूज़्ड बाय एनीवन टू क्रिएट अ स्टूडेंट
प्रोफाइल एंड रिक्वायर्स अ वेरिफिकेशन कोड
फॉर द साइन अप प्रोसेस। एंड जब आप लेक्चरर
करेंगे तो इसके लिए एक साइन अप प्रोसेस के
लिए वेरिफिकेशन कोड आपसे मांगा जाएगा।
चलिए।
दिस शोज़ अस दैट इवन विदाउट एनी ब्रूड
फ़ोर्स टेक्निक्स वी कैन किक ऑफ द सेशन
मैनेजमेंट लाइफ साइकिल बाय क्रिएटिंग अ
स्टूडेंट अकाउंट। लेट्स क्रिएट अ स्टूडेंट
अकाउंट एंड सी व्हाट हैपेंस। तो यहां पे
एक एक स्टूडेंट अकाउंट क्रिएट किया जा रहा
है। ठीक है ना? एंड उसके बाद आफ्टर
क्रिएटिंग द यूजर अकाउंट वी रिसीव अ
प्र्प्ट दैट द यू यूजर अकाउंट हैज़ बीन
क्रिएटेड एंड वी आर नेविगेटेड बैक टू द
लॉग इन पेज। लेट्स परफॉर्म परफॉर्म अ
लॉगिन ऐज़ आवर यूजर एंड मॉनिटर द नेटवर्क
ट्रैफिक। ठीक है? ठीक है? तो एक यूजर
अकाउंट बना लेना है एंड उसको मॉनिटर करनी
है। चलिए अच्छी बात है। तो मैं यहां पे
क्या करता हूं? इसको नीचे करते हैं।
साइन अप
और यहां पे हम रजिस्टर एज स्टूडेंट करते
हैं। तो स्टूडेंट का नाम मैं यहां पे डाल
देता हूं। एना
एना टैकर
एना टैकर करके नाम दे दिया। यूजरनेम दे
दिया एन टी ए सी के ई आर एना टैगर दे दिया
पासवर्ड में मैंने कुछ भी पासवर्ड दे दिया
एंड मैं यहां पे साइन अप कर लेता हूं ठीक
है
डोंट नेवर सेव मैंने जैसे ही साइन अप किया
हमारे पास ये आ गया वापस से लॉग इन पेज आ
गई जैसा कि इन्होंने बोला था अब यहां पे
क्या करते हैं हम नेटवर्क टैब पे चलते हैं
यहां पे अभी फिलहाल तो कुछ भी नहीं हो रहा
है नेटवर्क टैब पे चलते हैं एंड हम यहां
पे लॉग इन करते हैं। लॉग इन करने के लिए
यूजर नेम एना अटैकर एंड हमने जो पासवर्ड
दिया था वो पासवर्ड यूज़ करेंगे। अब यहां
पे ये क्या बोल रहा है कि लेट्स लॉग इन
एंड परफॉर्म द नेटवर्क मॉनिटर टैब। दिस
टेल्स अस क्वाइट अ बिट ऑफ़ इनफेशन। कुकीज़
आर बीइंग यूज़्ड फॉर सेशन मैनेजमेंट। जब हम
लॉगिन करने के बाद जब हम देखेंगे ना
नेटवर्क टैब को तो उसमें हमें पता चलेगा
कि कुकीज़ का यूज़ किया जा रहा है सेशन
मैनेजमेंट के लिए। http ओनली फ्लैग इज़
सेट। व्हिच मींस वी डू वुड नॉट बी एबल टू
लेवरेज जावास्क्रिप्ट टू रीड द कुकी
वैल्यू। तो आप जो डॉक्यूमेंट डॉट कुकी
वाली जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड यूज़ करते हो या
कोई भी कुकी एक्सट्रैक्टिंग जावास्क्रिप्ट
कोड यूज़ करते हो तो उसको यहां पे आप
लेवरेज नहीं कर सकते। यूज़ नहीं कर सकते। द
कुकी एक्सपायरी टाइम सीम्स वियर्ड सिंस
बोथ द क्रिएशन एंड एक्सपायरी टाइम्स फॉर द
कुकीज़ आर एग्जैक्ट सेम। तो इसका जो
क्रिएशन एक्सपायरी टाइम है कुकी का वो
थोड़ा सा वियर्ड है। दोनों ऑलमोस्ट सेम है।
तो चलिए इसको हम लाइव करके भी देख लेते
हैं। तो यहां पे हमने अकाउंट बना लिया था।
अब हम यहां पे इसको ऊपर की तरफ लेकर आते
हैं। और यहां पे हम करते हैं लॉग इन।
लॉग इन के लिए एना टैकर एंड पासवर्ड में
जो हमने पासवर्ड दिया था वो पासवर्ड करते
हैं। एंड अब हम यहां पे करते हैं लॉग इन।
लॉग इन हो चुका है। अब हम लॉग इन जब कर
चुके हैं तो आप देखेंगे यहां पे इस पेज को
मैं रीलोड करूंगा। लॉग इन करने के बाद तो
नेटवर्क टैब हमारा पॉपुलेट हो जाएगा। कुछ
इस तरीके से हमारा पेज वापस से रीलोड हो
जाएगी। डैशबोर्ड यहां पे इस तरीके से आ
जाएगा। एंड यहां पे आपको मॉड्यूल्स वगैरह
जो है वो दिखेंगे। ठीक है? जिसमें एनरोल
स्टूडेंट्स वन टू वन ऐसे कुछ करके लिखा
रहेगा। अब यहां पे आप जब जाएंगे डैशबोर्ड
कार्ड्स डॉट जब हम ऊपर के पेज पे आते हैं।
ये रहा
हेडर्स पे चलते हैं। जब हेडर्स पे चलेंगे
तो यहां पे
कुछ खास हमें देखने को नहीं मिल रहा।
मॉड्यूल्स पर चलते हैं।
लेट्स रीलोड दिस पेज। लेट्स गो टू द
मॉड्यूल्स पेज।
चलिए अब हम यहां पे जस्ट अ सेकंड। अब हम
यहां पे मॉड्यूल्स पे चलते हैं। मॉड्यूल्स
पे चलेंगे। मॉड्यूल्स पे आएंगे तो यहां पे
हमें हेडर्स दिखेंगी। हेडर्स जब दिखेंगी
तो यहां पर रिक्वेस्ट हेडर दिखेगा आपको।
यहां कुछ रिस्पांस हेडर्स आपको देखने को
मिलेंगे। यहां पे कुकीज़ में जाएंगे तो
यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट कुकीज़ देखने को
मिलेंगे। अब हम यहां पे चलते हैं वापस से
इस पे एंड यहां पे देखते हैं व्हिच पेज।
दिस इज़ द लॉग इन पेज। ये यहां पे लॉग इन
पेज को एक्सेस कर रहे हैं। जैसे यहां पे
लॉग इन किया। इन्होंने लॉग इन पेज को
एक्सेस किया है। तो लॉगिन पेज को हम एक
बार एक्सेस करके चेक आउट कर लेते हैं।
व्हाट इनेशन डू वी हैव ओवर द लॉग इन पेज।
सो लेट्स गो टू द लॉगिन पेज।
कहां गई लॉग इन पेज हमारी?
हम हम
ये
नहीं नहीं ये तो सॉरी 304 ये दूसरा पेज
है।
200 ओ लॉग इन पेज वी हैव टू फाइंड। सो
यहां पे अभी नहीं मिलेगा। एक काम करते
हैं। इसको फिलहाल के लिए मैं लॉग आउट कर
देता हूं। अगेन रीलोड करता हूं।
अगेन जो है इसको मैं क्या करता हूं?
नेटवर्क टैब ओपन कर लेते हैं। मोर टूल्स
पर जाकर।
एंड यहां पर लॉग इन करते हैं। लॉग इन में
हम करते हैं एना टैकर एंड पासवर्ड जो हमने
पासवर्ड डाला था वो पासवर्ड डाल देते हैं।
एंड यहां पे हम लॉग इन कर लेते हैं। ठीक
है? लॉग इन जैसे ही किया अब हमारे पास एक
लॉग इन पेज आ गया। यहां पे वी हैव द लॉग
इन पेज हियर। पोस्ट एंड ऑप्शंस दो यहां पे
है। अब लॉग इन पेज में यहां पे आएंगे तो
यहां पे आपको
आई थिंक पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट हमें देखनी है।
या दिस वन द पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट। सो यू विल
बी गेटिंग द रिस्पांस हेडर। राइट। सो हम
लॉग इन पेज पे आ गए हैं। लॉग इन पेज पे जब
आएंगे लॉग इन वाली यूआरएल पे तो यहां पे
अब आपको मैं डीबगिंग यहां पे आपको जो है
डेवलपर टूल्स के अंदर में नेटवर्क वाले
टैब पे आएंगे तो ये आपको पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट
एक दिख रही है इस पर्टिकुलर पेज पे लॉग इन
पेज जिसका यूआरएल जो है ये रहा
10.10.248.169
कॉलन 5000 पोर्ट पे स्लैश लॉग इन पेज पे।
ठीक है? अब यहां पे जब आप आएंगे तो हियर
यू विल सी रिस्पांस हेडर में ये रिस्पांस
हेडर आपको दिख रहा है यहां पे सेट कुकी की
वैल्यू यहां पे आपको दिख रही है। राइट ये
सेट कुकी की वैल्यू दिख रही है। एंड सेट
कुकी वैल्यू में आप देख रहे हैं कि यहां
पे आपको एक सेशन की वैल्यू दी गई है। एंड
http ओनली ये यू कैन सी हियर एचटीटीp ओनली
फ्लैग है। जब आप कुकीज़ पे जाएंगे यू विल
सी कि यहां पे एचटीटीp ओनली ट्रू है। एंड
द सेम थिंग दैट अह दे आर सेइंग कि यहां पे
हमें कुछ इनेशन मिल रही है जहां पे
एचटीडीपी ओनली है कुकिंग का यूज़ किया जाए
असेस एंड मैनेजमेंट में ये सारी चीज़ आपको
दिखाई दे रही है। बट यहां पे अलग बात है
कि यहां पे इनको एक एक्सपायरी टाइम भी दिख
रहा है। हियर दे आर बीइंग गेटिंग द
एक्सपायरी टाइम ऑफ़ दैट कुकी आल्सो बट यहां
हमारे केस में एक्सपायरी टाइम नहीं दिख
रही है कुकी की। तो इट्स अ वेरी नॉर्मल
प्रोसेस नॉर्मल थिंग। इट्स नॉट एन इशज़। कई
बार ऐसा होता है, हो सकता है कि आप किस
तरह के ब्राउज़र कौन सा चीज कब यूज़ कर रहे
हैं, उसके ऊपर भी डिपेंड करता है। तो ये
एक नॉर्मल सी चीज है कि अगर वहां पे दिख
रही है, यहां नहीं दिख रही है तो इट्स नॉट
एन इशू। ठीक है? तो यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं एचटीपी ओनली यहां पे दिख रही है यहां
पे एक्सपायरी। रिस्पांस हेडर में
रिक्वेस्टर में मत देखिएगा। रिक्वेस्टर के
कुकी से हमें कोई मतलब नहीं है। रिस्पॉन्स
जहां से भैया हमें कुकी की वैल्यू सेट हो
के आई है।
तो यहां पे आपको दिख रही होगी http ओनली
ट्रू है। एंड ये हमें मिल चुकी है। चलिए
एक तो ये हमें मिल गया। एक यहां पे इसमें
भी कुकी है। नहीं इसमें कोई कुकी नहीं है।
स्टूडेंट स्टैट्स में कोई कुकी है? नो ऐसा
कोई कुकी एक्सपायरी के साथ यहां पे हमारे
पास नहीं है। सो यहां पे सिंपल सा एक कुकी
है। वी गॉट इट। अब नेक्स्ट प्रोसेस पे
चलते हैं। अभी हमारा कोई ये टास्क तो है
नहीं। नेक्स्ट प्रोसेस पे चलते हैं। वि
दिस ऑथेंटिकेशन वी आल्सो नोटिस दैट वी नाउ
हैव एक्सेस टू मोर फंक्शनैलिटी। तो हमारे
पास कुछ मोर फंक्शनैलिटी का एक्सेस हुआ
है। क्या मोर फंक्शनैलिटी है भैया? वह भी
दिखा देते हैं।
मोर फंक्शनैलिटी यह है कि यहां पर आपको
कुछ ऑप्शंस मिल जा रहे हैं। डैशबोर्ड
वगैरह का डैशबोर्ड मॉड्यूल्स, टेस्ट,
अटेम्प्ट्स ये चार ऑप्शंस मिल जा रहे हैं।
आप देख सकते हैं एनरोल स्टूडेंट्स कौन-कौन
है, क्या है? ये सारी चीज़ आपको दिख रही
है। ठीक है? चलिए, यूजिंग द मेन्यू
नेविगेशन एंड रिव्यूइंग द नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक
वी कैन सी दैट सेशन ट्रैकिंग इज़ इनफोर्स
थ्रू द कुकी दैट इज़ बीइंग ट्रांसमिटेड विथ
ईच रिक्वेस्ट। मतलब कि हर हर रिक्वेस्ट के
साथ सेशन ट्रैकिंग हो रही है। जैसे कि अगर
मैं आपको ऐसे दिखाऊं
अगर आप नेविगेट करोगे किसी और मॉड्यूल उस
पे नेविगेट करोगे। जैसे मैं इसको ऊपर की
तरफ लेकर आता हूं। ठीक है? नेटवर्क टैब
में आप रियल टाइम जो भी नेविगेशन करोगे
उसको लोड करता है यहां पे ये चीजों को। तो
जैसे मैं मॉड्यूल्स पे जाता हूं मान लो तो
यहां पे मॉड्यूल्स वाली जो चीज है वो लोड
हो जाएगी। यहां पे टेस्ट पे जाओगे तो
टेस्ट वाली जो पेज है वो भी लोड हो जाएगी
आपकी। अटेम्प्ट्स पे जाओगे तो अटेम्प्ट्स
वाली पेज यहां पे लोड हो जाएगी। जैसे
मॉड्यूल्स वाली है तो मॉड्यूल्स वाली पेज
है। जैसे इस तरीके से तो ये पेज है आपका
मॉड्यूल वाला पेज है। ठीक है? यहां पे
मॉड्यूल्स वाली पेज। तो आप देखोगे कि यहां
पे कुकीज़ के थ्रू जो है वो सारी चीजें जो
है वो ट्रैक हो रही हैं। जैसे-जैसे आप
रिक्वेस्ट भेजोगे जैसे आप देखोगे
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स में आपने मॉड्यूल्स पे
रिक्वेस्ट भेजा तो यहां पे कुकी यहां पे
आपको दिख रही है। यहां पे कुकी यहां पे आ
चुकी है। सेशन वैल्यू यहां पे आ चुका है।
एंड ये एक्चुअली इट इज़ गेटिंग ट्रैक्ड।
एंड यहां पे जब आप इसका लोकेशन देखोगे तो
इट्स स्लैश मॉड्यूल्स जो पाथ है वो स्लैश
मॉड्यूल्स का है जहां पे आप विजिट कर रहे
हो। तो हर आपके विजिट को हर आपके अ जो भी
एक्शन है उसको ट्रैक किया जा रहा है कुकीज़
के थ्रू। अगर आप जैसे-जैसे नेविगेट करोगे
वैसे-वैसे यहां पे आपको दिखता जाएगा। चलिए
अब आगे चलते हैं। जो भी चीज आप कर रहे हो
उसको ट्रैक किया जा रहा है इस कुकीज़ के
थ्रू। ठीक है? जो भी पेज को नेविगेट करोगे
वो सब पेज पॉपुलेट होंगे।
ओके।
नोट दैट योर हेडर्स
माइट डिफर स्लाइटली डिपेंडिंग ऑन वि
ब्राउज़र यू यूज। तो यहां पर इन्होंने ये
चीज बोली भी है कि आपके जो हेडर्स है वो
हो सकता है वो डिफरेंट अ डिफरेंट हो कौन
से ब्राउज़र या क्या यूज़ कर रहे हो उस पे
वो डिफरेंट होंगे। हाउएवर एन इंटरेस्टिंग
थिंग इज़ नोट इज़ टू नोट इज़ दैट इवन दो द
कुकी एक्सपायरी टाइम हैज़ बीन रीच्ज़्ड द
सेम सेट कुकी हेडर इज़ यूज़्ड टू रिफ्रेश द
कुकीज़ टू एग्ज़ैक्ट सेम वैल्यूज़। मतलब सेम
कुकी वैल्यू का यूज़ किया जा रहा है। सेम
कुकी वैल्यू इवन सुसेशन कुकी जो है आपका
जो ये कुकी है एक्सपायर भी हो जाएगा।
एक्सपायरी अगर टाइम है एक्सपायर भी हो जा
रहा है। उसके बाद भी सेम कुकी वैल्यू को
यूज़ किया जा रहा है। दिस माइट पॉइंट टू अ
पर्सिस्टेंट कुकी। इसका मतलब है कि ये हो
सकता है एक पर्सिस्टेंट कुकी हो। जैसे
Netflix वगैरह यूज़ करती है। लेट्स सी
व्हाट हैपेंस व्हेन वी रिमूव दिस कुकी।
अंडर स्टोरेज रिमूव द कुकी एंड मेक द
मॉड्यूल रिक्वेस्ट अगेन। तो अब बोल रहा है
कि अंडर द स्टोरेज आप कुकी को डिलीट कर
दीजिए और मॉड्यूल रिक्वेस्ट को वापस से
रीलोड कीजिए। तो हम एक काम करते हैं। ऐसे
ही काम करते हैं। क्या करते हैं? अब अभी
आपने मॉड्यूल्स में आप जब गए थे तो आप
यहां आपको इनरोल स्टूडेंट्स 1 2 3 ये सब
दिख रहा है। राइट? अब हम क्या करते हैं?
कुकी को डिलीट करते हैं। स्टोरेज पे चलते
हैं। यहां पे यह कुकी है। यहां पे कुकी
वैल्यू है। ठीक है? राइट क्लिक करते हैं।
एंड यहां पे डिलीट करते हैं। यहां पर आ
रहा है डिलीट।
ऑल सेशन कुकीज़ यहां पर आ रहा है। तो मैंने
क्या किया? डिलीट ऑल सेशन कुकीज़ यहां पर
डिलीट कर दिया। दैट्स इट। डिलीट कर दी। अब
मैं वापस से मॉड्यूल वाले पेज को रीलोड
करूंगा वापस से। तो मैं अब रीलोड यहां पे
करता हूं। जैसे ही मैंने रीलोड किया। ये
देखिए यहां पे पहले तो एरर लोडिंग स्ट्स आ
रही है डैशबोर्ड में। मॉड्यूल्स पे
चलेंगे। मॉड्यूल्स आ तो रहा है बट यहां पे
आपको कुछ डिफरेंस नजर आ रही है मॉड्यूल्स
में। मुझे बता दीजिए। किसी को आ रही है?
बता दीजिए।
क्या बात है उमैर खान वेलकम टू दिस लाइव
सेशन। बताइए कुछ डिफरेंस आपको लगा यहां पे
मॉड्यूल्स वाले सेक्शन में दिखने में जो
सामने व्यू है जब हमने कुकीज़ को डिलीट
किया एनीवन कैन नोटिसिंग एनी काइंड ऑफ
डिफरेंस
मुझे लग रहा है ध्यान ही नहीं दे रहा कोई
डिफरेंस कोई नजर आ रहा है आपको
अरे सिंपल सा है यार यहां पे पहले लिखा था
ना एनरोल्ड स्टूडेंट्स एनरोल्ड स्टूडेंट्स
वन टू ऐसे करके लिखा हुआ था वो गायब है।
तो यहां पे कुछ चेंजज़ आए हैं जिसको ये
ट्रैक नहीं जैसे हमने कुकीज़ हटा दिया ना
तो वो चेंजज़ आ गए। एनरोल्ड स्टूडेंट्स
गायब हो चुके हैं। एनरोल्ड स्टूडेंट्स के
नंबर्स गायब हो चुके हैं। जो पहले नंबर्स
आ रहे थे। राइट? जो पहले नंबर्स आ रहे थे
वो नंबर्स गायब हो चुके हैं। पहले नंबर्स
आ रहे थे एनरोल स्टूडेंट्स 1 2 3 वो गायब
हो चुके हैं। ठीक है? तो यहां पे देखो द
रिक्वेस्ट सीम्स टू स्टिल सक्सीड। हाउएवर
इफ यू टेक अ क्लोज़र लुक यू विल सी दैट वी
कैन नाउ ओनली सी द मॉड्यूल्स बट नॉट द
नंबर ऑफ़ एनरोल स्टूडेंट्स और द पोटेंशियल
टेस्ट्स। अब यहां पे नंबर नहीं देख पा
रहे। मॉड्यूल्स तो देख पा रहे हैं बट नंबर
नहीं देख पा रहे। ठीक है? दिस टेल्स अस
दैट वी माइट नीड टू डू फर्दर
इन्वेस्टिगेशन टू डिटरमाइन एग्जैक्टली
व्हाट वी आर अलाउड टू एक्सेस फ्रॉम अ
कंप्लीटली अन ऑथेंटिकेटेड पर्सपेक्टिव।
दिस वुड वारंट फर्दर इन्वेस्टिगेशन टू
फुल्ली मैप आउट द सेशन मैनेजमेंट सल। हमें
फर्दर इन्वेस्टिगेशन करनी होगी। देखना
होगा कि भैया हमें क्या-क्या चीजों का और
एक्सेस है या नहीं है। हाउएवर वी विल कीप
थिंग स्लाइटली सिंपलर। लेट्स टेक अ लुक एट
द लॉगउ फंक्शनैलिटी। वंस वी प्रेस द लॉगउ
बटन वी कैन सी दैट आवर सेशन इज़ रिमूव्ड
क्लाइंट साइड। मतलब यहां पे जब हम लॉगउ
बटन पे ये करेंगे तो हमारा सेशन जो है
रिमूव हो जाएगा क्लाइंट साइड से। सिंपल।
हाउएवर वी शुड प्रोबेब्ली टेस्ट इफ द सेशन
इज़ आल्सो टर्मिनेटेड सर्वर साइट। तो हम
यहां पे एक बार लॉगउ वाला फंक्शनैलिटी देख
सकते हैं। जैसे देखो जैसे यहां पे है ना
तो अगर अभी यहां पे
मैंने होस्ट सेलेक्ट किया। तो यहां पे एक
सेशन चल रहा है। सेशन स्टोरेज में लोकल
स्टोरेज में एक सेशन चल रही है। ठीक है?
अब मैं यहां पे क्या करता हूं? मैं यहां
पे लॉग आउट कर देता हूं। लॉग आउट किया।
जैसे ही लॉग आउट किया लोकल स्टोरेज से
सेशन हट गई। यहां पे देखा आपने जैसे ही
लॉग आउट किया यहां पे जो सेशन चल रही थी
यहां पे जो प्रेजेंट थी सेशन की
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन जो थी वो हट चुकी है। वो
डिलीट हो चुकी है। खत्म हो चुकी है। तो
जैसे ही लॉगउ किया ऐसा ही होना चाहिए कि
खत्म हो जाना चाहिए। द सेम थिंग दैट दे आर
हियर इट इज़ बीइंग शेयर्ड कि जैसे ही हमने
लॉगउ किया टर्मिनेट किया वो वहां से
क्लाइंट साइड से हट चुकी है।
यू कैन रीऑथेंटिकेट टू द एप्लीकेशन एंड
रिप्लेस योर न्यू कुकी विथ योर ओल्ड कुकी
वैल्यू। बट इट डस सीम्स लाइक द सेशन
टर्मिनेशन इज वर्किंग टू सम कैपेसिटी। यह
आप कर सकते हो कि आप न्यू कुकी को ओल्ड
कुकी ओल्ड कुकी को न्यू कुकी में डाल के
चेक आउट कर सकते हो। लाइक अगर आपको करना
है तो अब देखो, लेट्स विजिट रिविजिट सम ऑफ़
आवर प्रीवियस क्लेम्स हियर। इफ वी नेविगेट
टू द लोकल स्टोरेज, वी डू नोटिस क्वाइट अ
बिट ऑफ़ डेटा इज़ बीइंग प्रेजेंट। ठीक है
ना? देखो, दिस डस टेल अस दैट देयर इज़
समथिंग रोंग। सिंस एन इनवैलिड सेशन शुड
नॉट लीड टू एन इंटरनल सर्वर देयर। लेट्स
इन्वेस्टिगेट। ठीक है? अब यहां पे ये बोल
रहा है कि भैया एक नया सेशन हम शुरू कर
लेंगे। एक नया सेशन मतलब पहले तो हमने
टर्मिनेट कर दिया। मतलब वहां से जैसे ही
लॉगउ किया सेशन टर्मिनेट हो गया। अब ये
बोल रहा है ओल्ड कुकीज़ वैल्यू से नई कुकी
वैल्यू को आप अ जो है ना उसको क्या कीजिए?
रिप्लेस कर दीजिए। तो यही हो जाएगी वो जो
हमने किया सेशन फिक्सेशन वाली चीज हो
जाएगी। उसकी सेशन यहां पे आ जाएगी। सिम
सिमिलर लॉग इन सेशन यहां पे हमारे पास आ
जाएगी। अगर हम उसको चेंज करते हैं वैल्यू
को चेंज करते हैं। राइट? सिंपल सा सिंपल
सा फंडा है। वैल्यू को चेंज करते हैं। उसी
तरीके से। चलिए अब यहां पे
अब क्या करते हैं? देखिए
लेट्स प्रउंड अपडेटिंग यूजर फ्रॉम
स्टूडेंट टू लेक्चर एंड रिफ्रेश इन द पेज।
अब यहां पे देखते हैं कि अब ये क्या कर
रहे हैं? फिर से हम लॉग इन करते हैं एक
बार। एक बार लेट्स लॉग इन अगेन।
है ना टैकर एंड पासवर्ड क्यू डब्ल्यू ई आर
टी वाई। हम यहां पे लॉग इन कर लेते हैं।
जैसे ही लॉग इन करेंगे वी गॉट लॉक्ड इन
एंड यहां पे अगेन सेशन इनफेशन आ चुकी है।
कुकीज़ की वैल्यू यहां पे कुकी जो वैल्यू
है वो आ चुकी है। ये वैल्यू है। ये वैल्यू
को वही इसी वैल्यू को कॉपी करके ये बोल
रहे थे कि कॉपी करके वो चीज़ फिर से डालने
को और कुछ भी नहीं है। यहां पे आपका सेशन
आ चुका है। एंड यहां पे कि की के साथ जो
भी की मतलब व्हाटएवर की एंड यहां पे उसकी
वैल्यूज़ जो है वो सारी चीज़ हैं। एंड यहां
पे। ठीक है? तो अब यहां पे ये बोल रहा है
कि हम यहां पे वैल्यू को एक चेंज करेंगे
एंड देन देखते हैं कि क्या होता है। लेट्स
प्ले एंड प्ले अराउंड बाय अपडेटिंग आवर
यूजर रोल फ्रॉम स्टूडेंट टू लेक्चरर एंड
रिफ्रेशिंग द पेज। तो अब ये बोल रहा है कि
अब स्टूडेंट को लेक्चरर वाले रोल को दे
देना है। तो अब हमें यहां पे क्या करना
है? हमारा जो यूजर रोल यहां पे फिलहाल
स्टूडेंट का यूजर रोल है। इसको हमें चेंज
करके लेक्चरर का कर देना है। तो देखिए अभी
क्या है? अभी ये चार ऑप्शंस आपको दिख रहे
हैं। ठीक है? यहां पे आपको चार ऑप्शंस दिख
रहे हैं। डैशबोर्ड, मॉड्यूल्स, टेस्ट एंड
अटेम्प्ट्स। चार। अब हम यहां पे यूजर रोल
को चेंज करते हैं। इसको करते हैं लेक्चरर।
एल ई सी टी यू आर ई आर। लेक्चरर करते हैं।
अब इस पेज को रीलोड करते हैं। देखते हैं
कि ये चार ऑप्शंस में कुछ चेंजज़ या कुछ और
चेंजिस होते हैं क्या? लेट्स रीलोड द पेज।
कुछ चेंजेस दिए? देखा आपने? कुछ चेंजज़ हुए
हैं क्या?
कुछ चेंजज़ हुए? सर, आपकी वजह से सबोमेन
टेकओवर मिला है। वाओ! कांग्रेचुलेशंस,
सेक्युलर मीम्स। क्या बात है।
डड यू सी नोटिस एनी चेंजेस? कुछ तो बताओ
यार। फोकस तो दिया होगा आप लोगों ने। कोई
चेंजेस देखा आपने?
जी हां।
एक और यहां पे आपको ऑप्शन आ गया है। चार
ऑप्शंस के अलावा। पहले डैशबोर्ड
मॉड्यूल्स, टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट्स तो थे बट
यहां पे एक स्टूडेंट करके ऑप्शन आ चुका
है। देयर इज़ एन ऑप्शन नोन ऐज़ स्टूडेंट्स।
जब आप स्टूडेंट्स ऑप्शन यहां पे एक आपके
पास आ चुका है। तो आप देखेंगे
व्हाइल नाउ वी हैव एक्सेस टू मोर टैब्स।
इट सीम्स लाइक वी डोंट हैव एक्सेस टू मोर
इनफेशन। सिंस वी कैन सी एनी स्टूडेंट और
टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट्स। इट सीम्स लाइक वी डोंट
हैव एक्सेस टू मोर इनफेशन सिंस वी कैन सी
एनी स्टूडेंट्स और टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट्स।
लेट्स टेक दिस फर्दर बाय अपडेटिंग द आवर
रोल इन द यूजर वैल्यू फ्रॉम A2 टू A3
सैडली दिस स्टिल गिव्स द सेम रिजल्ट।
हाउएवर देयर आर मोर वैल्यूज़ टू प्ले विथ
हियर प्ले विथ हियर सच एज़ आवर आईडी एंड
यूजरनेम जो आईडी एंड यूजरनेम के इस पे अ
छेड़खानी कर सकते हैं। ठीक है ना? ये चीजें
आप कर सकते हैं। ठीक है?
हाउएवर दिस न्यू इनफेशन टेल्स अस दैट द
सेशंस माइट बी मैनेज्ड नॉट प्योरली थ्रू अ
कुकी बट थ्रू टोकन इनेशन। टोकन इनेशन से
भी ये मैनेज हो रही है। ठीक है? तो ये
लाइफ साइकिल है एंड ये क्वेश्चंस है यहां
पे पहले तो। तो अब आ जाते हैं यहां पे कुछ
वैल्यूज़ को चेंज करने का। मेन है यहां पे
क्या कि आपको वैल्यू चेंज करने हैं।
स्टूडेंट से लेक्चरर बनाया तो एक नई आपको
मेन्यू आ गई है। स्टूडेंट अ स्टूडेंट्स की
लिस्ट आप देख सकते हैं। एंड यहां पे आप
आईडी को मतलब यूजर वैल्यू अपडेटिंग और रोल
इन द यूजर वैल्यू जो भी आपका रोल है यूजर
वैल्यू में जैसे मान लो कि
यूजर वैल्यू में जो भी रोल है उसको आप
चेंज कर सकते हैं। लाइक यहां पे एक आईडी
है। यहां पे एक रोल है। तो आप देख सकते
हैं कि अपडेटिंग अ रोल इन द यूजर वैल्यू।
यूजर वैल्यू में जो रोल है उसको फ़ A2 टू
A3 यहां पे इसको अपडेट कर रहे हैं। इट
गिव्स द सेम रिजल्ट्स। और भी इसमें आईडीज़
और यूजरनेम और भी फील्ड्स हैं। आईडी है,
यूजरनेम है जिसके साथ आप छेड़खानी कर सकते
हो। जिसके साथ आप छेड़छाड़ करके और भी चीजें
देख सकते हो। तो यहां पे फिलहाल के लिए अब
लेक्चरर का रोल है। अब स्टूडेंट्स यहां पे
ऑप्शन आ चुके हैं। लेट्स गो टू द
स्टूडेंट्स एंड लेट्स सी व्हाट वी हैव। सो
स्टूडेंट्स पे जब जाएंगे तो यहां पे आपको
दिखेगा तीनचार कुछ स्टूडेंट्स यहां पे
आपको दिख रहे हैं। एना अटैकर और ये सब
चीजें दिख रही हैं आपको। राइट? ये
स्टूडेंट्स दिख रहे हैं। अब हम इसमें कुछ
चेंजेस कर सकते हैं। जैसे अब लेक्चरर हैं।
अब इसमें हम यूजरनेम एंड आईडी के साथ
छेड़खड़ कर सकते हैं। जैसे यूजरनेम इज़
अनटैकर है। अनटैकर करके है। तो हम इसको
चेंज कर सकते हैं। आईडी के साथ हम चेंज कर
सकते हैं। जैसे हमारे पास
आईडी है एट।
तो आईडी को हम
नाइन करके देखते हैं। इफ देयर इज समथिंग
आईडी न करते हैं। देयर इज समथिंग वी आर
गेटिंग अ नथिंग मॉड्यूल्स पे चलते हैं। ये
तो मॉड्यूल्स है। स्टूडेंट्स पे चलते हैं।
नहीं आईडी 9 पे भी हमें कुछ खास यहां पे
देखने को वैल्यू पे नहीं मिली है। सो
लेट्स गो एंड लेट्स चेक ऑन
आईडी 10 पे चलते हैं।
आईडी 10 पे चलते हैं। लेट्स रीलोड इट इफ
देयर इज समथिंग ऑन आईडी 10
मॉड्यूल्स पे चलते हैं। ना आईडी 10 यहां
पे भी कुछ भी कुछ खास यहां पे नहीं है। अब
यहां पे आपके कुछ क्वेश्चंस यहां पे
इन्होंने स्टार्ट किए हुए हैं। क्वेश्चंस
में क्या है? यहां पे सिंपल सा क्वेश्चंस
है।
व्हाट इज़ द यूजरनेम ऑफ़ द स्टूडेंट विद द
नेम एक्स? अब यह नेम एक्स से जो यूजर नेम
व्हाट इज द यूजर नेम ऑफ द स्टूडेंट विद द
नेम x? अब एक नेम x का कोई स्टूडेंट है।
ये बोल रहे हैं उसका यूजरनेम बताइए। अब ये
नेम x का स्टूडेंट आना तो चाहिए ना। ये
आपको खोजना है। नेम x का स्टूडेंट ये आपको
खोजना है। तो अब नेम x का स्टूडेंट मान लो
यूजरनेम उसका क्या है? ये बता ये आपको पूछ
रहा है। तो नेम मान लो कि एन अटैकर है
यहां पे।
मैं नेम मान लो x देता हूं।
मान लो x देता हूं। एंड यहां पर आईडी 10
रहने देते हैं। एंड यहां पर रीलोड करते
हैं। लेट्स सी लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज़ समथिंग
वी कैन गेट इन द स्टूडेंट सेक्शन। सो यहां
पे कोई एक्स नाम का कुछ है यहां पे। आई एम
नॉट सीइंग एनी एक्स काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग्स। तो
कुछ ऐसे कुछ खास मिल रही है कुकीज़ वाले
में। हम
यहां पे कुछ ऐसा कुछ खास मिल नहीं रहा
यहां पे। बट यहां पे हमारा रोल जो है वह
लेक्चरर का ही रोल है। याद रखिएगा यह
लेक्चरर का रोल है। एंड यहां पे हम
यूजरनेम चेंज कर रहे हैं। अब यूजरनेम यहां
पे मान लो डार्कर है। इसको हम रिमूव कर
देते हैं। ब्लैंक कर देते हैं। आपको चेंज
आपको ना छेड़छाड़ करनी है। आईडी 10 है।
यूजरनेम एक्स देके यहां पे चेंज करनी है।
सो ऐसे आपको पता करना है कि क्या यूजरनेम
है उस पर्टिकुलर अगर कोई एक्स नाम का कोई
मॉड्यूल्स है। यहां पे कई बार पॉपुलेट
आपकी कई बार वो करेंगे तो आपका नहीं होगा।
बट कई बार हो भी जाएगा। तो बेफिक्र रहिएगा
उससे। ब्राउज़र टू ब्राउज़र एंड डिपेंड करता
है वो। तो यहां पे लोकल स्टोरेज में
जाएंगे। यहां पे अभी फिलहाल के लिए यहां
पे कोई छेड़छाड़ कर रहे हैं। तो यहां पे कुछ
ऐसा कुछ खास यहां पे हमें मिल नहीं रहा।
अब इसको आप चेंजेस कर करके देख सकते हैं।
अलग-अलग तरह की वैल्यूज़ अलग-अलग तरह की जो
है इसमें एट्रिब्यूट्स डाल के आप चेक आउट
कर सकते हैं। जैसे मान लो कि मैं आईडी नेम
एक्स में डाला। नेम मिक्स रहने देते हैं।
रोल टू ही रहने देते हैं।
मैं यहां पे रोल
वन कर देता हूं।
रोल वन करते हैं एंड रीलोड करते हैं।
लेट्स चेक विद द रोल इफ देयर इज सम रोल
इशज़। रोल किया मैंने यहां पे। रोल में कुछ
खास यहां पे डिफरेंस आया नहीं हमारे पास।
अ
आईडी को ज़ीरो कर देते हैं। लेट्स चेक विद
द ज़ीरो आईडी। इफ़ देयर इज़ समथिंग। तो, यू
हैव टू प्ले विथ द आर्गुमेंट्स। जो आपके
आर्गुमेंट्स हैं, जो भी आपके ऑप्शंस हैं,
उनके साथ आपको प्ले करना है। इसमें यही
है, इसमें मजा तभी आता है। प्ले करते रहो,
कुछ आपको रिजल्ट्स आपको देखने को मिल
जाएंगे। हो सकता है कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग आपको
सामने मिल जाए। राइट? दैट कुड बी पॉसिबल।
सो, वी हैव टू प्ले। तो, यहां पे आईडी
ज़ीरो कर दी। अब यहां पे यहां पे इन्होंने
यहां पे क्या किया? हिंट दिया। अब यहां पे
मान लो हिंट लेना है आपको। यहां पे ये
वाली चीज़ है। तो, यहां पे एक बार हिंट आप
ले सकते हो। सिंपली स्टॉक ऑन क्वेश्चंस।
आई एम हियर टू हेल्प यू द रियल टाइम
गाइडेंस पर्सनल हिंट एंड एक्सप्लेनेशन। तो
मैं यहां पे करता हूं मान लिया यहां पे
एंड
ठीक है। मैंने यहां पे किया। यहां मैं
स्टक। पहले क्वेश्चंस पे आ जाते हैं।
एक हिंट मांगते हैं। कुछ भी हिंट मांगते
हैं। देखते हैं क्या है। हिंट में क्या
है? व्हाट इज द यूजर नेम ऑफ द एक्स?
ये ठीक है
चलो ये कुछ और ही ये कुछ और हिंट की है। अ
हिंट देखते हैं कुछ इफ देयर इज सिंपल है।
यहां पे छेड़छाड़ करनी है। कुछ अगर आपके
दिमाग में है तो बताइए। आई एम गोइंग टू
यूज दैट।
ठीक है।
तो यहां पे आपको कुछ एक्सप्लइटेशन करनी
पड़ेगी। कुछ एक्सप्लॉयटेशन मतलब कुछ आपको
थोड़ा सा इनमरेशन करना पड़ेगा यूज़र्स के
लिए। तो उसके लिए आपको थोड़ा सा हाथ पैर
मारना पड़ेगा। देन आप उस यूजर को पाएंगे।
यहां पे मैं नेटवर्क में चलता हूं। यहां
पे नेटवर्क टैब पे। अब मैं यहां पे
नेटवर्क टैब पे चलूंगा। मैं स्टूडेंट्स
वाली लिस्ट जो है इसको मैं पॉपुलेट
करूंगा। ठीक है? सो आई विल बी पॉपुलेटिंग
स्टूडेंट लिस्ट। मैं स्टूडेंट लिस्ट को
यहां पे रीलोड करूंगा। एंड रीलोड करने के
बाद देखते हैं क्या होता है। सो आई जस्ट
रीलोडेड इट। एंड लेट्स सी गो टू द
स्टूडेंट पोर्टल। यहां पे स्टूडेंट वाला
पोर्टल है यहां पे हमारे पास। इस वाले में
चलते हैं। अह
304 नॉट मॉडिफाइड है। ठीक है? नीचे की तरफ
चलते हैं। इफ देयर इज समथिंग सम इन वी आर
गेटिंग यहां कुकीज़ में
कुकीज़ वैल्यू है यहां पे होस्ट। ठीक है?
ये रिक्वेस्ट हेडर है हमारे। लेट्स गो टू
द रिस्पांस हेडर।
या सो यहां पे हमें मिल रहे हैं स्टूडेंट
वाली पोर्टल। ठीक है? अब स्टूडेंट वाली
में हमें यहां पे अगर मैं यहां देखूं अ
थोड़ा सा इन न्यूमरेशन करना पड़ेगा हमें।
वैसे यहां पे ईज़ली यहां पे यहां पे
डायरेक्टली आ जाएगा। यहां पे डायरेक्टली
आनी चाहिए जो नाम है आपके स्टूडेंट का। अ
सिंपली बट यहां पे नहीं आ रहा है। उसका
कुछ रीज़न होगा। मे बी पॉसिबिलिटी है। बट
यहां पे इट शुड बी कमिंग डायरेक्टली।
लेट्स सी वंस अगेन। मैं स्टूडेंट्स पे
चलता हूं। एंड
लेट्स गो हियर
इफ देयर इज समथिंग हियर वी विल बी सेइंग
कुकीज़ वैल्यू यहां पर हैंडर में सो नथिंग
इज देयर
हम तो हमारा यहां पे क्वेश्चन है।
क्वेश्चन यहां पे है कि
द नेम एक्स का यूजरनेम क्या है? ये
यूजरनेम क्या है? तो यहां पे स्टूडेंट के
लिस्ट आने चाहिए। नहीं नहीं एन अटैकर नहीं
है। एन अटैकर नहीं है। वी हैव टू चेक द
आईडीज एंड अदर। तो आईडीज वगैरह एक बार चेक
कर सकते हैं हम। तो एक बार वापस से आईडीज
को लेट्स सी चेक करते हैं। लेट्स सी द
आईडीज एंड लेट्स रलोड। तो मैं यहां पे
आईडी जीरो से
अ 1 2 3 4 5 तो आईडी सिक्स पे करते हैं।
लेट्स सी लेट्स चेक द आईडी सिक्स।
आईडी सिक्स पे भी नहीं है। एक एक
इंक्रिमेंट करना पड़ेगा। वी हैव टू
इंक्रीमेंट।
आईडी से पे एक बार देखते हैं
दिस इज़ दिस इज़ अ लेक्चरर ऐसा कुछ देखो
उससे नहीं है मतलब यहां पे एक बार देख
सकते हैं यहां पे मॉड्यूल्स में लेट्स सी
अडी7 पे भी नहीं है। लेट्स गो टू द आईडी
एट
आईडी एट पे करके देखते हैं।
नोप्स
लेट्स ऑन आईडी न
आईडी जीरो पर तो चेक हो चुकी है भैया।
आईडी न
हां एक बार एक सेकंड मैं आईडी एक बार देख
लेता हूं आईडी न पे भी नहीं है।
ओके। सो यहां पे देखना है पहले और भी कोई
यूजर है क्या? तो मैं नेटवर्क पे चलता हूं
यहां पे। मैं और भी कोई पेज पर यह चेक आउट
कर रहा है क्या? स्टूडेंट्स हैं, लेक्चरर
है एंड देयर आर सम मोर
कोई और भी एंड पॉइंट है क्या? यूजर लेक्चर
स्टूडेंट्स लेक्चरर।
ओके। मैं यहां पे एक बार डैशबोर्ड पे
क्लिक करता हूं। एंड इसको डैशबोर्ड पर
रीलोड करते हैं। लेट से सम अदर रोल्स आर
देयर।
हम हम
एडमिन से रिलेटेड कोई रोल है क्या?
सुपर एडमिन डैशबोर्ड। ओके। सुप सुपर एडमिन
का भी है यहां पे। एक सुपर एडमिन रिलेटेड
चीज है। सो सुपर एडमिन को भी हम ट्राई कर
सकते हैं। सो लेट्स गो टू द स्टोरेज
स्टूडेंट्स।
लेट्स गो टू द हियर हियर लेट्स गिव इट
आईडी
आईडी 10 पे भी एक बार चेक कर लेते हैं।
आईडी 10 कर लेते हैं। एंड यहां पे लेक्चरर
से लेक्चरर के जगह पे कर देते हैं सुपर
एडमिन। सुपर एडमिन रोल भी एक अवेलेबल है।
सो लेट्स चेक आउट विद द सुपर एडमिन रोल
एंड
लेट्स रीलोड। लेट्स सी इफ इट इज वर्किंग।
मॉड्यूल्स पर चलते हैं। स्टूडेंट्स पर
चलते हैं।
इट्स नॉट वर्किंग।
थैंक्स ब्रदर। थैंक्स।
सुपर यूजर सुपर एडमिन भी नहीं काम कर रहा
है भैया।
स्पेलिंग गलत दी थी क्या मैंने सुपर एडमिन
अब देखते हैं
लेट्स सी
हम
अच्छा इसमें और भी आ गए क्या लेक्चरर्स
वगैरह क्या आ गया यहां पे लेक्चरर आईडी दो
में
यूजरनेम लेक्चरर लेक्चरर एक लेक्चरर है
स्टूडेंट्स में अ ये आ गए मॉड्यूल्स में
चलो इसके और भी क्वेश्चंस हैं ना उनके भी
देख लें हाउ मेनी लेक्चर आर रजिस्टर्ड ऑन
द एप्लीकेशन तो एक ही है वो तो अभी दिख ही
गया सबमिट कर दो यह तो सही है
एक्सक्लूडिंग द अनऑथेंटिकेटेड यूज़र्स हाउ
मेनी रोल्स डस द एप्लीकेशन हैव एप्लीकेशन
को तीन कितने रोल्स हैं अन ऑथेंटिकेटेड
यूजर्स को हटा के तो रोल्स तो
लेक्चरर्स पे
रोल्स देख लेते हैं कितने हैं। तो नेटवर्क
टैब पे चलते हैं। एंड यहां पे देखते हैं।
एक तो लेक्चरर का है, एक स्टूडेंट का है
और एक सुपर एडमिन का है। तीन रोल है ना?
तीन रोल हैं। फिर तीन रोल हैं। सुपर
एडमिन, लेक्चरर एंड अ आपका स्टूडेंट। तो
थ्री रोल्स लिख लेते हैं। आई होप इट्स
सही। सही है। सही है। थ्री रोल्स हैं।
राइट? उसके बाद हाउ मेनी टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट्स
इन टोटल हैव बीन परफॉर्म्ड ऑन द
एप्लीकेशन? टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट्स कितने
परफॉर्म हुए हैं? टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट्स? सो
इट्स ईजी। आई थिंक टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट्स कितने
हैं?
एक भी नहीं है।
अरे टेस्ट अटेमप्स तो स्टूडेंट वाली आईडी
से होगी ना। स्टोरेज पर चलते हैं। लोकल
स्टोरेज पे
यहां पे लेक्चरर वाली लेके देखते हैं।
टेस्ट नो टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट्स कितने हैं? नो
अटेम्प्ट्स। अच्छा
जीरो यहां जीरो दिखा रहा है। ठीक है? एक
बार एक काम करते हैं। स्टूडेंट वाले पे
चलते हैं।
स्टूडेंट
स्टूडेंट वाले पे लेट्स गो टू द स्टूडेंट।
एंड यहां पे अटेमप्ट्स में कितने हैं भाई?
भाई लेक्चर वन टेस्ट वन है। एनरोल
स्टूडेंट्स वन है। यानी कि एक अटेम्प्ट तो
हुआ है। तो एक हुआ है। टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट तो
एक हुआ है। तो एक कर देते हैं।
क्या है? हाउ मेनी टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट्स
हैज़ बीन? जीरो है क्या यार?
ना टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट्स कितने हुए हैं यार?
टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट्स तो यहां पे हुए ही नहीं
है। लेट्स चेक विद द सुपर एडमिन। सुपर
एडमिन रोल। चलिए सुपर एडमिन रोल में देख
लेते हैं भैया। यहां पे कुछ पता चल जाएगा
हमें।
जीरो टेस्ट जीरो मॉड्यूल्स। यहां डैशबोर्ड
में तो पता चलना चाहिए।
मान लो मॉड्यूल्स है यहां पे लेक्चरर
टेस्ट अच्छा अच्छा यहां पर है ना यह यह
रहे यह रहे
स्टूडेंट वन
एक डेटाबेस वाली
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड डेटाबेस अटेम्प्ट
ठीक है मॉड्यूल्स
उसके बाद मैथमेटिक्स लेट्स ओपन द
मैथमेटिक्स
इसमें कोई भी अटेम्प्ट नहीं हुआ है। अह
मैथमेटिक्स में कोई अटेम्प्ट नहीं हुआ है।
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड डेटाबेस में हुआ है।
इसमें भी कोई अटेमप्ट नहीं हुआ है। राइट?
तो यहां पे
एक ही होगा। ऑब्वियस सी बात है।
अच्छा टोटल इन टोटल टोटल कितने हुए हैं
ना? टोटल पूछ रहा है ये। तो टोटल कितने
होंगे? डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड में हमारे कितने
अटेम्प्ट्स हैं टोटल टेस्ट्स के?
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड डेटाबसेस के यहां पर
हमारे टेस्ट हैं।
1 2 3 4
चार हुए हैं। राइट? चार। चार ये हुए हैं।
बाकी किसी में हुए नहीं है। तो चार ही
होंगे यहां पे। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। सो चार
टेस्ट अटेम्प्ट्स हुए हैं टोटल। तो चार
हैं हमारे। ये सही है।
व्हाट इज़ द हाईएस्ट स्कोर ऑफ द स्टूडेंट
वन हैज़ अचीव्ड? तो तीन मैंने देखा था अभी।
थ्री हमने देखा था। थ्री हाईएस्ट स्कोर
है। तो हाईएस्ट स्कोर जो है हम थ्री कर
देते हैं। व्हाट इज द सीक्वेंस ऑफ द
करेक्ट आंसर्स फॉर द डेटाबेस टाइप टेस्ट?
सीक्वेंस क्या है डेटाबेस टाइप टेस्ट का?
तो चलिए
डेटाबेस सॉरी मॉड्यूल्स पे चलते हैं।
डेटाबेस टाइप टेस्ट का सीक्वेंस क्या है
करेक्ट आंसर्स का? तो आंसर्स क्या हैं?
ऊपर दिखेंगे ना आंसर्स। इसमें दिखेंगे
शायद। ये इसमें दिखेगा आंसर।
करेक्ट है यस नो
ठीक है नो
ये तो चलो ये तो आंसर्स वैसे हैं यहां से
टेस्ट किए हैं ये एनरोल स्टूडेंट्स ये रहा
बंदा स्टूडेंट जो है यहां पे तीन इसने सही
मिले यस नो
नो यस नो नो वाई एन एन वाई एन एन ये
सीक्वेंस है सो सीक्वेंस इज़ वाई एन एन सही
है।
आई थिंक सही होना चाहिए। बिल्कुल सही है।
करेक्ट राइट? y एंड एन हमारा सही है। एंड
जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस। जस्ट अ सेकंड अ जस्ट अ
सेकंड।
मुझे एक सेशन शुरू करना है। सो लेट मी
स्टार्ट द सेशन फर्स्ट।
ओके चलिए एक सेशन स्टार्ट करना था। आई
स्टार्टेड दैट सेशन। सॉरी फॉर द ट्रबल।
चलिए।
अभी यह क्या हुआ?
एक वो एक मतलब इंटर्नशिप के एग्जाम का
सेशन था। तो उसको स्टार्ट करना था।
ओके। सो यहां पे सारे आंसर सही है। एक
हमारा जो क्वेश्चन है व्हाट इज द यूजर ऑफ
द स्टूडेंट विद द नेम x? नेम एक्स वाली जो
है ना ये आनी जरूरी है। इसको हमें
छेड़छाड़ करना पड़ेगा। तभी ये नेम x आएगा।
ऐसे आएगा नहीं ये। तो स्टूडेंट्स पे
जाएंगे। यहां पे हमारे पास इस रोल के साथ
ये स्टूडेंट की लिस्ट x वाली तो हमें सुपर
एडमिन से मिल नहीं रही है। ठीक है? सुपर
एडमिन वाली मिल नहीं रही है। दूसरा यूजर
रोल कोई और है नहीं। चलो एडमिन रोल देख
लेते हैं। आई डोंट थिंक एडमिन रोल
एक्सिस्ट करता है। बट स्टिल लेट्स ट्राई
टोटल इसमें एडमिन रोल में आ रहा है। टोटल
लेक्चरर्स वन टेस्ट मॉड्यूल्स तीन टोटल
स्टूडेंट्स चार टोटल टेस्ट टू। क्या बात
है? तो यहां पे स्टूडेंट्स लिस्ट में
देखते हैं। इफ वी आर गेटिंग दैट। नो वी आर
नॉट गेटिंग दैट दैट x वाला। चलो इसमें वो
तो आ रही है। तो लोकल स्टोरेज में अब हम
यूजर रोल एडमिन ही रहने देते हैं। एंड
आईडी को लेट्स चेंज द आईडी टू वन।
सो लेट्स चेक द स्टूडेंट्स नेम। आईडी पे
कुछ खास असर पड़ नहीं रहा हमें। सो यहां
पे अब हम कर देते हैं यूजर रोल वन। तो
हटाओ
नेम एक्स तो हमारे पास है ही आईडी को हम
वन से 10 कर देते हैं।
लेट्स रीलोड
स्टूडेंट्स
इट्स नॉट कमिंग। इट्स नॉट कमिंग। ऐसे तो
ये आ नहीं रहा है। तो एक बार ना हम इसके
देखते हैं रूल्स के लिए। सो लेट्स गो टू द
नेटवर्क टैब। लेट्स गो टू दिस प्रोफाइल।
फुल नेम यहां पर x हो रखा है। आपको यहां
पर फुल नेम x हो रखा है बेसिकली इसी का
क्योंकि हमने वहां पे एक्स कर दिया था तो
ये x हो रखा है। चलिए अच्छी बात है। तो हम
यहां पे अपडेट कर देते हैं। यूजरनेम पूछ
रही है तो यूजरनेम यहां तो हमें देना नहीं
है ना भाई। तो यहां पे हम देख लेते हैं एक
बार नेटवर्किंग टैब में। कुछ और भी यहां
पर अगर कुछ
हमारे पास रोल्स या कुछ और है तो
सुपर एडमिन डैशबोर्ड ठीक है। सुपर एडमिन
एक है। लेक्चरर है एक। ठीक है। अ
सुपर एडमिन लेक्चरर देन देयर आर अदर
ओके सुपर एडमिन स्टूडेंट्स स्टूडेंट्स।
ठीक है? सुपर एडमिन।
टेस्ट भी है एक टेस्ट टेस्ट। चलिए टेस्ट
वाली भी टेस्ट कर लेते हैं। स्टोरेज पर
चलते हैं। लोकल स्टोरेज पर चलते हैं। एंड
टेस्ट
टेस्ट वाली रोल पे चेक करते हैं। व्हाट इज
द थिंग वी आर गेटिंग स्टूडेंट्स एंड नो।
तो यहां पे हमें टेस्ट वाले में भी कुछ
हमें यहां तो खास मिल नहीं रहा है।
स्टूडेंट स्टूडेंट के अलावा
वी आर नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग।
नहीं टेस्ट वाले पर तो हमें नहीं मिल रहा।
वी आर नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग ऑन टेस्ट बट वी
कैन सी
अ एक काम और कर सकते हैं।
लेट्स सी एक काम करते हैं हम यहां पे।
इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं। इसको हम लॉग आउट
कर देते हैं। ठीक है? हमने लॉग आउट कर
दिया। सारी इनवैलिडेट कर दिया। हमने यहां
पे फिर से अना अटैकर एंड क्यू डब्ल्यू ई
आर टी वाई करके लॉग इन करते हैं।
ठीक है? यहां पे लॉग इन कर चुके हैं हम।
यहां पे नाउ वी आर गोइंग टू चेक द मोर
टूल्स। अगेन मैं वापस से रिपीट कर रहा हूं
चीजों को। लोकल स्टोरेज पर चलते हैं। यहां
पर चलते हैं। यहां जो स्टूडेंट है इसको
मैं कर देता हूं।
सुप लेक्चरर
मैं यहां पर लेक्चरर कर देता हूं एंड
लेट्स चेक लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज़ समथिंग वी
आर गेटिंग। सो हियर स्टूडेंट्स ले चलते
हैं। एंड वी आर नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग। ठीक
है?
सारी चीजें सेम रहने देते हैं। यहां पे कर
देते हैं टेस्ट।
टेस्ट पे रीलोड करते हैं।
लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज स्टूडेंट टेस्ट के
नाम पर भी नहीं है हमारे पास कुछ नहीं
मिला है। टेस्ट टेस्ट करते हैं। लेट्स सी
टेस्ट के नाम पे क्या मिलता है। लेट्स सी
देखते हैं यार देखते हैं।
तभी तो मजा आएगा। अभी तो देखो टेस्ट में
भी नहीं है हमारे पास। इसको हम यहां पे कर
देते हैं एडमिन रोल के लिए।
लेट्स चेक द एडमिन रोल।
लेट्स चेक फॉर द एडमिन रोल। सो स्टूडेंट्स
लेट्स सी देयर इज़ सम एक्स नहीं एडमिन रोल
के लिए भी नहीं है। लेट्स चेक फॉर सुपर
एडमिन।
सुपर
एडमिन रोल।
लेट्स चेक आउट द सुपर एडमिन रोल।
सुपर एडमिन रोल में भी नहीं है भैया हमारे
यह। तो अब हमारा बच जाता है स्टूडेंट रोल।
स्टूडेंट में स्टूडेंट तो दिखेंगे नहीं
हमारे भैया। राइट? स्टूडेंट में स्टूडेंट
कहां से दिखेंगे? नहीं दिखेंगे। तो यहां
पे रोल लेक्चरर ही रहने देते हैं क्योंकि
लेक्चरर को तो स्टूडेंट्स दिखने चाहिए ना।
सिंपल सा फंडा है। लेक्चरर को स्टूडेंट
दिखेंगे। कोई भी स्टूडेंट होगा लेक्चरर को
देख दिखेगा। तो मैंने यहां पे लेक्चरर
रहने दिया। एंड यहां पे मैंने
स्टूडेंट लिस्ट देखा। इसमें नहीं है। अब
मैं यहां पे क्या करता हूं?
चलो ठीक है। यूजर रोल रिमूव कर दें। इससे
क्या होगा? चलो यूजर रोल रिमूव करके देख
लेते हैं। इफ देयर इज़ समथिंग वी आर गेटिंग
गायब। बिल्कुल गायब।
बिल्कुल गायब। यूजर रिमूव करोगे तो गायब
ही हो जाएगा। चलो यहां पर अब अगेन लॉग इन
करते हैं।
यूजर रोल तो हम लेक्चरर ही रहने देते हैं।
लेकिन लेक्चरर को तो दिखेगी। अब यहां पर
ना सिंपल सा हम यूजर नेम जो है ना अनटैकर
जो है इसको तो हम रहने देते हैं।
ईमेल आईडी भी रहने देते हैं। आईडी जो है
एट
लेट्स डू वन थिंग।
8 को 10 किया
रीलोड किया
स्टूडेंट्स
नहीं नॉट कमिंग व्हाट इफ वी डू हियर नाइन
न किया
तो यह भी शायद ना हो
8 9 10 तीनों चेक हो गए हमारे। अब यहां पर
3 4 5 है।
सिक्स बचा है हमारा। सो लेट्स ट्राई फॉर द
सिक्स।
लेट्स ट्राई फॉर द सिक्स।
सिक्स भी नहीं है। 3 4 5 हो गए। टू एंड
वन। लेट्स ट्राई फॉर वन एंड टू।
इसमें करते हैं
लेट्स ट्राई फॉर
वन टू
टू पे ट्राई करते हैं। वन तो आई थिंक हमने
पहले चेक किया हुआ था। लेट्स ट्राई टू टू
और टू पे भी ये नहीं है। लेट्स ट्राई फॉर
वन।
लेट्स ट्राई फॉर वन।
ओके। सो वन पे भी यह नहीं है। अब एक काम
करते हैं।
यहां यूजर यूजर रोल लेक्चरर तो रहने देते
हैं। हम चलते हैं नेटवर्क टैब पे।
लेट्स सी द
रिक्वेस्ट। सो ये स्टूडेंट है। दैट्स नॉट
ऑफ आवर यूज़। हमारे काम का नहीं है ये। 200
यहां पे यह भी कोई हमारे काम का नहीं है।
लेट्स फाइंड इफ देयर इज़ सम अदर क्रिएट
स्टूडेंट्स। क्रिएट स्टूडेंट हमारे काम का
नहीं है। अ 200
सो यहां पे सिर्फ 200 वाले पहले ऊपर ले
लेते हैं। जो जो हमारे 200 स्टेटस कोड्स
हैं। सबसे पहले उनको ऊपर ले लेते हैं।
सो सो प्राइम रिएक्ट प्राइम रिएक्ट ठीक है
चक्स चक्स ऐसा कुछ यूज़फुल तो नहीं लग रहा
मुझे
प्राइम रिएक्ट प्राइम ठीक है
लेक्चरर स्टैट्स लेक्चरर स्टैट्स लेक्चरर
नहीं चाहिए मॉड्यूल्स मॉड्यूल्स भी नहीं
चाहिए अ टेस्ट्स एक टेस्ट्स करके है
टेस्ट्स ठीक है
ओके स्लश टेस्ट रखते हैं मॉड्यूल
स्टूडेंट्स स्टूडेंट्स ओके देयर इज अ
क्लाइंट
वेट वेट क्लाइंट
ओके इट्स नॉट मॉडिफाइड ठीक है
रजिस्ट्रेशन
लॉगिन लॉगिन है लॉगिन ठीक है लॉग इन टेस्ट
टेस्ट मॉड्यूल फॉर्म रूट सफलिंग ठीक है
वेरिफिकेशन कोड यूजर प्रोफाइल
ओके इंडेक्स कौन सुपर एडमिन डैशबोर्ड सुपर
एडमिन डैशबोर्ड
यह एक है सुपर एडमिन डैशबोर्ड भी है ओके
चलो एक बार सुपर एडमिन डैशबोर्ड पे भी देख
लेंगे सुपर एडमिन बट रोल के लिए तो है
नहीं ना रोल तो सुपर एडमिन का ही है सिंपल
यूजर टेस्ट
ठीक है। लेट्स गो टू द स्टोरेज।
लेट्स गो। हां। नमस्ते सर। मैंने साइबर
मैंने साइबर क्विट कर दी थी और बैक एंड
डेवलपमेंट पर शिफ्ट हो गया था और मैं
थोड़ा एडवांस भी साइबर में कुछ नहीं बोला
था। हां रखो रखो। कंटिन्यू रखो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है। कंटिन्यू रखो कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है।
ठीक है।
क्या हुआ?
ठीक है। यहां पर अब हम करते हैं। एक काम
करते हैं। यहां पर हम करते हैं सुपर एडमिन
एंड आईडी में हम दे देते हैं
वन। तो हम चेक कर लेते हैं। एक बार चेक
करते हैं सुपर एडमिन में वन पे क्या है?
स्टूडेंट
वन पे नहीं आ रहा। सुपर एडमिन
आईडी इज टू इफ देयर इज टू
स्टूडेंट्स में
टू पे भी नहीं है। थ्री पे तो खैर है ही
नहीं क्योंकि थ्री ऑलरेडी है। 4 5 6
सुपर एडमिन सिक्स पे देख लेते हैं।
लेट्स चेक क्लशिक टेस्ट भी है एक तो उस भी
हम देख सकते हैं।
नहीं है इसमें
सेवन
लेट्स चेक ऑन सेवन
कोई बात नहीं ऋषि कोई बात नहीं
अरे यूजरनेम स्टूडेंट एक्स क्या होता है
क्यों करेगा कोई यूजरनेम स्टूडेंट एक्स
इसका यूजर स्टूडेंट नेम तो
वो होगा ना स्टूडेंट एक्स चलो ठीक है करके
देख लेंगे अभी
7 8 9 एंड 10
तो एक बार 10 कर लेते हैं 10 आईडी चलो
इसके बाद स्टूडेंट एक्स करके भी देख लेंगे
अगर एक्स नाम से है तो स्टूडेंट एक्स कर
लेंगे सो इफ देयर इज समथिंग तो तो हम
लेक्चरर के लिए भी कर सकते सुपर एडमिन की
जरूरत भी नहीं है क्योंकि लेक्चरर को
स्टूडेंट का तो पता ही होगा ना लेक्चरर
ठीक है लेक्चरर करते हैं एंड आईडी में जो
भी है यूजरनेम में हम कर देते हैं
स्टूडेंट
स्टूडेंट एक्स
नहीं यूजर नेम में नहीं यार
नेम में करते हैं स्टूडेंट एक्स क्योंकि
यूजर नेम तो हमें फाइंड ही करना है ना।
[संगीत]
नहीं ऐसा कुछ नहीं है।
इज ऑथेंटिकेटेड
फॉल्स
यहां पर ऑथेंटिकेशन फॉल्स कर देते हैं एक
बार।
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग। इट्स लॉक्ड
आउट। ठीक है? अब इसको करते हैं एना टैकर
एंड यहां पर क्व ठीक है? लेट्स लॉग इन
अगेन।
यूजर नेम
अटैकर जो है ना
चलो इसको भी टेस्ट कर लेते हैं।
लेक्चरर देते हैं।
रीलोड करते हैं। लेट्स सी
हम नोप्स नोप्स। चलो इसका सिंपल यहां पे
फंडा है। लेक्चरर है। यहां पे ईमेल एंड ये
यूजर रोल्स जो भी है यहां पे दिख रहे हैं
आपको।
पूरी रोल हटा देते हैं एक बार। लेट्स
ट्राई अगेन इट्स लॉक्ड आउट। एंड अटैकर एंड
यूजरनेम एक्स चाहिए हमें भाई। वी नीड टू
एक्स।
वी नीड टू इनमरेट थोड़ा इन्यूमरेशन करना
पड़ेगा।
नहीं नेम देखो नेम वहां पे रहने से कुछ
नहीं है। यहां पे जो स्टूडेंट नेम है जैसे
मान लो तुम्हारा लेक्चरर है ना और मैंने
रीलोड कर दिया। ठीक है? यहां पे मैंने
रीलोड किया। अब सी यहां पे मैंने
स्टूडेंट्स पे देखा तो स्टूडेंट के
यूजरनेम्स आ रहे हैं और नेम्स आ रहे हैं।
तो यहां पे स्टूडेंट 1 2 3 आ रहा है। और
हमारा जो क्वेश्चन है व्हाट इज द यूजरनेम
ऑफ़ द स्टूडेंट विद नेम x? ये नेम x है। अब
यहां पे ये क्या हिंट भी नहीं दे रहे हैं।
तो मैं यहां पे हिंट का एक चीज वो करता
हूं। जस्ट वेट।
वैल्यूस ऑफ कुकीज़ फील्ड
देखते हैं इसका कुछ इसको थोड़ा घुमा के
पूछा है। ऐसे ही कुछ भी पूछ दिया है।
देखते हैं यह क्या बोलता है।
देखते हैं स्टूडेंट्स यूजरनेम
इफ दैट इज द गिविंग
नहीं नहीं प्रोवाइड यह ये तो बेकार है।
पहले का जो हिंट का था ना वो ज्यादा बेटर
होता था। अब यहां पे एक चीज करते हैं।
यहां पे योर आंसर इज़ टू शॉर्ट। प्लीज मेक
श्योर योर आंसर। ठीक है? फॉर्मेट कोई बात
नहीं। यहां पे हम एक चीज करते हैं। लेट्स
इनमरेट अ लॉट। इनमरेट अ बिट। ठीक है? यहां
पर
यूजर की
ईमेल आईडी स्टूडेंट थ्री
अ स्टूडेंट
x@examp.com
ये देते हैं आईडी
आईडी हम नल रखते हैं। आईडी नल रखते हैं।
नेम यहां पे हम एक्स रखते हैं।
एंड यूजरनेम नल रखते हैं। लेट्स कीप द
यूजर नेम नल। हमें जो नहीं पता उसको नल कर
देते हैं। एंड लेट्स चेक नाउ।
इफ वी आर गेटिंग समथिंग समथिंग समथिंग।
ओके। यहां पर कुछ भी नहीं मिला हमें। सो
देयर देयर इज समथिंग दैट वी शुड बी डूइंग
नाउ। सो यहां रीलोड करने पे हमें कोई भी
आउटपुट नहीं मिल रहा। वी आर गेटिंग ब्लैंक
पेज। दैट्स गुड। सो अब हम यहां पे
एग्जांपल.com ईमेल जो है उसको हटा देते
हैं।
इसको हम ब्लैंक नल कर देते हैं।
नल नेम इज एक्स रोल इज रोल भी हम डिफाइन
नहीं करेंगे। रोल हम कैसे डिफाइन कर दें?
रोल भी हम नल कर देते हैं। सर नेम नल,
यूजर नेम नल। नेम बस एक्स रखते हैं। बाकी
सब नल नल कर देते हैं। एंड देन रीलोड
लेक्चरर के लिए है। सो स्टूडेंट पे चलते
हैं। एंड हियर वी शुड बी गेटिंग सम बट
यहां अभी कुछ नहीं है। ठीक है? तो यहां पर
अब कर देते हैं सुपर एडमिन। सुपर एडमिन।
लेट्स रीलोड इट।
आईडी को 10 करके देखें।
आईडी को 10 करते हैं। लेट्स रीलोड अगेन।
अरे रुको यार तुम लोग कुछ भी बोल रहे हो।
मतलब उससे क्या होगा यह बताओ मुझे। उससे
कुछ नहीं होगा यार। आईडी को
11 करते हैं।
नप्स न्स न्स न्स
यहां पे टेस्ट्स एक देखते हैं रीलोड करके
इफ देयर इज समथिंग कमिंग ऑन टेस्ट
स्टूडेंट्स तो आ रहे हैं इसमें भी
यह कोई रोल तो नहीं है सुपर एडमिन
डैशबोर्ड तो क्या ही रोल है कोई रोल नहीं
है ऐसा बट स्टिल वी आर जस्ट गिविंग इट अ
ट्राई रोल इज तो रोल बस रोल ही है बस जो
है
तो एक काम करते हैं एक काम करते हैं इसको
लॉग आउट करते हैं पहले तो
लेट्स लॉग आउट एंड देन गो टू द नेटवर्क
टैब
[संगीत]
नेटवर्क पे चलते हैं। यहां पे करते हैं अ
एन अटैकर।
एक और ट्राई करते हैं।
लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज़ समथिंग
स्टूडेंट्स लॉगउ
लॉग इन
एट व्हाट इज दिस एट? एट क्या है यह?
ग्रेड्स। ठीक है? ग्रेड्स क्लाइंट। व्हाट
इज दिस क्लाइंट?
वाइट क्लाइंट। वाइट क्लाइंट ये क्या है?
अच्छा 304 है। अ
स्टूडेंट
सर ईमेल नल करो। आईडी 11 एंड रोल दो करो।
एंड सर नेम नल चलो लेक्चर करो यह ट्राई
करो सर अरे नहीं इससे नहीं होगा यह जो यह
तो तुक्का वाला हो गया तो उससे होगा नहीं
बट वो लेक्चरर ठीक है देख लेते हैं
लेक्चरर जो है टीएस एक्स हमारे हैं भैया
जी लेक्चरर जी
सुपर एडमिन लेक्चरर डैशबोर्ड डिलीट
कन्फर्मेशन क्वेश्चन
यह क्या है एक
टेस्ट इंट्रो
ये क्या है? टेस्ट्स
अच्छा टेस्ट की है ये। सिंगल सेलेक्टिंग
टगल
ट्रेवल टेस्ट चैट्स मॉड्यूल टेस्ट
डैशबोर्ड एग्जिस
ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट। सो यहां पे देखो
लेक्चररी होगा तो लेक्चररी होगा। ये तो
श्योर है। अ इसको चेंज करने की जरूरत नहीं
पड़ेगी शायद। लेट्स सी
मैं यहां पे एक काम करता हूं। लेट्स टेक द
एल कैपिटल लेक्चरर।
देखते हैं।
स्टूडेंट्स
नॉट कमिंग।
लेट इसका हिंट ले लेते हैं। एक बार
इसका एक बार हिंट ले लेते हैं।
अरे ये क्या हो गया?
अरे यार मैंने क्लोज कर दिया क्या ये? कोई
बात नहीं, कोई बात नहीं। चलो लेट्स टेक द
हिंट। यहां पे व्हाट इज़ यूजर नेम?
स्टूडेंट एक्स?
ओके
यूजर यूजर नेम ऑफ स्टूडेंट एक्स ट्राई है
कुछ तो गड़बड़ है। आई थिंक वी आर डूइंग
गुड। हम सही कर रहे हैं। जहां तक मुझे लग
रहा है वी आर डूइंग अब्सोलुटली करेक्ट। बट
कुछ गड़बड़ तो मुझे लग रहा है। कुछ तो
गड़बड़ है दया।
नहीं मुझे कुछ गड़बड़ लग रही है। मुझे लग
रहा है वी आर डूइंग करेक्ट लेक्चरर का और
देख लेते हैं।
यहां तो सीधा
सीधा यहां पे आ गया। का आंसर दे दिया।
टीएचएम गॉट द यूजर। यह तो आंसर दे दिया इस
इसने। आंसर नहीं चाहिए ना। वी डोंट वांट
वंस आंसर्स। आंसर तो ऐसे कोई भी दे देगा।
यहां पे है। फर्स्ट रजिस्टर ऑन द वेबसाइट
एज़ अ स्टूडेंट। एंड व्हेन यू गो थ्रू द
नेटवर्क कनेक्शन यू कैन नोटिस दैट देयर इज़
सुपर एडमिन फ्रॉम द रिक्वेस्ट सेंड टू द
सर्वर। वी विल एस्केलेट द प्रिविलेज टू
सुपर एडमिन एंड गेट द आंसर। चेंज द वैल्यू
यूजर रोल टू सुपर एडमिन एंड रिफ्रेश द
पेज। ठीक है?
यह तो वही चीज है यार। यूजर रोल को चेंज
कर दिया सुपर एडमिन से यूजर रोल को। तो
क्या हो गया इसमें? यह तो हम भी कर रहे
हैं सुपर एडमिन।
वी आर ऑलरेडी डूइंग द सुपर एडमिन थिंग।
अच्छा हमारा वह खत्म हो गया क्या?
ओके सो लेट्स ओपन दिस
एन अटैकर एंड यहां पे एक क्वाटी कर देते
हैं।
ये क्या खुल गया यार ये?
चलो यहां पे कर लिया हमने। अब यहां पर ओपन
कर लेते हैं
मोर टूल्स पे। लेट्स गो टू वेब डेवलपर
टूल्स।
लेट्स गो टू द लोकल इंडेक्स देयर।
एंड एक काम करते हैं।
सेशन कुछ होगा नहीं। यहां पे स्टूडेंट को
कर देते हैं। सुपर एडमिन।
सुपर एडमिन का रोल दे दिया हमने। रीलोड कर
लेते हैं।
लेट्स सी इफ देयर आर स्टूडेंट्स दोज़
यहां पे भी हमारे पास वो तो नहीं आ रहा।
वो तो नहीं आ पा रहा।
ठीक है। कोई बात नहीं। यहां से एक काम
करते हैं।
इसको खुद भी शायद ना पता हो।
चलो इधर देख लेते हैं एक बार।
इससे नहीं होगा यार। इससे नहीं होगा। मैं
अभी बता रहा हूं। अभी जस्ट वेट।
डू वन थिंग
एक काम करते हैं। इसको यहां से हटा देते
हैं।
इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं। मतलब
टर्मिनेट मशीन टर्मिनेट कर दिया।
यह वाला तो चल रहा है अपना।
ठीक है?
अब इसको ना मेन सिस्टम पर ले आते हैं।
वो ऐड करते हैं। वीपीएस
सॉरी ओपन वीपीए से कनेक्ट करते हैं।
ठीक है? सो लेट्स कनेक्ट टू द ओपन वीपीए।
कनेक्ट करते हैं।
ओके।
या इट्स इट्स कनेक्टेड रिफ्रेश कर देते
हैं यहां पर यहां पर वैल्यू आ जानी चाहिए
नहीं आ रही है
इनका कुछ प्रॉब्लम है कुछ तो प्रॉब्लम है
अभी ये ओपन वीपीए कनेक्ट है बट फिर भी
यहां वैल्यू नहीं आ रही है बट यह ओपन हो
जाएगी मुझे लगता है देखना देखते हैं लेट्स
कॉपी द आईपी लेट्स एक्सेस थ्रू दिस
पर्टिकुलर पोर्टल हम अपने मेन सिस्टम पे
एक्सेस करते हैं इसको देखो चल रहा है
इट्स हैपनिंग चैलिंग
ये ओपन हो रहा है मतलब
तो ये मे बी हो सकता है एक एक ग्लिच होगी
एक टेंपरेरी ग्लिच होगी किसी रीजन की वजह
से इस वजह से हमारा वो स्टूडेंट पॉपुलेट
नहीं हो रहा अदरवाइज इट्स द नॉर्मल सीन
यहां पे मैं एन अटैकर यूज़ कर रहा हूं एंड
पासवर्ड सेम यूज कर रहा हूं
आई एम लॉगिन। तो मैं लॉगिन हो चुका हूं
यहां पे। मैं यहां पे अपना मोर टूल्स पे
जाके डेवलपर टूल्स ओपन कर देता हूं।
नेटवर्क पे चलते हैं।
मैं रीलोड करता हूं यहां पे।
सो इट्स डन। तो यहां पर मेरे पास कोई भी
सुपर एडमिन की कोई चीज आ गई है क्या? ऑथts
ओथ क्या है भाई?
ओके एपीआई ऑथ ठीक है।
दिस इज़ नॉट
अ सुपर सुपर एडमिन सुपर सुपर एडमिन सुपर
एडमिन डैशबोर्ड ये रहा।
नॉट मॉडिफाइड रजिस्टर सिस्टम यहां पे ठीक
है रेफरल ये है हमारे ये वाले हमारे हैं
रेफरल इसमें चलते हैं अ सुपर एडमिन
डैशबोर्ड का ये रेफरल लिंक है
JS1 B64
[संगीत]
ठीक है
लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज समथिंग
हम जेस जी एक्स टेक्स
ऐसे कुछ तो यहां नहीं है। यहां पे चलते
हैं।
यहां पे भी हो जा रही है। बर्फ की क्या
जरूरत है?
यहां पे जब हमारा हो ही जा रहा तो अवॉइड द
नीड ऑफ़ बर्फ।
यूजर स्टूडेंट है यहां पे
यूजर रोल
एडमिन यूजर रोल डॉट एडमिन यूजर रोल डॉट
स्टूडेंट
यूजर लोड डॉट लेक्चरर
ओके सो एडमिन लेक्चरर एंड स्टूडेंट
तीन यहां पे हैं। एडमिन है यहां पे एक एक
रोल यहां पे हमारा एडमिन है। सो लेट्स गो
टू स्टोरेज। लेट्स गो टू लोकल स्टोरेज
हियर। लेट्स गो टू द एडमिन रोल। सिर्फ
एडमिन रोल करते हैं। रीलोड करते हैं। इसको
थोड़ा छोटा कर लेते हैं।
देखो तो स्टूडेंट्स
लेक्चरर
और एक सुपर एडमिन का भी देख लेंगे।
लेक्चरर भी देख लेते हैं इफ यू आर गेटिंग
मॉड्यूल्स स्टूडेंट्स
नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग
लेट्स गो टू अ
सुपर एडमिन रोल
लेट्स गो टू द सुपर एडमिन सुपर एडमिन सुपर
एडमिन
सुपर एडमिन में भी नहीं
सो देयर इज कुछ तो गड़बड़ है। आईडी दो यहां
है।
तीन चार पांच यहां है।
तो
और एक आईडी पे तो यह चली गई। इस इसमें तो
इसमें हिंट में भी है कि एक आईडी से कुछ
नहीं हो रहा नीचे वाले पर।
यूजर वैल्यू
सेम हाउवर देयर आर मोर वैल्यूस टू प्ले
विद हियर सच एज आवर आईडी एंड यूजरनेम आईडी
एंड यूजरनेम का वैल्यू है यहां पे सो
यूजरनेम मस्ट बी यह लेक्चरर रहने देते हैं
लेक्चरर ही रहने देते हैं इसको आईडी एंड
यूजरनेम यहां पे जो हिंट दिया है उस पे
उसके ऊपर ही जाते हैं। हिंट के ऊपर में
यहां पर है कि सच एज आवर आईडी एंड यूजरनेम
आईडी एंड यूजरनेम के साथ चेंज करना है।
सो आईडी
यूजरनेम
स्टूडेंट एक्स
यह यूजरनेम हो सकता है।
सो पुट इट स्टूडेंट एक्स
एंड लेट्स चेक इफ देयर इज समथिंग
स्टूडेंट एक्स नहीं ये तो उस पर्टिकुलर
स्टूडेंट की यूजर की है ना ये स्टूडेंट की
ये दिखाएगा
स्टूडेंट एक्स नहीं है
आईडी
आईडी 10
आठ तो यहां में नौ और 10 बचे तो नौ और 10
को देख लेते हैं। 10 को देख लिया। उसके नौ
को देख लेंगे एक बार। लेट्स चेक नाइन पे
नहीं है ये।
10 पे नहीं है। सो लेट्स चेक ऑन द नाइन
आईडी नाइन। स्टूडेंट एक्स तो रहने देते
हैं। लेक्चर ही रहने देते हैं।
idडी 11 के पीछे क्यों पड़े हो भाई?
तुम्हें आईडी 11 कैसे पता है?
आई एम नॉट गेटिंग दिस।
चलो आईडी 11 कर देते हैं।
लेट्स ट्राई ऑन आईडी 11।
कुछ नहीं मिल रहा।
[संगीत]
यूजर नेम
अटैकर ही रहने देते हैं। बाकी सब सेम है
जैसा यू सेड। एंड आईडी
सिर्फ 11 है। लेट्स सी कुछ नहीं है। यह
कुछ भी ऐसे ही कुछ भी बोल रहे हो। कोई बात
नहीं, कोई बात नहीं, कोई बात नहीं।
देखो यहां पर
लेक्चरर होगी। यह तो सही है। लेक्चरर इज
गुड। रही बात आगे की तो आगे हम देखते हैं
ईमेल आईडी नल है। आईडी 11 है। गिव टू आईडी
12 एंड यूजरनेम रहने देते हैं।
ओके लेट्स सी।
हम
ओके सो इसको इसको देखो इसके रोल में कुछ
प्रॉब्लम है क्योंकि हम जो रोल के लिए
डिफाइन कर रहे हैं जो भी यूजर रोल जैसे
अभी यूजर रोल हमारे पास जितने हैं लेक्चरर
हैं हमारे पास यूजर रोल अ एडमिन है हमारे
पास यूजर रोल
स्टूडेंट है हमारे पास यूजर रोल लेक्चरर
है। ये कुछ यूजर रोल है। नहीं एक और यूजर
रोल है क्या? अ
नहीं
और तो कुछ नहीं है इसमें यूजर रोल में। ये
हमारी मेन यूजर रोल्स थे जिसके लिए हम
यहां पे देख रहे हैं। बट यहां पे सुपर
एडमिन के केस में भी दिस इज़ नॉट ट्रू।
सुपर एडमिन में भी अगर हम बात करें। सो
इट्स नॉट गिविंग द थिंग। एंड यह चीज ना अ
नहीं ये क्या है? टॉपिक इज जस्ट सेशन
मैनेजमेंट। ये क्या है? सुपर एडमिन में भी
ये हमें देने हैं। इसका मतलब है देयर इज़
सम थिंग सम मिस्टेक्स या कुछ ऐसी चीजें हो
रही हैं जो यहां पे अभी काम नहीं कर रही
हैं। शायद इनके साइड से भी हो सकता है। ये
पॉसिबिलिटी है कि इनके साइड से भी हो रहा
हो। ठीक है? इट्स नॉट लाइक दैट कि हमारे
साइड से हो रहा है। मैं यहां पे अगर कुछ
देखूं तो यहां पे कुछ मिल भी नहीं रहा है।
अगर मैं लेक्चर्स देखूं तो यहां पे
लेक्चर्स दो जो हैं वो इसके अंदर कुछ हैं।
कुछ भी नहीं है। डैशबोर्ड में कुछ आपको
मिलेगा नहीं। अटेम्प्ट्स में कुछ मिलेगा
नहीं। टेस्ट में कुछ आपको डेटाबेस एंड
साइंस टेप्स डेटाबेस टेब्स में कुछ नहीं
मिल रही। यहां पे
साइंस टेस्ट में भी कुछ नहीं है।
सो अगर मैं यहां पे सुपर एडमिन की जगह
लेक्चरर डाल दूं। एंड यहां पर मैं चेक
करूं।
स्टूडेंट वन है यहां पे एनरोल्ड स्टूडेंट
स्टूडेंट वन है। स्टूडेंट टू स्टूडेंट
थ्री ये अलग-अलग स्टूडेंट्स हैं। ठीक है?
मॉड्यूल्स में
न्यू मॉड्यूल में
न्यू मॉड्यूल में भी कोई नहीं है।
टेस्ट में साइंस चेंज नो मॉड्यूल अटैच
इससे देख लेते हैं। इससे कुछ है क्या?
नहीं है यहां पे।
ठीक है?
नेम इक्वल टू टेस्ट यूजर नेम इज़ इक्वल टू
टेस्ट। अरे
इससे कुछ नहीं होगा। उससे नहीं होगा कुछ
यार। देखो देखो उससे कुछ नहीं होना है।
उससे जो तुम सोच रहे हो वो चीज नहीं हो
रही है। सो लेट्स गो टू द दिस थिंग एंड
अटैकर प्रोफाइल
यूजरनेम इसका अटैकर है।
और अगर हम हम इसमें ऐसे कर सकते हैं।
यू कैन क्रिएट
यूजरनेम एक्स।
यूजरनेम तो है फुल नेम एक्स। तो फुल नेम
एक्स है इसका। सो लेट्स ट्राई ऑन सम अदर
पैराटर्स। कुछ और पैरामीटर देखते हैं।
देखो, यह प्रॉब्लम इसका है। यह प्रॉब्लम
इसके इसमें है। यहां पे कुछ प्रॉब्लम्स
हैं जिसकी वजह से ये आ नहीं पा रही है।
अदरवाइज यह हमारा जो सेम चीज है, सेम चीज।
मान लो मैं यहां पे एक काम करते हैं। चलो
स्टोरेज करते हैं। एंड यहां पे डिलीट ऑल
कर देते हैं।
कुकीज़ में यहां पर चलते हैं। डिलीट ऑल
सेशन कुकीज़।
ऑल गॉट हियर रीलोड हियर ये लॉग आउट हो
जाना चाहिए
हम लॉग आउट हो गया यहां पे अब यहां पे हम
क्या करते हैं लेट्स क्रिएट अनदर यूजर
साइन अप करते हैं रजिस्टर एज लेक्चरर कर
देते हैं यहां पे हम रजिस्टर एज लेक्चरर
करके देखते हैं लेट्स सी मतलब सेम एज
स्टूडेंट नहीं करते रजिस्टर एज लेक्चरर
करते हैं हम उस टाइम में जैसे कर रहे
वेरिफिकेशन कोड यहां पे एक पूछ रहा है। तो
मैं यहां पर दे देता हूं नेम
ले ले यूजरनेम
टेस्टिंग वेरिफिकेशन कोड अभी वेरिफिकेशन
कोड
पांच पासवर्ड में
ओके इट्स नीड वेरिफिकेशन कोड
टेस्ट
टेस्टिंग
खैर वो तो अब एक काम करते हैं। एक बार
यहां पे दे देते हैं। हेलो यहां पे दे
देते हैं नेम में हेलो यूजरनेम में हेलो
वन टू थ्री एंड पासवर्ड हम दे देते हैं।
और अब देखते हैं एक बार हेलो वन टू थ्री
एंड पासवर्ड। ठीक है? तो हेलो 1 2 3 एंड
पासवर्ड इज पासवर्ड। लेट्स लॉग इन एंड
लेट्स ट्राई दिस टाइम। तो यहां पे हेलो
आया। ठीक है? परफेक्ट। यहां पे टेस्ट में
चलते हैं। ठीक है? मॉड्यूल्स में चलते
हैं। ठीक है? अब यहां पे लोकल
कहां गया? स्टोरेज। लोकल स्टोरेज में यह
रहा स्टूडेंट।
ठीक है? सो हियर वी आर गोइंग फॉर द एडमिन
रोल। नहीं यहां पर हम चलते हैं।
सुपर एडमिन रोल में एंड लेट्स ट्राई टू
रीलोड दिस सुपर एडमिन रोल। तो हमने रीलोड
किया यहां पर स्टूडेंट्स पे चलते हैं।
यहां पे एन अटैकर एंड हेलो ये आ गए दोनों।
चलो गुड। सुपर एडमिन में दोनों आ रहे हैं।
नाउ लेट्स चेंज टू
लेक्चरर एलईसीटी यू आर हियर ले लेक्चरर
रोल। लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज़ समथिंग
ऑल यूज़र्स आर शोन ऑ नॉट। तो यहां पे शो
नहीं हो रहे हैं। यहां पे कुछ इशू है ये
इस वजह से। बाकी देखो बाकी आ रहे हैं।
न्यू अकाउंट करके हमने करा सब कुछ करा। तो
बाकी जो हमारे पास डिटेल्स हैं, बाकी
यूज़र्स हैं वो सारे आ रहे हैं। बट हमारा
जो रोल है ना वो जो मेन वो वाला है वो
नहीं आ रहा। रोल में x लिखने से कुछ नहीं
होगा। रोल इज़ टू दैट इज़ अ डिफरेंट थिंग।
रोल में x लिख के कुछ नहीं होगा। तो यहां
पे हमारा लेक्चरर में ये चीज़ आ नहीं रही
है। अब मान लो यूजर नेम जो पूछ रहा था।
मान लो यहां पे मैंने नेम में हेलो डाला
है। यहां पे
यहां पे हेलो डाला है। ठीक है? अब ये बोल
रहा है स्टूडेंट विद नेम एक्स। तो मैं
यहां पे नेम
स्टूडेंट
एक्स लिख देता हूं। ठीक है? मैंने लिख
दिया स्टूडेंट एक्स में यहां पर नेम में
स्टूडेंट एक्स आईडी तो जो भी है वह रहने
दो।
लेक्चरर ही रहने देते हैं। देखते हैं लोड
करके इफ देयर इज समथिंग। बट इससे
कुछ खास फर्क तो पड़ना नहीं चाहिए। ठीक है
ना? क्योंकि इसको तो हम वहां से चेंज कर
रहे हैं। सो इट्स नॉट गिविंग एनीथिंग एनी
रिजल्ट। यहां पे हम पास्ट वैल्यू में
देखें तो यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं हो रहा। नेम
रोल हो रहा है। ठीक है? अब एक काम करते
हैं। यहां पे ईमेल आईडी आईडी में हम
कुछ नहीं डालते आईडी में।
नल नेम स्टूडेंट्स रोल
नल सर नेम नल यूजर नेम नल
ठीक है इस बार होता है तो ठीक है अदरवाइज
ये कुछ प्रॉब्लम्स हैं इनके
यूजर लेक्चरर ही है यार तो कुछ हो सकता है
इशूज़ होंगे कुछ इनके साइड से इस वजह से
ऐसा हो रहा है हां कुछ इनका साइड से इशू
है अदरवाइज इस तरीके से चीजें नहीं होती
आराम से काम करता है है ना
नहीं यहां पर आईडी का कुछ इशू है ही नहीं
ना। आईडी का कुछ इशू होना नहीं चाहिए। मान
लो मैं आईडी चलो मैं आईडी 11 भी डाल देता
हूं। यहां पे 11 डाल देता हूं। यहां पे
स्टूडेंट एक्स कर देता हूं। बट इससे कुछ
फर्क नहीं पड़ना चाहिए।
चलो मैंने आईडी डाल दिया। मैं यहां पे कुछ
भी नहीं आया। चलो मैं अब यहां पे एक काम
करता हूं। आईडी में मैं यहां पे 11 ही डाल
देता हूं। ठीक है? मतलब या फिर ऐसे कर
देते हैं।
चलो आईडी में नल डाल देता हूं। नेम में
स्टूडेंट एक्स में यहां पे सेम सिंपल एक्स
रख देते हैं। ठीक है? अब ठीक है। नेम एक्स
में देते हैं। यूजर नेम लेक्चर रखते हैं।
ये चीज़ करते हैं। या तो कोई ग्लिच होगी या
ऐसे प्रॉब्लम होगी। ये भी हो सकता है। ये
लास्ट ट्राई करते हैं। उसके बाद वी विल बी
सेटिंग इट डाउन। सो ईमेल नल है। आईडी इज़
नल। नेम इज़ एक्स। रोल इज़ नल, सरनेम नल,
यूजरनेम नल। ठीक है? लेक्चरर यहां पे है।
इसको रीलोड करते हैं। देखते हैं इफ देयर
इज़ समथिंग क्योंकि ये ग्लिच होगा अगर इस
पे भी नहीं हो रहा है तो। ठीक है? अ या सो
देयर इज़ अ ग्लिच। सो मैं यहां पे अब सुपर
एडमिन रोल कर देता हूं। रोल भी मैं चेंज
कर देता हूं। सुपर एडमिन में कर देता हूं।
एंड लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज़ समथिंग वी आर
गेटिंग ऑन सुपर एडमिन। सो स्टूडेंट में
चलते हैं। सुपर एडमिन पे भी हमें कुछ नहीं
मिल रहा है। सो इट्स अ ग्लिच। कंप्लीट
ग्लिच। लेक्चरर टू यहां पे लेक्चरर@
example.com मिल रहा है।
एंड दैट्स इट। सो ये एक ग्लिच है। अ
बेसिकली वी आर डूइंग सेशन मैनेजमेंट
प्रैक्टिकल्स। सो ये ग्लिच है जिसकी वजह
से ये आपका नहीं आ रहा था। अदरवाइज़ जो
चीजें अभी हमने देखी थी सेम प्रोसेस है,
सेम चीजें हैं जो आपको करनी है। सेम चीजें
आपको करके एंड यहां पे आपको इसका आंसर
देना है। आंसर यहां पे वही है टीएचएम गॉट
यूजर करके यहां पे इसका आंसर है। टीएचएम अ
गॉट
दी यूजर। यही इसका आंसर है। तो यह आपका
कंप्लीट हो जाएगा। राइट? सो,
हां हां ठीक है ठीक है यूजर लेक्चर था तो
ये हो गया ये ग्लिच था जिसकी वजह से काफी
टाइम हमारा हुआ है काफी टाइम वेस्ट हुआ है
एक छोटे से ग्लिच की वजह से आप अगर करेंगे
हो सकता है आप पॉसिबबली आपको वो जो जो चीज
है जो यूजर स्टूडेंट है वो मिल जाएगी तो
उसके लिए बेल बेफिक्र रहिए आप एकदम टेंशन
फ्री रहिए एक बार ट्राई कीजिएगा इसको वापस
से प्रैक्टिस कीजिएगा एंड यू विल बी एबल
टू डू मैं इसकी गारंटी देता हूं कुछ ग्लिच
होगा ट्राई हैक का जिसकी की वजह से हमारा
काफी टाइम बट हम उस पे लगे रह लगे रहें।
तो ऐसा भी नहीं लगना है कि आपका टाइम बहुत
ज्यादा वेस्ट हो जाए ग्लिच के चक्कर में।
ठीक है? थैंक यू सो मच। सर आई एम डूइंग बग
क्लासेस एंड इन 25th वीडियो आई हैव अ
क्वेश्चन दैट कि मैं पहले कोर्स पूरे
क्लासेस कंप्लीट करके पूरी नॉलेज ले लूं
या फिर अभी से प्रैक्टिस नहीं ये टॉपिक्स
सेपरेट है। आप इन टॉपिक्स को देख सकते हो
और पहले के टॉपिक्स को अभी कंप्लीट करो।
थैंक्स सर। आप हमारे लिए इतनी मेहनत कर
रहे हैं जो इतना अरे वेलकम वेलकम कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है। आप मस्त मस्ती करते रहो।
एंड हां ठीक है। एंड अगेन नेक्स्ट जाने से
पहले मैं एक बात बोलूंगा कि नेक्स्ट
वीडियो के नेक्स्ट सेशंस में आप सभी
प्रेजेंट हो जाइएगा। मजा आएगा। ऐसे ही
चीजों को एक्सप्लोर करेंगे और बहुत सारी
चीजें करेंगे यार। ऐसे बैठ के लाइव
इंटरेक्ट करने में जो मजा है ना वो और
कहीं भी नहीं है। मैं सच बता रहा हूं। वो
मजा और कहीं नहीं है। तो ये लाइव
इंटरेक्शन के मजे हैं। तो फिर आ जाइएगा।
एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में। अभी आज
के सेशन के लिए बस इतना ही। आप सबका
बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद एंड गुड नाइट। टेक
केयर।
लाइक करते जाना